Six feet social distancing from Candace Owens. We're gonna get
every influencer on social media. Six feet social distancing.
Save lives. What are you, a grandma killer? What? You just don't
like what? And then Tim Tim's all fired up and she's a c-word.
People are going to die if you don't get this vaccine. What about
the gropers who just choose to turn a blind eye to Nick being
gay? Nick Fentes gay Catboy date. Archive footage. I grew up
as a leftist. I was living in Washington State before this. And
in 2017, No. No. He got soul red.
IAN. NO.
NO. How many such cases?
Main story of the day. Erica Kirk.
The Erica Kirk, wife of St. Charlie,
called out Candace Owens today.
Called out Candace Owens publicly,
not by name. Okay. But I've heard I think Candace says that Eric
Erica Kirk will call Candace Owens out by name by Monday. I believe
by content that comes out Monday. That will happen. Okay, give
me a second. Let me change the title. Erica Kirk
calls out Candace's
uh Candace
Owens
Okay, here we go. Hey yo, what the [__] does this
shirt say is being for real?
I don't know. Ag wars.
Okay. This is the Fuentes response from last night.
>> It's like Qanon on steroids.
I feel like this is like the remnant of Qanon.
This is >> Why is he acting like he doesn't know that it's
Q anon, not Qanon?
Q anon.
Like quality assurance. Naan.
What? It seems weird.
She's like Kylo Ren going to that planet
and whoever was behind QAN was like, "Okay, you want to see some
real?" It's like the QAN people were >> never show this
clip to Quean. OH MY GOD, DID HE JUST MAKE A STAR WARS >> You
say, "Dude, Trump lost." And they go, "No, secretly in charge
and Hillary Clinton's at Guantanamo." And it's the same level
of psychosis and it's scary and it's I don't want anything. I'm
really just separating myself out. I'm saying let's draw a hard
line. If you're in the Candace cult, I don't want I want no overlap.
This is I'm not hospitable to that at all. >> So, if you
have a problem with that, go somewhere else. I'm drawing a firm
line in the sand. If you're with that, you have to get out. We
do gatekeeping here
to protect the integrity of the message. That has to be outside
of it. Just like QAon. Just like flat earth. Just like this.
N. Okay.
Now we're talking about some actual hypocrisy. Okay. Do you remember
when he really likes Zirka? I was saying, I don't know, man.
Maybe I'll listen to Zurk about this flat earth stuff. He's been
telling me about the firmament. He did that. He totally swept
for the firm firmament. Okay. Oh, just like flat earth. It's
got to be totally outside. Yeah, it was not totally outside before.
It was not totally out. You were willing to give a little bit
of air time to Zurka on it. Come on. >> Now that was when
he was much smaller. But
funny that he said that. >> This is kuckery. It's stupid
and I'm drawing a line. It's got to go. That's how it is.
So anyway,
>> Apollo Credto sent $20. >> Okay. All right. Okay.
What about the gropers who just choose to turn a blind eye to
Nick being gay? Nick Fentes gay Catboy date archive footage.
Might have to take a look at that at some point. Might have to
take a look. Just how gay? Just how gay is he? Oh my god.
Just how gay is this guy? >> People want to call you. >> Oh.
Oh, he also went after Ian Carol, which was pretty funny. >> But
genuinely, when was the last time >> So, this has to do
with So, Ian Carol is the guy who's supporting Candace's conspiracy
theory. Ian Carol's the guy who's been running down the jets.
Okay. Jets who intersect on flight paths with Erica Kirk a lot
apparently. Thus, making Erica Kirk somebody who's being like
either stalked or a part of the conspiracy in some way to Charlie
Kirk. like they're using these Egyptian jets were flying around
with them, shadowing them, and trying to spy on them. According
to Candace, I think there's essentially nothing to it. I've seen
nobody put it together in any coherent way. It's just one of
those things where she says this, she's asking like a question.
Is it doesn't that seem weird that like they overlap a lot and
then she doesn't do anything else? There's no other work, right?
>> Told her audience to get involved in politics, not just
voting, but taking the helm. >> At this point, I'm convinced
that Ian is an operative.
>> Ian is pro RFK Jr. He said he he defended Eric Prince
repeatedly,
defended the Gaza deal. He's on Joe Rogan with this Cabala bracelet.
You know, you want to know why I think that? It's because I was
talking to him and he was treating me like a robot because I
texted Ian Carol the other day and I said, "You know what, man?
You I said, I defended you."
>> Ian Carol, okay, going take Ian Carol >> Ian is
pro RFK Jr. He said he he defended Eric Prince repeatedly,
defended the Gaza deal. He's on Joe Rogan with this Cabala bracelet.
And you know, you want to know why I think that? It's because
I was talking to him and he was treating me like a robot
because I texted Ian Carol the other day and I said, "You know
what, man? You I said, I defended you." I said when everybody
was calling you um
an operative because of your Cabala bracelet and whatever. I
said I defended you. I said and this is how you repay me. We
disagree and now you call me a Fed. That's that's your go-to.
It's not I disagree with him or I don't understand his position.
It's oh he's a Fed. I said you're a trader. And he just wouldn't
he's like just talking right past me. He's like, "Uh, well, this
isn't about you or me. This is about Charlie and blah blah blah."
I'm like, "No, it's about me because you're calling me a fed
and you're a traitor."
I'll read it to you. These people like, "Something's not right
with these people. I don't know what it is, but something's not
right. I'll read you the conversation.
This is the ball washer that was just on Timcast, right?" Yeah.
Yeah. But he's more of a he was like a Candace Owens ball washer
and then he tried to like monkey branch over to Fentes and Fentes
kind of just was like nah I'm good I'm good with your weird conspiracy
theories. He's the guy who when I first saw him on Candice he
basically was going through court documents about Diddy. He was
going over didd like a diddy
not an indictment but a submitted case. Okay. Like a submitted
civil complaint. I think he was going through the evidence and
he's going through all the names and then he was early lifing
all of them and pointing out that they were that's how that's
my introduction to Ian Carol, okay? Where he went through all
of these all of these legal documents and every name he'd go
and look them up and then he'd look them up like early life on
Wikipedia and be like, "Huh, neighborhood, eh?" Raised in a neighborhood,
eh? And it was a very weird conversation. So I texted him. I
said, "You are a really disloyal person. and I went to bat for
you when people were calling you a fed. Now, because I disagree
with you, you attack my credibility. [__] you. He
texted me. He said, "Watch the video. You're way out over your
skis, man. Blatantly wrong, and it's hurting your credibility
whether I point it out or not."
>> Whether I pointed out, okay, but you you're not attacking
my credibility. You're calling me a fed. Go rewatch your live
stream segment about me. Did you think I wasn't going to respond?
You asked for evidence so I produced it.
I said you are saying has Fuentes flipped disagree all you want
but insinuating I work for Israel or the FBI you are a total
piece of [__] when people were attacking you for
your Cabala bracelet. I called that out as paranoia and said
they were being ridiculous. Now we disagree for the first time
and you immediately jump on bad faith accusation saying I'm controlled
op. You are trash. You agreed with me that can of someone did
me dirty and didn't say anything because you didn't want to offend
her. There was nothing honest about you. And with that being
said, now I actually want to check it out. You're the Israel
guy. You're our guy, bro.
And we are now well into the moment.
Okay, let's be real. How many of you guys watch Community?
Do you guys remember the carney boyfriend that Burda had in community
that like she talked about how cool he was or whatever? That's
who Ian Carol looks like, right?
That's it's like one to one. Hold on. Uh
Brida Carney boyfriend community. Yeah. His name was Blade, wasn't
it? Yeah.
I feel like he looks the same. Let me look it up. >> Nice
shooting. >> That's totally from memory. >> Tough
luck. >> Yeah, that's close. That's close.
There's room in our bed for three bears, right, honey? >> And
and Vinceo Sugar, you're very >> I'm sorry. I see it. Okay.
I just I That was my first read. I feel like there's something
there's something going on there. Okay. Okay. Hold on. You can't
just say nah. They clearly look for me to grab like an 8-year-old
10-year-old TV show and just go I think it's like this guy, this
random guy from a one-off episode.
Shut up. Oh, you guys are actually wrong. Oh, you guys are so
wrong. It's like the same
with TP USA,
>> with Candice,
>> with the Trump government, with everything. You're supposed
to be out ahead of us leading the charge. So, is it milking it
to try to get to the bottom of the whole thing? Everyone else
has gone off to fight it and you are not
>> Ian Carol just slam >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Wait.
Does this guy link to the actual Ian Carol thing? A happy Friday
to you all?
A happy Friday to the world. It's free speech Friday, baby. This
guy makes so much money.
And realistically, he does really awesome stuff. Like, his stream
is just really fun.
I wish I feel like I should actually go watch some of his streams
cuz I've tuned in sometimes and I'm like, "This guy is just doing
Skitzo Sunday like every day." And while I would always have
to go and say like, "Oh, well, this is just funny. We're like
doing some stuff and we're trying to make connections and it
is like not real. It's just like fun. It's just a fun thing,
right?" I think it's like it seems like it would be so fun to
just try to prove things and try to do like really skitso all
over the place. I would have to go, you know, we haven't proven
anything, but this is interesting. We could go in this direction.
It' be It'd be interesting. I think I think it'd be fun. Like
a lot of fun.
I No, not Glaze. I think he's a terrible person. I think he's
a really terrible person who's giving cover to a lot of other
people. But yeah, I like the streams. I appreciate like the the
overall like model of the stream I think is very fun. It feels
like it'd be fun. I get it. I get why people would want to watch
it. See here where he pulls up the Fuentes coverage.
I think this guy's like openly anti-Semitic. Like really not
even debatable. I think there's a lot of room for something like
what he does for other stuff. And I do think it'd be a lot of
fun to do. We got uh I'm not sure if the show is going to take
long time tonight. It might be a little bit more of a compact
um heavy hitting show um unless I get carried away and start
rambling. But uh just to run you through what we're going to
cover tonight before we get into it all. But the scary thing
for me is, is there any buy in unless you're really selling it?
You know what I'm saying? Like, while the content seems fun,
I don't know if you get the buy in that he gets if even if it's
as good, even if it's as compelling. I just don't know if you
get that same buy in if you're not like really into it, if you're
not really trying to sell it to people. Um, Nick Fentes missed
his big shot, missed his big opportunity. Seems to be missing
his moment to shine. Um, and I mean that in a number of ways,
and we're going to get to that. Um, we're going to talk about
stop anti-semitism and the anti-semit of the year competition.
The annual anti-semit of the year competition. Yours truly was
not even included in the competition this year. So, we're going
to have to step our game up for next year, I suppose. Um, there's
been >> I still think Hassan is worse. Okay. I still listen,
Hassan's obviously more anti-Semitic than this. >> Some
crazy new rumors and leaks and developments floating around on
the internet. Everything from people that tend to have sources
and tend to be in the no starting to talk about the fact that
maybe Charlie's body is not actually on the ground yet. Um I
haven't corroborated it but we're going to talk about the sources
that are speaking about it. Uh Tim Pashing
out and it is indicative of the larger divide in the community
in the journalism journalism space and um it's all about Israel
as always and there's some pretty interesting developments about
Israel. For example, there's a new le the dream is real. Okay,
we might get Mecha Charlie. We might get it. We might
Z1000. Okay. >> Coming out of TP USA that alleges that
there was Israeli assets inside of TP USA for a long time and
specifically
Israeli assets vetting new recruits about their allegiance to
Israel under very strange and suspicious circumstances. This
leaker has had multiple accounts banned, multiple accounts taken
down. They've been jumping all over Tik Tok and Instagram. And
you've probably, if you're if you're hip to uh the new platforms
like that, you've probably seen one of these videos floating
around. So, we'll take a look at that. And uh I think we'll probably
wrap it up with a bit of a a bit of a catch up with Candace with
the case and with Cash Patel on the job because thank goodness
the Cash Patel is on the job. The FBI is here folks and Cash
Patel is officially taking matters seriously as always. And so
rest assured that we're going to get some real answers and we're
really going to get to the bottom of things now now that Cash
Patel is on the >> I don't think now that I think about
it, I don't think I covered that on stream, but Candace did say
that she talked to Cash Patel, I believe, which yeah, I does
not inspire confidence. Big shout out to Megan Kelly for putting
Cash Patel on the job.
But let's start at the start with our boy Nick. Nick Fuentes.
Um Nick,
listen. Listen, I'm going to take a lot of heat for this section
of the show. Bring it on. I've been pretty outspoken in my support
of Nick Fentes. I've been pretty um pretty into Nick's rise.
And you know, regardless of disagreements about specific things,
>> he's done a ton of glazing content on Nick. never never
criticisms, just all, "Oh, he's really awesome." >> That
Nick says, "Uh, I'm pretty much generally excited that Nick is
entering the mainstream and the normal conversation." I like
how Nick forces us all to challenge our ideas and forces people
to think more critically about ideas that we didn't even realize
we should be thinking about. I like that his ideas are controversial.
I like that they're complicated and they're backed up by a uh
intense intellect. And I like that he uh has the backstory of
10 years of hard work to make it happen. There's a lot of things
I like about Nick. And obviously the thing that most
there's a lot of things I love about Nick. Okay.
I love I love everybody. Yeah. That even includes Nick. Okay.
There's a lot of things I love about
most of us like the most about Nick is his stance on Israel.
>> Oh, he does look a little bit like Dr. Disrespect. Yeah.
Is his unwavering stance on Israel against all odds across the
years, against censorship, against everything. Right. It's a
real It's a real David versus Goliath story with Nick Quentis
is how it would how it would read. And it's hard not to root
for the guy, you know, being cancelled by Ben Shapiro basically
a decade ago and now triumphantly returning at long last just
that kind of like isn't really remotely provable. Uh Ben basically
retweeted him or quote tweeted him. I don't know that there's
a lot of evidence he was canceled by Ben that far back when he
was 18. I do believe Ben has like had a probably had a behind-the-scenes
like position very similar to Charlie Kirk. I believe they would
have coordinated on that position. I totally get that. But that's
more of like a 20 21-year-old Nick Fuentes
policy, not an 18-year-old Nick Fuentes policy. I think the 18-year-old
stuff sort of made up. It's built up as a mythology to to make
his like rise against all odds and and way more unbelievable
or way more, I guess, inspiring.
What's up, fairy queen? Merry Christmas. Welcome. Welcome. the
Squash Ben and the entire Daily Wire and all of his critics in
so many ways. It's it's a wonderful story and I do mean all of
that. Seriously. Um I'm not being sarcastic about that. But Nick,
you're the Israel guy. You're our guy, bro. And we are now well
into the moment with Israel, with TPUSA, with Candace, with the
Trump government, with
And what's going on, man? Where are you at, Nick? Oh, saw the
stream title. This is Serious T. Can't believe Erica actually
responded to Candace. Well, she did. But unfortunately, we've
gone off on a tangent. And that's okay. We've got tons of time
for the stream tonight. It's not even 11:00 yet. We got a ton
of time on the stream. So guys, I should also shill. If you like
the content, go ahead throw a couple subs my way. Add more time
to the stream. All right. We can go forever. You guys just keep
paying. We'll keep adding hours. But and you can donate through
the Streamlabs links as well. Buy TTS. But
we went off we gone off on a tangent. We're talking about Ian
Carroll and his fight with Nick Fuentes. is a little aside real
quick. Like, yeah, Nick is still doing his thing. He's still
running a show. He's still being critical of Israel,
but he's also doing the podcast circuit basically running everything
he can against Candace and against actual like factual information.
I I could understand if Nick was skeptical of Candace's sources.
Wait, but Nick is Does he not understand why that would Candace
literally came for his throat? Candace literally tried to put
Nick in the ground earlier this summer. Why is that confusing
that he doesn't like Candace? He wants to blow her up for the
thing she's vulnerable for. That's just that's just like intelligent
politics. No, your enemy makes a mistake, you try to end their
career.
I don't even I mean he he definitely holds a grudge, but I that
makes total sense to me. Straight up
like not here, not not there for the conversation about Israel
in the way I think a lot of us expect and the way I think a lot
of us were ready for. It's like arriving on the battlefield and
your general is off hanging out with Steven Crowder
and it's like what is going on, bro? Why are you doing puff pieces
with Steven? Why doesn't that energy apply to Ethan? Because
Ethan is using financial ruination to go after somebody and then
lying about why he's doing it. You ask Fentes why he's going
after Candace, he would say because she's lying and also she
tried to [__] me over. This stupid [__]
See, Nick stands on business. Ethan is a whiny, spineless.
pretty easy to discern the two or the difference between the
two. >> Crowder right now, dude.
It like this is weird and it's weird to me and I bet it's weird
to a lot of people. It's probably weird to some of the gropers,
though. I'm sure some of the gripers will follow Nick till the
end of the earth. And you know, you do you. And I'm not here
to say that like I'm not here to say that Nick is a fed. I'm
not here to say that Nick is this or that. I'm not here to [__]
on Nick completely. >> Um, okay. Well, you just threw it
out there. But I am here to just, you know, air out the room
like the dude these speaking of. Okay, Candace and this guy.
Speaking of, okay, I'm not here to say this. I'm just here to
say, isn't it strange what they're doing right now? I'm not saying
Casey Tron is evil, but isn't it a little weird that she like
hasn't spoken out against the Holocaust >> Bro, I' I'd
have way less respect for Ethan if he worked that way, too. But
I am here to just
air out the room like, "Bro, where you at? What's going on, dog?
It's time. It's happening. We're in
over there hanging out with Steven Crowder doing puff pieces."
And if you don't know what I'm talking about,
I'll show you and I'll just we'll just try to reconcile this
somehow.
So, Steven Crowder yesterday at 11 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
here for the Mug Club as always with special guest Nick >> Mr.
Fuentes, thank you for being here, sir. Can you uh hear me? See
me? Okay. >> Yes. Can you hear me? >> I can I can
hear you. And I >> And I just want to really quickly take
the take the little lowblow shot and remind all of >> So,
does Ian not like Crowder? A tangled web here. Well, if you don't
remember, Crowder hates Candace. And Candace must have disliked
him because when Crowder did his whole play against the Daily
Wire, who was the bulldog that came out and was used to attack
Crowder.
That was Candace Owens, right? So, I assume there's actual animosity
there because I believe she was the one bringing up his wife
a whole bunch of like she was constantly ringing the bell about
his wife and how abusive he was. And
so, I have I have a feeling there's just a lot of animosity that
was probably genuine. And Candace was like, and they were like, "Who?"
Yeah. Who's going to go up Steven Crowder now? Candace probably
raised her hand was like, "Yeah, I got this. I got this guy."
Of the con influencers that you're evil if you platform Nick
Fentes. How could you ever platform such a raging anti-semite?
Oh my gosh. I'm just going to go out on a limb and guess that
Steven Crowder is not going to get that treatment. And I'll let
you make up your own mind as to why that might not be. But I
don't think that Steven Crowder's going Does Ian Carol know about
the whole
like I believe con as a term as a pjorative for like the mainstream
conservative establishment
was invented by Crowder when he did the whole speech about the
contract he was offered and how up it was. I believe he was the
one who was saying that this is conk.
So he just used the term coninc
in a way that I don't think really was used by right-wingers
and he doesn't even understand that the person who started using
that term I believe unless I'm mistaken was actually Crowder
is this 3 years ago four years ago going to get the same treatment.
He might get a little nudge a little prickle here or there and
I'm not alleging that Steven Crowder was ever on the cancel train.
I'm not here to try to like dig up every clip that anyone's ever
posted. Whatever y'all do your thing I'm just I'm just reminding
us that Khan
crowd is crowd
they're going to be duplicitus on this one. I see. I appreciate
the Christmas decor. A lot of a lot of people don't do that.
Uh let me get this just out of the way really quickly. Obviously
on X. Uh and that's a win. You're back. Nick J. Fuentes. Nicholas
J. Fuentes. It's America first on Rumble >> Monday. I'll
be doing a show. >> Uh I will warn you. Pierce Morgan Uncensored.
He's rather censored. Pass it and then edit it out afterwards.
>> So no. Huh. All right. I'll I'll keep that in mind.
I'll try not to use it. >> If he asks you, well, would
you say it
on a good actually did that one time in hate above all else.
It's like I feel compelled to defend no matter who it is when
jokes or statements. I just pile and he feels compelled to reach
out to >> compelled to defend no matter who it is when
jokes or statements I just want to remind us just reminder before
we get into this a Steven Crowder hates when there's a dog pile
and he feels compelled to reach out to the censored and help
them out and uplift them when everyone's on someone he just feels
compelled to help out but I also want to remind you that Steven
Crowder had some weird government leaks about the rifle that
Tyler Robinson allegedly used where like the government was reaching
out to Steven Crowder with the inside scoop on the day of the
shooting to help create the fed that narrative and it was very
>> I mean, I thought that was just like somebody from the
ATF who clearly would have gotten fire like fired because they
were leaking private information to Stephen Crowder for no reason.
Wrong. Right or wrong? I think. And it was like inaccurate information.
It was like a field report that wasn't verified and it was clearly
that it was there at all. It like had the wrong It had totally
incorrect what would you say? totally incorrect explanations
of what the bullets meant. Like there was inscriptions of the
bullets and they kind of listed them off and then just said this
is like trans propaganda which it was not at all. There's a lot
we could say about Crowder. Y'all make up your own mind, but
like specifically on the Charlie Kirk thing that was weird.
Just listen to the things that they actually allege, right? What
did he allege there? Nothing. No allegation, no concrete claim,
no way for Crowder to push back against it. This kind of schizophrenic
garbage is just ins. It's so stupid. Uh, wasn't it just weird
that he like had a leak from the ATF? Yeah, I guess. What does
that even mean? Like when somebody says something is weird. Oh,
this is just weird. It's like you could say, "I need to keep
a note of that cuz I'm going to think about it later." But when
you just go, "Oh, isn't that weird?" And you kind of hint that
you really think he's like a fed or something. You think he's
like compromised, but you never actually allege it. We can all
see what you're doing. You're just too much of a [__]
to say what you actually think. Why don't you just be transparent
about it >> or mischaracterize taken out of context? I've
had that happen to me. I think it's happened to you quite a bit.
I don't want to do that. All right. Hopefully, I think, you know,
not crazy how many people latch on to that stuff. That's a part
of Candace's power.
Candace, it will just be your pay.
>> Dr. Lou donated $5 being a minute. Hope you've been
well. >> I have been well. Thank you very much for the
five, Dr. Lou. Appreciate it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you.
All right. I hope you are well as well. I also need to throw
up a tweet I threw out earlier today just so you guys see like
how annoying this is when Candace Candace is the most powerful
one. Okay, I just took a screenshot of her live concurrence before
I went live. Shortly before I went live.
176,000 today. She's broken past the 150 plateau. She's on her
way to 200. She's more than halfway there. Okay. Every single
time this lies or is proven wrong or somebody condemns her, she
gets another 5,000 concurrent viewers. It's there's literally
no nothing that could stop her. Okay. Um the follow-up point
is at what point do we admit that she's an extradimensional entity
that can't be stopped if we just start negotiating with her to
leave this plane? How many virgins? 10,000 virgins? We got a
whole legion of gropers. Okay, we got 10,000 50,000 virgins.
How many virgins you need, Candace, to just leave this plane
of existence and go somewhere else? Okay, Cthulhuesque being
leave. [__] to STOP TORMENTING US. GET OUT. Salvo
asked me about it and then he wanted to debate. Um I think he
actually wanted to debate. I just had to start the stream.
Yeah, dude. It's just crazy that like she's unstoppable. Nothing
stops her. Literally nothing can stop her. Orin governments bought
people like this to deflect from the truth. To deflect combo
from the truth except
Okay, how much are they investing in this? Cuz she gets
crazy donations. She gets crazy donations. And from what I understood,
like these foreign governments, maybe they're doing it via like
super chats and stuff now. I wouldn't put it past like Russia
to be like, "Oh, we're gonna platform. We're gonna buff up Candace
Owens, Tucker Carlson, Nick Fuentes, and Ian Carroll, and all
these insane people. We're going to make them all talk about
them." Nick Fuentes, I feel like has way more claim to like an
organic following. But I do think a lot of people, like here's
the
Puggyups is here and I've got a couple other conservative women
who I think while they don't necessarily believe everything Candace
is saying, they do find it incredibly compelling content.
And so I have a I have the signals I have available to me are
all signaling that the Candace stuff is actually very compelling
content.
And so I'm led to believe that this is probably not just totally
fake or totally astroturfed. There probably really is something
legitimate there. Right.
Yeah. Exactly, Norblaze. Like they she did the Diddy stuff as
well. Like I think there's probably something genuinely compelling
about this content to a lot of people that leads me to believe
that those numbers are roughly correct right
now. Is she getting botted a little bit? Yeah. But I don't think
she's getting like doubled up right. I I don't think so, man.
And so many people are listening that I don't I don't believe
it's fake.
You know what I'm saying? She captured the female audience. How?
with her like staunch commitment to marriage and believing like
listening to what her husband tells her to do. What do you mean
she captured the female audience? The you talking about, man,
say coherent things. She just went on her stream the other day
and said, "I can't debate cuz my husband said no." What do you
mean the female audience? Okay. Anyway, we >> Neither one
of us does that. And I also really hate seeing gang ups and that's
why anyone here. I >> You really hate seeing people gang
up on creators,
right?
Just not on that one black girl because her but Nick, I just
hate seeing people gang up on creators on on people speaking
the truth on free speech. >> Really didn't like seeing
>> Yeah, he definitely hates Candace Owens after his whole
divorce thing was like brought up by her. And I think Did she
leak that he was getting divorced? Did she leak like some [__]
about that? Like she was she did some where I was like, "Oh yeah,
you get to hate that person forever." Kind of like with Asmin
Gold and Casey Trron, right? Where it's like, "Okay, I don't
really have a problem with Asmin Gold hating Casey Tron forever."
Casey Trron said some [__] That's understandable.
Okay. Everybody else who gets parasoially attached and gets parasoially
mad for Asmin Gold, those people are pathetic. But for Asmin
Gold himself, it's like, "Okay, you know what? Yeah, I get it.
I get it. I get it." Yeah, she was hinting at it. Yeah, she hinted
at it. Okay, I'm going to leak some stuff about you. I remember
just being like, "Whoa, that's up." So, and said to pray for
him before the divorce leak. Okay, got it. >> What happened
with Candace and Tucker? Um, especially after you appeared with
Tucker and it seems pretty cordial. And then he took pot shots
once you were gone. I promise you I'm not going to do that. Is
that that fair? >> Yeah. No, I appreciate that. >> Okay.
And what I really want to do is I want people to actually hear
your views for what they actually are. >> I I do wish that
Tucker hadn't taken like I I don't know to say pot shots, but
I wish that Tucker had stood more like more completely firm on
how he had conducted himself and how he conducted that interview,
but you know, and I know a lot of people are going to disagree
and some people um you know, they'll be they'll be moved, they'll
be convinced, and I want them to make up their own mind and be
able to contrast it. So, I I were able to do that. I will also
say, "Hey, look, I do want to thank you because, you know, I've
been subject to some uh some concerted hit pieces myself and
you didn't join in uh on the dog pile and I I do appreciate that."
>> Yeah. Got to stand up for a guy, you know, it's bros
before hoes. So, uh I'm with you. >> No, not I don't so
much appreciate you implying that, you know, I'm bringing talking
points from from Black Rockck or the Israeli considering I've
been sued by Black Rockck and even Rumble had to fight back.
So, I think let's just make sure we take each other's opinions
at face value. I don't think that you're paid for to say anything
that you're saying and I can tell you definitively that I've
never taken a dime from an outside entity. >> This is a
weird sentence. I can I can assure you that I've never taken
a dime from an outside entity or I think he says a foreign government.
>> Define an outside entity. Crowder. I mean like you're
allowed to take advertisers, but
>> you know I think I get what he's trying to say. >> Foreign
interest. Okay. >> Yeah, I believe you. Sounds good to
me. All right. Also, I want to make sure issues are not mischaracterized.
A lot of people watching. This is the last kind of ground rule.
Uh I want to kind of address each issue point by point. I'm going
to avoid point stacking. We're just go rapid fire because >> pay
attention to Crowder's wording here at the start. Okay. Just
just look for the wording. Right. Right. Right. Right. that take
out of context. You know, people go and Nick wiggled out of this
and they do that with me. I want no one
have a couple of rapid fires, but I think you're going to
be softballs.
I'm here to help, which is >> Okay. Is he just going to
react? I thought he was going to pull up the part that's like
actually critical here. Okay. He doesn't react to this for long,
>> he must get to it really fast. >> What are we
doing with Steven Crowder >> These are layups and I mean
rapid fire and then I'm going to give you the floor. Uh Nick,
I think there's some >> He kind of is
heard this said. Can you clear the air? Nick Fuentes, do you
hate all sir? >> No. You got that energy? >> Uh,
do you consider yourself an anti-semite? A noted anti-semite?
>> Okay. Wait, does he have Hold on.
>> Yeah. Hold on. I took exception to this, too. It's like,
bro, I've literally watched an episode where he's like, I'M AMERICA'S
PREMIER ANTI-SEMITE. I'M AMERICA'S FOREMOST ANTI-SEMITE. YOU
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT ME. It's like he was mad cuz somebody was
talking about anti-semitism without mentioning him. It's like,
brother, now you're sitting here. Oh, no. I've never I would
never be anti-Semitic. No, I would never do that. I would never
I would never do that, man. What? We'll get to this in just a
second. >> YEAH. YEAH. HOLD ON. IT'S THE same thing, though.
Why wasn't I nominated for anti-semite of the year? It's And
then he's like, "No, I'm not anti-Semitic at all." Actually,
so gay. We'll get to this in just a second. >> Clears that
up. Do you believe that white people are superior to all other
races on the planet? >> Okay. Do you want to eradicate
all non-whites from the United States?
>> Okay. Okay. Well, Barry Wise will be very happy to hear
that. No doubt. >> I believe that last one, by the way,
the one before that, he just believes they're superior in every
single way that could possibly matter.
He believes they're superior in like culture and everything,
but maybe modern music and sports,
but only some sports.
That's like, but everything else they're superior in. >> Uh,
and then because this happened to >> Well, then black people
like the He basically argues the races have like different talents.
Okay. It's like when you sign up for World of Warcraft and you
get different passives. That's what he thinks, right? Like black
and white is like orc and undead. Okay. >> Right. It's
the you're >> white people are the orcs there. I'm not
>> With you. Fed. Fed. Fed. Nick Fentes. Are you in fact
a fed?
>> Okay. Uh I'm going to get through the rep really quickly.
They're actually So this week Julie Michael will be on the show
next week while you're doing Pierce Morgan Censored. And um she
said that we need to disavow you. Um, and specifically said you
had said that women either want or need to be I looked for this.
I have not found as a matter of prescription uh from you, correct
me if I'm wrong, that you believe women uh should be >> what's
their racial ability? I'm not getting into that one, man. No,
thank >> As a matter of policy, do I have that >> Uh,
yeah, you're correct on that. Yes. >> Okay. All right.
>> And to be clear, I'm not saying that you shouldn't give
Nick an opportunity to clarify his views. I'm not saying that
his clarifications are disqualifying. I'm not trying to make
fun of any like whatever. Just subtext. Um, and now here we go.
>> Right. So, so she's wrong. Okay.
Now, uh I'm not saying And I'm not saying And I'm not saying
How about you just say what you're saying, [__] Okay.
Can you go? How about you say something? Say
Now, I'm not saying Now, I'm not saying No, I'm just saying it's
weird, but like I I I'm not even saying it's weird. It's just
kind of weird, man. And I'm not saying this or that or that.
But isn't it weird that this And I'm not saying but isn't it
weird that that Can you shut the [__] up? She's an
angry lesbian. Got it. Now, uh, finally, this one might surprise
people. Um, because I know you and Charlie Kirk are sort of rivals
as you've described. Been a lot of controversy floating around
that and people often say that you blamed for everything. Uh,
do you believe that Charlie Kirk, that's one of the conspiracies
out there right now. What's your position on that? >> I
don't believe that. As it stands right now, I think it was Tyler
Robinson. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, Nick, pay attention
out here, bro. You think that a 30 six hit a neck vertebrae and
turned at a 90° angle and then continued at full velocity and
shattered a bunch of neck vertebrae below it and then possibly
went down into his heart and stopped his heart.
You think that they just I don't know just paved over the crime
scene two days later on a Sunday
just by happen stance.
Wouldn't that be like find outable?
I guarantee you somebody's found that out if that really did
happen. Although, wait, why would they just pave over?
Why would they pave over like that courtyard? That courtyard's
like nice. >> You think that there was a bunch of foreign
military planes on the ground that day doing weird flight stuff
just by chance?
Okay, that's already I'm already not here for the Egyptian planes.
They're just doing weird flight stuff.
I feel like you should have some claims there, right? I swear
to God, if we go and watch all of his coverage of the planes,
I feel like it's just going to be Isn't this weird? Isn't this
like odd that this happened? with no understanding of whether
or not it would be odd. Okay. Um, what was the other one? Oh,
the 30 odd six. Okay. Question. Can somebody explain to me
why if he wasn't shot with a 30 odd six would the FBI, because
you're saying the FBI's compromised, why would they plant a 30
odd six in the woods and say it was Tyler Robinson's and that's
what he used to shoot him?
Why wouldn't they either plant a rifle where the story makes
sense, right? makes more sense and is less questionable. Or plant
just the weapon that was actually used to kill him. Why' they
plant a fake rifle? How do they claim to know it isn't a 30 odd
six? They're saying that because of the lack of damage that Charlie's
entire shoulder didn't explode. They think it's not a 30 odd
6.
Now, like if it was a 30 odd six, his entire shoulder and back
would be blown out entirely, but there's no exit wound that's
massive, so it's not a 30 odd 6. That's what they're saying.
And I'm saying if if you say it's not, then why did they plant
a 30 odd six? If that's like totally unbelievable, why would
they come up with this whole conspiracy and then just shoot him
with the wrong gun and then plant the wrong gun? Like shoot him
with a gun, plant the wrong one, and try to cook up like a totally
fake story. Yeah. I just don't know. >> Do you think that
Charlie Kirk literally tweeting to his and Zionist donors that
he needs to leave the pro-Israel cause is not relevant? and that
him texting to his friends the day >> I don't think he
tweeted that >> before this happened that he was afraid
they were going to kill him is not relevant that BB Netanyahu
offering him an enormous sum of money that Wait hold on who did
he text
did he text somebody saying that Israel was going to kill him
or is he just taking that from Candace one to one hold on is
he did he just take that from Candace one to one or is there
like leaks of that um Charlie Kirk tweets about
um
people going to kill him. Not tweets,
texts. The text messages between Charlie
No, no, no, no, no. We have a possible cover up. There are people
at Turning Point who Charlie texted the night before and said,
"They are going to kill me." So, I see Candace there. I hold
on. What is this? These text messages now confirmed to be authentic,
were sent shortly before Charlie Kirk was assassinated. When
truth and honesty are suppressed, both people and the planet
suffer. just lost another huge donor. Two million a year because
we won't cancel Tucker. I'm thinking of inviting Candace. Uggh.
Donors play into all of the stereotypes. I cannot and will not
be bullied like this. Leaving me no choice but to leave the pro-Israel
Okay. Well, we saw the rest of this conversation, wasn't it?
Like, and then we saw the letter to BB, but I have never seen
the texts that are like, "Oh, I think they're going to kill me."
Where where are those texts? Cuz I feel like he's just taking
that from Candace and saying it's true. Where are these? Okay.
Well, I couldn't find them with a simple Google search, so I'm
going back to the video. Okay, that's way too much work >> that
he turned down is not relevant.
Like, you're supposed to be our guy, bro. This is your moment.
This is your moment on so many levels, dude. Where are you? You're
on Steven Crowder disavowing the people that are actually out
here taking on Israel, taking Dude, this this relies on his the
other pronunciation. You ever hear people call him Nick Fuentes?
Now you get Nick Juentes. Nick Chuentes.
Let's go.
It's crazy.
Sorry, I tried to do it like him. I couldn't there. I didn't
hit it. The music threw me off, but it's fine. On the deep state
taking on the whole thing and you're over here with Crowder with
Crowder. And we're going to get into all of these different elements
throughout this show. And like the world is not about picking
sides, but sometimes when you look at the sides of an issue,
it tells you a lot about the issue. And it tells you a lot about
what's what like what how if you are thinking about a thing in
a way that makes you arrive at the same conclusion as Tim P
and as Steven Crowder and as Rabbi Schmoolie and as all these
other people. I should be clear. I'm not saying that Nick is
the same as Rabbi. Okay. I'm just saying. Now I just want to
I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm not saying but you are kind
of saying you're on the same side as them. You think the same
thing as them
now. You're on the same side as OJ and Cosby and
Weinstein. I'm not saying you're like a but you know actually
OJ didn't rape but if I had three rapists like now I'm not saying
you're I'm just saying the only thing that ties these things
together is that they are rapists and obviously Diddy. Sure.
Diddy. Yeah. Let's go. What are you saying? >> How are
you winding up at the conclusion of these guys
with all that you know with all that you've called out with your
deep understanding of how donors control things?
with your deep understanding of the history of MSAD and of the
CIA. You don't even think there's a possibility,
not even a chance. And I know that you've got beef with Candace
and that you do just don't like Candace and I know that Candace
has beef with you and it's like I know it's a lot for her to
be doing really well right now on her podcast despite all the
hardship that is involved in that. But like that is not why like
that's not a reason that's not what's going on here. Like what
is what is going on here, bro?
And I also understand, I get it, that there is a perfectly good
reason why when this first happened, Nick might have been reticent
to come out with any kind of theories because the Gropers were
about to be target number one. Okay, real quick. No evidence
has been produced, no primary source evidence has been produced
to and Candace hasn't even named the person when she says that
there are people in TPUSA who who Charlie was saying Israel's
going to kill me unless I cooperate with them. There's no evidence
of that. There's none. It's
But he just repeats it. They just like invent. You just invent
something. Okay. But in fact, it was actually Candace and everyone
pointing the finger at Israel and everyone starting to uncover
on this exact train of thought that exonerated the Griers because
they all quickly dug into the case and realized that this is
not Tyler Robinson. And Tyler Robinson also is not a grier. >> Yeah.
No, the gropers were exonerated because Tyler Robinson clearly
wasn't a groper,
not because Tyler Robinson didn't do it. Yeah, he just said he
just realized my my face when I realized I just said something
really that's going to get clipped. Oh boy. I just I just up
and said something really dumb.
The gripers only got exonerated because then we real when we
realized it wasn't Tyler Robinson and then but also Tyler Robinson
wasn't a griper. Right. Right. You didn't need the you didn't
need me making [__] up to exonerate them cuz the
truth Yeah. Oh boy. Oh boy. And so once the Gropers were exonerated,
I just don't really see how that affects the conversation right
now. And Nick, even
what did this guy just say? What did he just say? What the That
absolutely obliterates the pro-Israel narrative that absolutely
exposes Israel's infiltration of Christian churches. Israel's
infil Wait, did I just skip way past this? >> And it's
like, I know it's a lot for her to be doing really well right
now. Zack train of thought that exonerated the >> I skipped
forward >> because they all quickly dug into the case and
realized that this is not Tyler Robinson and Tyler Robinson also
is not a griper. And so once the gropers were exonerated, I just
don't really see how that affects the conversation right now.
>> That was a totally incoherent sentence.
I I'm going to go back and play it one more time. Like that is
not why like that's not a reason. That's not what's going on
here. Like what is what is going on here, bro?
And I also understand I get it that there is a perfectly good
reason why when this first happened, Nick might have been reticent
to come out with any kind of theories because the Gropers were
about to be target number one. Okay. But in fact, it was actually
Candace and everyone pointing the finger at Israel and everyone
starting to uncover on this exact train of thought that exonerated
the gripers.
So it's definitely not. And he admits that in the literal next
sentence
and then he says, "But now I so I don't see why this is a part
of the conversation." Well, it's not. Nick isn't saying, "Well,
you know, I couldn't say
dude.
It's not a part of the conversation at all because they all quickly
dug into the case and realized that this is not Tyler Robinson."
And Tyler Robinson also is not a groper. And so once the gropers
were exonerated,
I just don't really see how that affects the conversation right
now. Yeah. Nobody's claiming it affects the conversation. They're
like, "No, he's saying I don't get how, you know, Groper is being
accused." He's like, I understand that some people say that Groper
is being accused of this means he can't comment, but I don't
see how it affects the conversation. It's like, okay, maybe that's
a little bit, but you understand that that is nothing. Ken is
digging into this or blaming Israel had nothing to do with, you
know, blaming the really helped you, Nick. Can't you help us?
Can't you do us a solid here and blame the too? No, that doesn't
make any sense. You look like a total joke following through
with that line of logic. Um, actually, uh, you're like the guy
who hates Israel. Shouldn't you be blaming Israel for this? No,
that's how you lose all credibility. That's how you look like
a total.
And Nick, even if
you still kind of think it might be most likely Tyler Robinson
and you want to be the one that made that right call, even when
everyone else made the wrong call, even so, along the way here,
we have gotten so much information that absolutely obliterates
the pro-Israel narrative that absolutely exposes Israel's infiltration
of Christian churches, Israel's infiltration of politics, Israel's
infiltration of donor uh culture of conservative guys, we needed
Charlie Kirk getting to know that Israel donates money to US
politicians.
Wow.
Guess guess uh guess Nick didn't do any work to expose, you know,
donors in America or anything like that, which he said at the
beginning. He's like, I really respect Nick's understanding of
like how money makes its way into politics was more or less what
he said. And now
now apparently we needed a Charlie Kirk getting shot to know
that Israel pays for propaganda.
Amazing. I think and this is supposed to be your moment. This
is supposed to be your rise. You're on the generational run,
bro. And you have generationally run to Steven Crowder's show
to hang out with the feds narrative
for like kind of a facious take on it. It like it's very confusing
to a lot of us and it's a bummer because I genuinely like you
being here. I genuinely like that you challenged the conversation
and I'm genuinely impressed by what you've done with your platform
and your messaging over the years. But like I think a lot of
creators right now are feeling the way I'm feeling and are just
afraid to say it because we all know how the grikers are and
we all know that Nick is good at holding a grudge and that's
cool. If Nick wants to hold a grudge that's fine. I'm not stressed.
But I'm just genuinely like bro this is your debate some of these
people. Uh that would be good. Yeah. But the debate here's the
thing. The debate isn't something that can be engaged in legitimately,
right? Like it actually can't like they understand or at least
they have to understand. Like if their level if their level of
proof is enough for them to believe something there's no real
like that's a man I don't know anything about philosophy but
I believe that's like an epistemic foundation you can't build
your church on right like if that's your way of epis uh epistmiology
is how you evaluate truth right am I
epistemics the theory of knowledge especially with regard to
its methods validity and scope
yeah so it's like how you evaluate truth in the world right like
they can't evaluate truth so it's actually like super hard to
try to debate them on something. How in the world do you
epistemology epistmiology? Jesus. Like I said, I've never ever
taken a philosophy course except maybe prop logic for computer
science. So that's my bad. I I I when I tell you I've never looked
into philosophy at all. I'm not joking. I know none of the terms.
I try to like get them. Okay. But yeah, it's like they don't
they can't evaluate the truth. It's super hard to debate people
who can't evaluate the truth. Unless you just want to scream
at them, but maybe that's all you want is me to scream at them.
It gets it gets exhausting after bit though and you ain't here.
We're all on the front lines of battle
for America to save America from this influence. This exact investigation
has not only exposed Israel's grasp over organizations like Epsteinology
is, I believe, the study of how to get blackmail on powerful
political figures
for the state of Israel. That last part's optional TP USA. But
in the process, it is exposed reporting about Israel's grasp
over Trump himself, over the White House, over American Christian
churches. It's just very confusing. It's very confusing. And
I guess the way that is, by the way, is this him is this him
admitting that they don't really have proof that Charlie Kirk
had anything to do with any of this other stuff? Like, this feels
like it's him just admitting, "Yeah, we haven't proven anything
with regards to Charlie Kirk or Tyler Robinson." But even if
we didn't, isn't there a whole bunch of other cool stuff we learned
along the way while claiming this is true? The way that it seems
to me is that like I came up with a conclusion is real Charlie
Kirk. And then when I investigated, I found some things out about
Israel. Well, did they Charlie Kirk? Well, even if they didn't,
didn't we find some concerning stuff?
is that if we're going to be winning
>> it it seems like you got to be on the front lines of
battle, bro. And I get it. That's not why he didn't win anti-semit
of the year because they're [__] scared of giving
him a bigger platform. They they know that if they give antite
of the year, if they even nominate him, it's just going to make
him bigger. And you know, we're No, it's because anti-semit of
the year is used to discourage people who aren't actually anti-semmites,
just people who question Israel and have some amount of decency.
They're not going to accuse actual anti-semmites because guess
what? Jake Shields went on Piers Morgan, argued that the Holocaust
was fake. He doesn't give a if you call him an anti-semite. Okay?
The point of anti-semite of the year from stop anti-semites is
just to scare people. they have a chance of actually scaring.
It's not to actually chastise real anti-semites. It's to scare
normies who are like incredulous about Israel. That's the whole
point of that account. We're just going to all celebrate it
because everyone else is just celebrating. Drew Peter's doing
a victory lap. Everyone's hyped. We're all competing for it.
But Nick is just out here taking shots at Candace left and right,
left and right. And it's like, I get that you got to vendetta,
but it's like, bro, what's what's going on here? And you're going
on all the podcasts is for like engagement. >> I think
that's a huge part of it. I think that she cares that her friend
died. At the same time, this has been really good business for
her. She's getting like 150,000. >> She's actually pretty
much been doing the same numbers as before. If you actually look
at it, she's, you know, she's gone up maybe like a few hundred,000
views per live on average, but she's been getting 2 million views
on a live since long before Charlie was. Her Bit stories were
doing incredible views. They were break.
Listen, her recent totally madeup slanderous lies have no bearing
on her numbers. When she did previous totally madeup slanderous
lies, they also did numbers. Amazing.
You love to see it breaking the whole world. It's actually kind
of a fallacy to say that she's been milking this for for money.
I mean, it's very understandable that she's going to >> It's
absolutely not. >> Follow the investigation to its end.
>> Well, hold on. Maybe maybe it could be wrong that she's
doing it for money. It could be for like attention or something
cuz she obviously is from a family now where they're super rich.
She has nothing to worry about. But
she's definitely doing it for the views. But viewers, millions
of views on every show. She's probably making tons of money at
this point. I think she's milking it. It's been like 3 months
and every show is This changes everything. You're not going to
want to miss. >> Nick, if you were murdered, I would not
stop until I figured out who the did it. No, no, no. Be honest.
Hey, be honest, Ian. Be honest. Nick, if you were murdered, I
wouldn't stop until I'd personally proven BB Netanyahu was behind
it. That's what you mean. I wouldn't stop until I prove that
Israel did it to you. Okay, that's what you actually mean here.
Let's be real. That's that's the truth. Okay. And I don't even
know you. I've never met you. But if you were murdered today,
especially if there were suspicious circumstances, especially
if you had just texted your Gist, I would I would blame Israel
immediately and then I would start looking for evidence. I would
blame Israel on the on the spot. Israel did it. And then I would
start I would start pounding the pavement. Okay.
But you know, if the situation were reversed and you had been
murdered, I would not
proved it because it would be essential to the conversation.
It would be essential to free speech and to everyone in our positions.
And if the FBI came out and there's the suspicious murder of
Nick Fuentes and the FBI comes out and is like, "Oh, it was this
lone gunman with a gay lover." I wouldn't be buying that for
a second. Lone gunman with a gay lover, eh? Oh, why did it stop?
Oh, well, you had it. It was there for a second. >> It
was there for a second. or a text message rather saying, "I'm
afraid they're going to kill me. I have to leave the pro Israel
cause."
>> We would all Well, here's the thing, Cam. My first question
about the planes would be, did he do like a control? Did he find
somebody else who travels roughly about as much as Erica Kirk
and then see how that looked like? And then were those planes
like centered around some? You'd have to find somebody who travels
roughly about the same amount from I think Arizona is where the
Kirks are from, right? Or where they live. like somebody who
lives in Arizona travels about that amount. Like is there a totally
logical explanation or did you just look for like a weird pattern
and then never explain why that pattern exists or what might
else like did you look into competing theories all do the same
is there anything to that plane stuff? Well, I think they matched
it up to times where Erica was flying and stuff and they basically
say, "Okay, it actually attaches as in these planes were being
used to spline on the Kirks, either Erica or Charlie or both,
and plan out whatever was going to happen with them, right?"
Or there's like some state state actors who are doing really
weird things with them. But I don't even know what really weird
means. I don't know why they don't describe the actual things
that were happening because basically every time Ian Carol or
Candace Owens says something's really weird, it's because they
don't they know that describing what actually happened would
sound insane. Isn't it really weird how like so many people are
saying Charlie felt like he was going to be betrayed? What do
you mean really weird? Well, you see, like I had a dream where
Charlie told me he was going to be betrayed. Uh, no, those are
not Wait, those are totally different, Candace. Those aren't
the same thing at all. The are you saying? Same for you. Or at
least I would. I can't speak for everyone. So, is it milking
it to try to get to the bottom of the whole thing when the story
that the feds were giving was falling apart on day one? The story
that the feds were giving fell apart a month before the shooting
happened when Harrison Smith tweeted out that a source close
to Charlie told him that Charlie was afraid that Israel was going
to kill >> To tune in tomorrow where she's like, "I have
more evidence, but I'm going to wait to release it." Why? So
you can milk it for ratings. If you have >> Do you remember
the time when she had that one text message that everyone said
she didn't have, and she got everyone to lie on Charlie's name,
including Andrew Kulit most prominently, and everyone's >> which
one? Hold on. Please tell me that's not the like Charlie Loved
Israel one. Please tell me that's not the one where she was like,
"Oh, yeah. We actually proved that he did say that the Israeli
people like, "Oh, you're going to make me leave the movement
with your criticisms." No, no, no, no, no. I'm pretty sure it
would be this one. I'm pretty sure it' be this one. But this
one clearly didn't have much of an effect cuz, you know, a couple
weeks later, he was he was sending a letter to BB Netanyahu
offering like [__] for free. I I need to be a part
of the the movement to build up Israel's reputation again, BB.
I need to I need to help you guys. I love you guys so much. Coming
out and trying to spin their own spin and she's just waiting
for all them to put their receipts on the table. You remember
that?
Put it all. You mean the one where eventually when everybody
did start leaking stuff because she was trying to do a dance
of Victor over that, she looked like a complete
You mean that one all out there? You think that Can
So I'm just I'm just bummed, man. I'm bummed cuz you're this
is supposed to be your moment. Like you're supposed to be out
ahead of us leading the charge. Your intellect is supposed to
be here dismantling the Zionist complex, dismantling the Zionist
donor base, exposing this because this specific issue right here,
this Well, I think probably Nick would talk about some of the
financial stuff if that's all you were talking about. But you're
basically saying that financial stuff leads to Charlie Kirk was
murdered by Israel with no actual evidence, no connection to
that, right? That's why he doesn't want to talk about it. If
you had like purely financial information, you interesting stuff.
Maybe this issue
is the exact example of why your point specifically your point
that it's not just the Israeli government. It is also American
Zionist American Zionist and this network that they have built
inside of America on behalf of this foreign state because that's
what TPUSA is is exactly. If there's >> Okay. Is is this
guy aware Apac exists?
this guy aware of Apac and like its existence or is he basically
think he's like proving Apac exists right now? I actually don't
know.
Uh I I don't know if you guys know this, but there are powerful
and rich American Zionists who are willing to fund politicians
all over the country. I'm I'm just hearing about this for the
first time. Yeah, bro. We've been talking about Apac for a while.
We've been talking about it for a little while. Welcome to the
show. Here it is. It's Apac. It exists. It's existed for a long
time. You're not breaking new ground here. This is the same people
have been talking about for months, for years. At any moment
in time when America has a direct obvious example of what you
have been championing for years, it right now with Turning Point
>> I
How in the world could he possibly think Turning Point USA is
bigger than
Oh, wait. Maybe hold on.
Well, Apac's the biggest political donor. I'd say TPUSA might
serve a more important function. Maybe you could argue that,
but I I mean Nick's been arguing that to begin with for a long
time anyway, right? that TP USA is just like mega central like
am I make Israel great again central I feel like that and uh
Prageru he's been saying that about those two companies forever
you might have like more proof of it now more donors or something
but it's I don't know Nick's been saying it anyway I guess
and suddenly everyone else is gone like uh I'm not even saying
Apac bad I don't know that Apac bad I don't know that Apac is
that unique I really don't the only thing I'm saying is that
if you're just talking about like rich American Zionist people
who donate money to politics, then Apac is
uh I thought Apac was the biggest donor to a lot of like individual
campaigns. Not to federal campaigns, but on a smaller level,
I thought they were the largest individual donor to a lot of
different campaigns
like that. They went to small races and they basically like flooded
them with cash to try to get like the person who's anti-Zionist
out in a lot of cases. Like this is what happened to Jamal Bowman,
right? This is what happened in New York City with Zora Mdani,
I believe.
But maybe I'm maybe I'm incorrect on that. I thought they're
definitely the biggest nation funer as well or like nationally
affiliated pack, but I thought they were also like one of the
biggest supporters of like congressional candidates. Everyone
else has gone off to fight it and you are not
>> So maybe I could be informed. >> I'm just It's
weird. It's weird. And so instead, Miss Rachel has won anti-semite
of the year for good reason because obviously look at this. >> Let's
go back to sleep. We're tired.
>> Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. So, American Israel
Public Affairs Committee, uh, let's see here. Contributions ranks
18 out of 40,455.
Lobbying ranks 191 out of 9200 in 2024. Outside spending 21 of
660, 37 million. So, this is I mean it's not massive. This is
one cycle, right? It's 2024.
It's not that big in terms of lobbying per country. Probably
the biggest.
>> Oh, is he investigating the the top nominee for anti-semite
of the year? This is the top nominee for anti-semite of the year,
by the way. Yeah, she did win. She won in the end. Let's go.
I mean, that's a rough L to take, but she is pretty anti-Semitic.
And like you know, like you could expect, everyone on the list
is just celebrating for the most part. Your favorite guy. Shout
out to Guy Christensen. I got an affinity for a guy because he's
a Tik Tocker like >> Dude, how I I'm just going to say
our boy was robbed. He did he he came up with an entire meme
of his own. >> Then you do this >> and he didn't
get >> I didn't do the meme. I didn't do the meme. I'm
just saying this. Okay. This is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give
me Tik Tok. Work for Israel. Give me CBS, work for Israel, give
me the American >> And he and HE COULDN'T EVEN SEEK out
the win. That's so up, dude.
To M. Rachel. That's so funny. >> An OG Tik Tocker. >> And
Guy made the list. He's trying to figure out how to help his
followers vote for him. I'm sure you'll figure it out, guy. Congratulations
on the strong performance this year. Keep up the hard work. Maybe
you should tweet more things like wanting kids to live isn't
Danny Semitic. Maybe, Ben, guy, you could take the top spot next
year. Stu Peters obviously is celebrating. When I win the award
for 2025 anti-semit of the year, I will dedicate to Charlie Kirk,
who gave his life for the cause. Make sure to cast your vote.
See, Ste's out here. Ste's out here. He's speaking the truth.
Ste's known since day one. And he's right. He's right.
Okay. Well, I think that's the whole section. That's probably
all we need here. I think that's all we need. He's moved on to
his next thing here. Okay. That's it for the Fentes stuff uh
from his angle. Okay. We're going to go back. You keep watching.
Nick, I might go back to the beginning of this clip. Okay, we're
going to go back to the beginning of this clip so we can catch
up on Nick's criticisms of Ian Carol's segment and then we'll
be on to the Canada stuff. >> imply you're disingenuous,
but genuinely, when was the last time someone told their audience
to get involved in politics, not just voting, but taking the
helm? >> At this point, I'm convinced that Ian is an operative.
Ian is pro- RFK Jr. He said he he defended Eric Prince repeatedly,
defended the Gaza deal. He's on Joe Rogan with this Cabala bracelet.
You know, you want to know why I think that? It's because I was
talking to him and he was treating me like a robot
because I texted Ian Carol the other day and I said, "You know
what, man? [__] you." I said, "I defended you."
Oh, by the way, I should chill again. Guys, if you like the content,
go ahead. Throw a couple subs my way. All right. Buy a TTS message.
Throw some cash at the stream. Buy kicks. Okay? really buy kick
so you can support kick creators. It's like the easiest way to
super chat. I think there's TTS. If there isn't TTS and you give
a $5 message and include a message, I will read it personally.
Okay, I will be your TTS.
What I would like to reinforce, okay, kicks, kicks are the best.
Give through kicks, okay? I love kicks. Throw the pennies, okay?
Throw pennies at me like you're like you're throwing them like
you're that guy who threw the pennies at Dave Portoy. Okay, throw
pennies one kick at a time. Let's go. I said, "When everybody
was calling you um
an operative because of your Cabala bracelet and whatever," I
said, "I defended you." I said, "And this is how you repay me?
We disagree and now you call me a Fed. That's that's your go-to."
It's not, "Hm, I disagree with him or I don't understand his
position." It's, "Oh, he's a Fed." I said, "You're a trader."
And he just wouldn't He's like just talking right past me.
He's like, "Uh, well, this isn't about >> He does seem
a little bit like a bot." Like, he kind of just gets brainwashed
by somebody and then goes off. Compelling guy, though. >> You
or me? This is about Charlie and blah blah blah. I'm like, "No,
it's about me cuz you're calling me a fed and you're a traitor."
I'll read it to you. These people like something's not right
with these people. I don't know what it is, but something's not
right. I'll read you the conversation. And it was a very weird
conversation. So, I texted him. I said, "You are a really disloyal
person. I went to bat for you when people were calling you a
fed. Now, because I disagree with you, you attack my credibility.
[__] you." He texted me. He said, "Watch the video.
You're way out over your skis, man. Blatantly wrong. And it's
hurting your credibility whether I point it out or not."
Whether I pointed out, "Okay, but you you're not attacking my
credibility. You're calling me a fed. Go rewatch your live stream
segment about me. Did you think I wasn't going to respond? You
asked for evidence, so I produced it.
I said, "You are saying, >> wait, you asked for evidence,
so I produced it." Wait, do we miss a do we miss any Carol's
stream? Cuz he was definitely trying to call Nick a fed, but
maybe we got the wrong stream. >> Has flipped. Disagree
all you want, but insinuating I work for Israel or the FBI, you
are a total piece of [__] When people were attacking
you for your Cabala bracelet, I called that out as paranoia and
said they were being ridiculous. Now we disagree for the first
time and you immediately jump on bad faith accusations saying
I'm controlled op. You are trash. You agreed with me that can
so >> Oh god, we might have watched the wrong VOD. We watched
him talking, but we might have actually watched the wrong VOD
here. And I will say it looks like this entire thing is like
two hours. It's like a massive react. So, I don't think we do
the whole thing. Okay. But I might skip over to where he talks
about the FBI. Okay. Let's see if FBI gets mentioned. Okay. Not
that guy. Not that guy. Different one. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Okay. Okay. Okay. I see.
Dude, he's going through Oh, he's going through a bunch of stuff.
Okay. He's got a seven minutee clip, bro. He went through Okay,
I got to watch it. I'm sorry. I got to watch it.
I got to watch it. He's like trying to do all of the
He's trying to do all of the what do you call the talking points.
Okay. Right >> Applebees. The conspiracy behind Burger
>> See, I've never talked.
>> Hold on.
Wait. Hold on. Hold on.
Okay. He pulls it up. That's why I made the stream that I did
because if anyone should understand what's going on with American
right now, American billionaires, Zionist donors, and the state
right now, what's exactly going on inside of TP USA right now,
it should be Nick Fuentes. And the fact that Nick is shoveling
the fed slop narrative that Jack Pobic and Benny Johnson and
Tim P and Brandon Tatum are all shoveling
>> is really weird.
So if Nick wants to do it, we'll do it. We'll go through his
response
and then we'll show him the evidence that he claims doesn't exist
or that he's never seen or that he something. And I saw Ian Carol
came out
today on a live stream pleading with me to join in on the
>> Wasn't pleading with you, bro. I was
>> Oh, that was the one we watched. Let's >> Asking
you to clarify where you stood. >> Nick, you're like a
general. Nick, you're like the general and you're not here. You're
not on the battlefield with me, Nick. Nick, I'm just a Roman
cowboy and you're my general, Nick. Very weird. Very weird stuff
to be saying.
and you very thoroughly clarified
where you
>> Ian Carol, the conspiracy theorist, he's making videos
about the conspiracy behind Red Lobster, the conspiracy
>> So, first note that Nick is doing what the mainstream
media does where he attaches a little a little like fed. >> Yeah.
Yeah. He's poisoning the well against you 100%.
Here's the thing. That doesn't say that Nick that doesn't say
that you're correct. that says that Nick is secretly a little
concerned that his audience is too dumb to know that you're wrong.
And so he's doing a little poisoning the well on top of it. Okay.
He he is he's a po he's poisoning the well here for sure. Okay.
But that's because deep down in his heart he knows his audience
isn't smart enough to just like actually listen to you and disagree
with you on the merits. So he's going to poison the well a little
bit too. Jacket to the start of your name. Alex Jones the crazy
conspiracy theorist. Nick Fuentes the anti-semitic.
Ian Carol, the conspiracy theorist.
Actually, Nick, what you're referring to is the fact that corporations
often engage in collusion, conspiracy, corruption. Okay. The
the Red Lobster thing was kind of funny though, right? You know
what I'm saying? You guys have seen the Red Lobster thing where
that company bought it and they just like made it a restaurant
because what was it like? It's like the the corporation that
makes the most or or ships like the most lobsters, right? It
was like a Thai food joint that buys a bunch of restaurants and
makes them and just runs them like super cheap,
right? And all sorts of other And you're referring to a really
dope episode that I did when I was hosting Candace's show while
she was on maternity leave where I tied together the fact that
Red Lobster had colluded with their shrimp supplier in order
to manipulate prices. Right. The endless shrimp. That's what
it was about. Yeah.
Extort cash. And it actually ties directly into a global marketplace
of slavery that is fueling the entire shrimp industry and the
fact that every time you buy shrimp at the grocery store, you're
almost certainly buying slave fararmed shrimp. And it's wild.
And once you learn about that story, you'll never eat shrimp
the same way. See, that's fun. What happened to that Ian Carol?
You know, it sounds like he got some facts. It sounds like he
grabbed some facts and he did like some
on the ground journalism
and he proved this out maybe, but like it it wasn't like you
didn't just go like I really hate Thai people. I think Tai people
are responsible for a lot of the problems in the world. I think
the Thai union group PCL, okay, is behind Red Lobster
endless shrimp stuff that that got cancelled or whatever. I think
that's actually them. And then you set out to prove it. That's
not what you did there,
way again. But I'm digressing into talking about journalism.
And you were talking about something else.
>> Applebee's, the conspiracy behind Burger
>> See, I've never talked about Applebee's or Burger King.
He's just doing a little label to try to characterist before
he gets into his arguments. >> I agree. I agree with Ian
Carol. Yeah, he's po. does a live stream tonight and says,
"Where where are you, Nick? We're all aligned on this against
the and you are agreeing with Crowder and Tim and everybody else."
I'm not against the
I'm aligned towards the narrative makes no sense. We have plenty
of evidence to say the narrative doesn't make sense. And when
you look around to see who the most likely culprit is once that
narrative doesn't make sense,
there's pretty much an obvious answer. And we don't have proof
of that. We haven't solved the case yet. That's what journalists
do is they try to figure out. You're welcome to join.
We need you. Why are you with them? And I would say with Ian
Carol, where's the evidence? What even is that? >> Sit
tight. We got it coming here for you, bud. He's going to do Oh
my god. He's going to do all of it for us. We don't even have
to do work. He's going to show and he's the guy. He's the preeminent
guy,
right? Like he's going to go through Nick complaining about this
and then he's going to show the evidence for all this stuff.
And I'm excited because I love conspiracy theories and I would
love to believe this. But when Candace presents, she doesn't
present
anything. She is the worst prover of any conspiracy theory ever.
She is dog at it. Okay. So, the idea that Nick might go, "Oh,
Nick, you Nick Fentes, sorry." The idea that Ian might go, "Hey,
Nick Fentes, you think I'm lying?" Well, here's the evidence
and facts, brother. Well, I'm I'm here for that. Let's go. Was
this dude always a conspiracy bro? He has, as far as I've been
concerned, always been a conspiracy bro. Never seen him not doing
conspiracy stuff.
Everything other than evidence. They're going to say, "Well,
is this real everybody else?" >> Nope. That's not what
anybody's saying,
>> Okay. People die all the time. That's an easy one.
>> people die all the time.
>> so this is called a straw man argument where when you
don't want to argue the actual points >> or the actual
evidence, you stand up a straw man in the field and pretend like
that's the argument that you're opposed to and that the other
person's arguing, then you knock it over like, "Ha, I won the
argument." >> No sir, that's a straw man.
>> And there are a lot of school shootings and assassinations.
This stuff happens with regularity.
Was Israel behind Luigi Manion? >> Straw man argument has
nothing to do with this. And by my understanding, no. Haven't
seen any evidence that Israel was behind it. Luigi Manion. >> Why
or why not.
Was Israel behind the school shooting in Colorado that happened
on the same day? >> Straw man argument. Haven't seen any
evidence. Haven't looked into it nearly as deeply. I have no
idea. >> Why or why not?
The evidence Candace had was like basically her hearsay from
within TPSA thinks she'd heard and it turned out to all be wrong.
The hearsay you based this on was entirely
Entirely incorrect. The whole point was Charlie was sincerely
thinking about leaving the Israel first movement. He was not.
And that was proven when Candace said he sent BB a letter really
setting him straight. And then that letter got leaked and it
had nothing in there at all like that. Not even remotely. It
got entirely blown up. Was Israel behind the shooting of Trump?
Why or why not? >> Straw man argument. But on that case,
actually, I have questions about who was behind that cuz it was
a seriously obvious cover up.
So, Israel would be a suspect in my mind, but I don't know.
>> Bro, we need we need to get on these YouTubers with
the lazy eyes, okay? These YouTubers are the lazy. It's like
if you lie a lot,
every single time God just slightly disalines your eyes, okay?
>> It's like Pinocchio, but your eyes start facing opposite
directions.
Okay, it's it's like Pinocchio, but your eyes just start facing
in opposite directions and gets Okay, this is how you know. Just
God's just like, "Yep, just a little bit. We just move your eye
a little bit. You got We just move it a little bit. >> A
little bit. A little bit. A little bit. Stop lying.
I don't know if any of those people blamed Israel for the shooting
of
>> No, I don't want to [__] UP YOUR VISION.
STOP LYING. >> I don't think so. Really? >> Trump
was Israel behind the Las Vegas
>> Straw man argument. Nope. And I produced content about
that and you could have watched it and realize that. >> Wait,
I thought that one was one they did blame on the god damn. He
debunked it. He debunked the being behind Banderlay Bay. What?
Okay, hold on. I
reset my hair really quick. One second. We're good. We're good.
We're good. We're good. I did not blame Israel for it. It's possible
that they're involved because it kind of seems like some complicated
geopolitics going on,
but I don't know.
Why or why not? Well, I know. Hold on. I know the Saudis were
there, but the Saudis would have wanted to be there and then
take the off your hair. So, it is long. Um, it's a little bit
long right now. Yeah. It's just I wear like a hair band most
of the time. Because the heristic seems to be Israel is behind
literally everything. >> Nope. No one's saying that, Nick.
That's a straw man argument. And it's pretty funny coming from
you.
Literally everything. Not. Now, to be clear, I do think while
he is talking to Ian Carol, I think Nick Fuentes is webbing Ian
Carol onto Candace Owens a little bit and is probably saying,
"No, it's not that long, Ry." Um he's probably saying that Candace
is blaming Israel for a lot of and you do have to say it's like
very suspicious the way Candace has webbed in. Okay. France and
Mcronone and Egypt and Israel all into the same thing. They're
all doing together like which she already had beef with all of
these people, right? Everybody she has had beef with is webbed
into this conspiracy theory. It seems a little suspicious, a
little too convenient, a little on the nose. >> Most not
in an anti-semitic way, not things we condemn.
>> Hold on. Hello,
>> we got another donation from Marmadude. Thank you for
the gifted sub, Marma dude. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Appreciate
it. Appreciate it. I think
[__] Yeah, I think based on the amount of money we
made on this stream, I don't know if we're going to take I don't
know if I'm going to shill a lot more or I don't know if I'm
going to do the timer. Might just move the timer out and go until
I feel like it. I'll shill more, but I'm just going to move the
timer and go until we feel like we're done. >> Demonstrate
with evidence. No, there >> see how he act. He's saying
hairband meaning hair tie. No, I have like the one of those little
like wire things that you put and you click your hair back. One
of those >> actually almost got to what people actually
say is things we can demonstrate with evidence. But no, that's
not what the argument is. I'm putting up a straw man so I can
knock it >> Behind literally everything. And if they're
behind literally everything in the past, then it's safe to assume
they're behind literally everything in the future.
>> No one's saying that. >> And that is ridiculous.
That doesn't make any sense. Why? Um, I will say Nick's incredibly
lazy with how he's going about this. If you just look at the
actual stuff they say and the way they connect things. Like I've
watched a bunch of Candace's stream. She doesn't connect things
at all. She just says like this is a fact fact.
This as a pattern seems weird. And I'm like I you've given no
indication that it's pattern or related. You just throw a bunch
of random facts in here and then say that they're related. But
I've seen no evidence they're related. You've shown no evidence
they're related. It's just like a whole bunch of things. You
put down all of these like random disconnected facts and they
go, "That's weird. You haven't proven
proven >> Harley Kirk was Israel's top guy. >> Yeah.
Go on. >> I don't know how much more clear you >> I
don't know why he used a U there instead of an O. Seems kind
of weird. >> You could make it. And here's a perfect example.
Hey, Ian Carol.
Actually, real quick before we get to his Max Nordau talking
points, let's review something. Charlie Kirk was Israel's top
guy.
And then we got a leak coming out of Harrison Smith saying, "I'm
not going to name names, but I was told by someone close to Charlie
Kirk that Charlie thinks Israel will kill him if he turns against
them."
That was tweeted on August 13th of this year,
a month before Charlie Kirk was assassinated by Lord knows who.
>> Wow. And I might point out that it's a reply to a video
where I was supporting Nick and calling out Charlie and Ben Shapiro
for not debating Nick.
First piece of evidence drops in, but it's just a rumor. Um,
while that is evidence, that is like incredibly weak evidence,
right? Like how much of what Harrison Smith says when he does
something like that, if he memes about something like that, how
much of that is reliable and is like reproducible?
Well, I say like I would say that this is not nothing. It's not
absolutely nothing. You would need more to claim that this actually
happened than just Harrison Smith sort of doing innuendo and
then other people running off Harrison Smith's innuendo, right?
Yeah. I'm not even going to do the thing where a lot of people
would look at that and they go, "Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, that's
that's not evidence at all." No, it's like kind of evidence.
It's like kind of it's like a thing that you could it could point
you in a direction to look for something more concrete, but it
is not evidence that the thing happened. It's just like something
that's like hearsay that could point you in a direction. That's
the best it but you have to you have to handle it that way. You
can't handle that and say well actually because this is what
he did earlier. This is what Candace has done. Well, actually
people close to Charlie were saying that he thought Israel was
going to kill him. One, this tweet is basically invalid because
there's no indication and I'm telling you zero indication that
Charlie was going to turn against Israel.
Doesn't exist. Doesn't exist. And Candace insisting it existed
has made her look like a complete fool. Not to her detriment
in any way, but again, just totally blown out on this point.
No indication that this Charlie is going to betray Israel, is
going to work against Israel, is going to do anything but suck
Israel's.
But anyway, we continue >> until it was corroborated by
multiple sources, by multiple other journalists,
multiple angles,
albeit this reporting was after Charlie Kirk was. But let's just
say that
this reporting by Max Blumenthal.
Um, let's see. Charlie Kirk refused Netanyahu funding offer,
was frightened by pro-Israel forces before death, friend reveals.
Let's put that in the old Google search here. Let me duplicate
this. Oh, hold on. Actually, I need this time stamp first. We'll
go right here. And then journalism.
Let's put it in here. Charlie Kirk refused Netanyahu
funding offer Max
Let's go to this article from black from Max Blumenthal. This
is a couple weeks ago. Hold on. Let me go to the Greyzone article
and see who is being referenced here. Trump insider, longtime
friend of Charlie Kirk, tells the Greyzone how the assassinating
conservative leaders turning point on Israeli influence provoked
a private backlash from Netanyahu Yahoo's allies that left him
angry and afraid. Wait, who is the friend? The source told the
Grey Zone that the late proTrump influencer believed Netanyahu
was trying to cow him into silence. Is there any sourcing to
this article at all?
Cuz all I want to know is is this is this Candace Owens herself
or somebody like very close to Candace Owens, right? I can't
see a name here. I I literally don't see I didn't see names.
According to Kirk's friend, according to his longtime friend,
Kirk's friend recalled, "The Friends account dovetales with those
of multiple right-wing commentators with access to Kirk." And
then this will be Candace Owens who said, "Yeah, I guess um I
think in the end Charlie's going to go through a spiritual transformation."
A friend said to me, interesting
hold on. Who is this? Kelly, I have less blah blah blah blah.
Megan Kelly appeared visibly. Oh, this is his his interview with
Megan Kelly. He was mad about people criticizing him for not
being pro-Israel enough when he's like the most pro-Israel person.
I do not believe in any way that that means he was going to turn
against Israel. I don't see it. And it's inconsistent with his
private actions. Totally
How long ago was the Desh Duza Nick Fentes debate where Charlie
Kirk was messaging uh Duza saying, "Do not platform this guy.
Do not platform this guy. Do not platform this guy." When was
that? Hold on. Nick Fuentes
Desh
Soua debates. This was from October 29th, 2025. No, no, no, no,
no. July 3rd, 2025. So, it would have been around the time a
lot of this stuff was happening, right?
Why was
why was Charlie doing Israel's bidding and trying to deplatform
Fuentes, who Charlie disagrees with basically on Israel alone
at this point? Why was he why was he telling Tuza not to debate
him? Right. Tech show. So this is when it got leaked that Charlie
was like trying to get Desh to cancel.
But why did that happen if Charlie was like actually oh Israel
is actually really bad. Turns out July 1st 2025
I just don't see it man. Journalism has been picking up this
vibe pretty thoroughly for quite some time. You can read into
some of this reporting and I know Nick Fuentes hates our boy
Max Blumenthal and the Gropers will say he's
>> reporting is reporting and he's got a pretty good track
record but feel free to wait does he
wait does Max Blumenthal have a pretty good track record actually?
I don't know. Isn't the Grey Zone a total rag? I mean it's anti-Israel
but it like it's pretty motivated and it's anti-Israel takes.
I'm I'm pretty sure
like it's not
I don't know if I could say it's the worst. I read it when the
Charlie Kirkite stories came out but that even even there I noticed
the sourcing was not great. Like it was a lot of circular sourcing.
It was like Candace or a friend that's unnamed like nobody's
on the record at all. They were the ones reporting that Vosch
was CIA backed.
No shot that happened. What?
Vous vouch video CIA backed.
No say it ain't so. >> Discount it and move on to the next
Charlie Kirk refused Netanyahu funding offer was frightened by
pro-Israel forces before death. Friend reveals a Trump insider
and longtime friend of Charlie Kirk tells the Grey Zone how the
assassinated conservative leaders turning point on Israeli influence
provoked a private backlash from Netanyahu's allies that left
him angry and afraid. Charlie Kirk rejected an offer earlier
this year from Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu to arrange
a massive new infusion of Zionist money into his Turning Point
USA organization.
In the weeks leading up to his September 10th assassination,
Kirk had come to loathe the Israeli leader, regarding him as
a bully. The source said Kirk was disgusted by what he witnessed
inside the Trump administration where Netanyahu sought to personally
dictate the president's personal decisions.
Kirk strongly warned Trump last
>> now last June against bombing Iran on Israel's behalf
>> against bombing Iran. >> So it sounds like he
was really upset and then Desh Duza I believe went to go debate
Nick Fuentes on bombing Iran
right is that not what we found here that this was actually
Iran war debate Desh Duza versus Nick Fuentes. So why then if
Charlie thought oh no the US really needs to not do this did
he go and say hey Desh you can't go and debate Nick Fuentes on
Iran. You can't do it, man. Why? Why did he do that? If he thought
these people sucked and that this needed to not happen, why wouldn't
he just let Nick do his work? Why wouldn't he just let Nick like
own this guy or something? And on Israel's behalf, Charlie was
the only person who did that. They said he was afraid of them.
The source emphasized.
the other thing you could, >> okay, this is this is the
one that I think is most like discredited
>> Nick, if you wanted to clarify
exactly how Charlie felt about Israel is you could read his own
text messages,
which I can't help but notice that you seem to never mention.
And I can't help but notice that you were on the same side as
all the people dog piling saying that this is
>> we had all Zionist coming out. This is literally just
Charlie venting, right? Like all of Charlie's work for so long
was to build up the Zionist cause within the right-wing movement.
And then he's like, "You guys are getting really sensitive. You've
played every stereotype. I'm going to have to leave is the Israel
the pro-Israel cause at this like at this rate." That's to me
that's what he's saying here. And that's proven out by him continuing
to have all these solid relationships with all of these people.
I don't know if we can find somebody else to back this up. Why
will nobody back this up,
right? I think Josh Hammer came and leaked more of these. Now,
I can't remember exactly where those went. And Josh Hammer's
a disgusting freak, but I I remember there being that I remember
looking into this at the time and it's like, oh, seems pretty
obvious Charlie's just venting. trying to whitewash Charlie's
perspective on Israel just like you might expect in this scenario
until Candace Owens dropped these text messages. Quote, "Donors
play into all the stereotypes. I cannot and will not be bullied
like this, leaving me no choice but to leave the pro-Israel cause."
He sent that to a group text chat with a bunch of his big donors
in
>> You think he was just kid? Oh, here's this one's at
least a little better. Oh, this is this is the same text chat
with his donors on September 9th.
Thank you guys for the help today. Good luck. Uh, as campus visits
start, don't hesitate to let me know or any of us know how I
can help. What's your first stop tomorrow, by the way? Honored
to be of assistance. Utah Valley. Say hi to your Antifa friends.
Bless.
Right. So like uh these are literally Charlie Charlie's final
messages in in that WhatsApp WhatsApp chat. Like he literally
is still talking to these people, still totally on board with
these people. So the idea is Ian. Now listen, if Ian goes and
talks about those and doesn't leave those out, then I'm starting
to you know, I'm going, "Oh, maybe he's maybe he's cooking here
a little bit around. >> We'll see." >> Or does this
not qualify as evidence to
>> But right, he was Israel's number one
>> is this the Megan Kelly thing? >> You know how
you know a lot about the history
of
organized crime Nick the mob >> Kennedy I hear I hear tell
they Kennedy >> you know what happens to someone when they
try to leave the mob when they try to walk away let alone when
they become a traitor.
In fact, his closeness to the whole situation, his closeness
to Israel is one of the best and biggest arguments for why Israel
is a suspect.
Similar to how when a wife is killed,
you should probably look at her husband.
And it's something like 40% of married women that are are killed
by this guy. We need to look at Erica Kirk. Erica Kirk Charlie,
I heard she wasn't there that day. Little did we realize she
wasn't there in any official capacity. Okay. Some form of lover.
>> I don't know how much more clear you could make it.
And here's a perfect example. Hey Ian Carol, why did you on >> this
part's amazing? September 7th
tweet at Charlie Kirk. You're working for the
Jesus
on se Okay, so we Okay, so he had like a good idea of what Ian
Carol thought before Charlie was killed. All right, he didn't
believe this at all before Charlie was killed. So then it's just
down to those text messages and stuff to see what he believes
after. I'm still looking for him to include this stuff from Josh
Hammer, which is showing the ending of like the end state of
that relationship with those people where he's like, I have to
leave the pro Israel movement. But he's still talking to that
same group of donors over and over again. Uh,
>> September 7th, 2025,
you tweeted that Charlie Kirk is working for the the
>> Was I wrong? And I didn't say the to Jesus. You know
what I said >> on? Wait, what did he say? Wait, what? Hold
on. What did he say? No, that's not the right guy. Ian Carol
show. Ian Carol show. Right. This guy. Okay, hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. I'm I'm going to find it. You're You're working for
the juice.
Oh, I don't see it here, dude. I can't find the tweet. Charlie
Kirk. Don't see it. Don't see it. Don't see it. Don't see it.
Oh,
Jesus. Oh, hold on. That'll be it, right? It's not. Okay. Well,
can't find the tweet. I'm not looking forward. >> September
11th, you were absolutely certain that Israel him.
>> Actually, that's not what I tweeted. But first, Nick,
>> why does he show Show me what you
Why don't he show me what he tweeted? Oh, here we go. Jesus defeated
death so you can live.
>> Isn't it kind of weird that you're using a
Mac? You've dedicated your life to serving the people who killed
him. What is he and Carol even signaling about there? What is
he What is he signaling about? Uh, I didn't tweet about Okay,
what did you mean here exactly? I didn't say that to them. Wait,
what did you mean here when you said and you've dedicated your
life to serving the people who killed him? I'm just I'm I just
really love to know what precisely
were you going for when you said the people who killed him. He
meant Romans, Italians. Did he?
Did he though? Did he have a group chat with Italians where he
said, "I think I'm leaving. I think where he said, I'm thinking
of leaving the pro Italy movement." Is that what he said?
and uh rich rich Italian billionaires are going to make me leave
the pro-Italian movement. Okay. Rich Italian billionaires,
they lean into all the stereotypes. Did he say these things?
Yosi Gastinter
and Leo Terrell talking point.
Oh, for a guy who could identify fallacies, he's sure falling
apart now. Um, do you think you could really point out that I
said Charlie worked for the when it was retweeted by cancel me?
Can you really use that as a talking point? Yeah. Yep, I can.
I can indeed.
Isn't
a little weird? I think that's a little weird, Nick.
Look, no claim. No claim. No claim. No actual factual rejection
of anything Nick said. Just Isn't that weird that like some tweeted
this as well? I don't say I was tweeting about the That's not
what I tweeted. Huh? But let's look at what I Everything is weird,
guys. Everything It's like the book, right? Everything on the
the idiots guide to arguing on the internet. Everything I don't
like is Everything I don't like is weird. It's all weird. Everything
is weird.
In an Ian Carol/ Candace bingo card, possibly. Yeah, good idea.
>> Yesterday was a turning point for Israel US relations.
less than 24 hours and the internet already figured out who the
most likely culprit is. The most
likely culprit.
Sorry, I said was. >> I mean, you end the tweet with Israel
just shot themselves. >> What? 4 hours and the internet
already figured out who the most likely culprit is. The most
likely culprit.
Sorry, I said was. He was their friend. He basically dedicated
his life to them and they murdered him in front of his family.
Israel just shot themselves. And Nick, I don't think I need to
educate you about being a little bombastic on the internet. Okay,
but you're not saying you're bombastic. You're saying that he's
lying about you. And he was just 100% correct in every single
thing he said about you. Like every single thing he said is true.
He said, it's really weird. Okay. It's odd to me, and by odd
I mean totally disingenuous and fake and grifting if you say
two days before Charlie dies that he is serving the who killed
Jesus. Serving the people who killed Jesus. Okay. And then
right after that saying, well, they definitely killed him and
he was their friend.
It's just it's very weird that he's like a was he just not a
good enough? He was like the best. He was the goodest guy. How
could he Why would they him? I guess he's saying I mean just
to be clear his argument is well it's because he was going to
turn his back on them. Again I think there is no real solid indication
that that is the case. Don't think that's true. I think he was
getting irritated. I don't think those those irritations were
going to amount to anything. He was still vehemently pro-Israel
on everything. And I stand by this tweet >> because he
was I don't know why he's pretending he's mad at Fentes about
>> This close to telling the truth and he died for it.
So what changed in those four days? Exactly. >> What changed
in those four days, Nick?
Um, this happened >> over the last 10 years. Counting or
not >> You just going to show the whole thing? Oh, no.
>> I think he got a frame of it though, dude.
Me. POV. You're about to throw up the guy St. Charlie getting
murdered on the stream. >> You're not counting.
Bet you didn't think I'd throw up the clip of Charlie getting
merked on my stream, did you? Bet you didn't think I'd do that,
did you, Fuentes? You little bet you didn't think I'd just throw
up the clip of Charlie getting merked. I think his eye just moved
another millimeter off center. By the way, unlucky, right? Charlie
Kirk got shot in the neck.
What irrefutable proof did you get in those four days on September
7th? You said Charlie
>> No one said irrefutable proof, but I'll let you finish
your sentence. Kirk is working for the that Jesus on September
11th, the day after he was you were certain be okay. Saying he
shot them. Now Nick's Nick's out on a ledge a little bit here
in that Ian Carol did say on September 11th. It looks like the
k the guy who was working for them doesn't make any so but I
I agree that's like a contradiction. It feels like a contradiction
unless you have some good evidence. So doesn't say and Carol
either. I don't know a shadow of a doubt that Israel >> that's
actually not what I said him to silence him. How does that even
happen before we had a suspect be? >> Actually, Nick, we'd
already had two
if you recall.
One of them was this guy.
This guy should never been talked about in
>> We don't know if IT'S HIM OR NOT.
ON SEPTEMBER 11TH,
we were fed this critical piece of fed slop. Okay, this is the
best part. Okay, where the feds are like, you know what we should
do? I heard I you know, we we just watched Charlie get killed.
They told us to cover it up. And you know what would be really
funny for a meme? If we threw a rifle in there where the story
would make no sense. Let's use like a 30 odd six that I think
would totally obliterate his clavicle and then the story will
make no sense. We're going to plant a gun and we're going to
plant the least believable gun so internet conspiracy theorists
have a chance. What do you guys think? You guys think that'd
be funny? Be like a really funny little meme. We do. We We plant
a gun that makes the whole story make no sense. Yeah, let's go.
Let's go. >> Which you appear to be defending a boltaction
rifle, which this technically is actually not a photo of the
weapon, which will become very relevant later. This is just some
other photo that the news agencies dug up, but the FBI and law
enforcement told us on that day that Charlie was shot with a
306.
And that's really all you need to know to know that you're Nick.
And I'm going to get into all the evidence about that in just
a little bit. Okay. So then it's like the FBI was not intentionally
behind it. They're like totally incompetent, which we all agree
on. And somebody else was planting all the evidence. It's like,
okay, what evidence do you have that somebody else was planting
all the evidence? Is it that the guy who's the psy is saying
I didn't do it? No. Is it that you have like some breaking evidence
that has come out of nowhere that's like been leaked online or
some state actors like said taken responsibility? No. What What
evidence is there? But
no, I did not say we have irrefutable proof that Israel has done
it. I said that the world had pretty much figured out who the
most likely culprit is. And that's because we had already figured
out that the narrative that the feds were giving to us, you know,
the really trustworthy FBI that you're shilling the narrative
of,
their narrative was already obviously
24 hours later. And we had plenty of evidence by then if you'd
been paying attention to presume that. I really don't think so.
But maybe maybe there's some really good information that I'll
think is super strange. I tried looking into a lot of this stuff.
It just it didn't work, man. I tried. I tried. I tried. I tried.
And that might still be that he What if he was killed by legate
actor or something? It's not impossible.
It's just
like not proven. There's just nothing that pushes you in that
direction right >> Before we knew any of the facts, any
of it. Actually, Nick, when you're doing journalism,
the things that happen each and every moment of an investigation
of a coverup
is that is that what he's doing? He's doing journalism. >> Those
are facts, too. Facts aren't just what the FBI. Although, I will
say, okay, I I do make fun of him. Um, I think I made fun of
him on the diddy thing. Although to be fair, that was because
of all the like super
signaling he was doing where he had to pull up the early life
section of every single Wikipedia game he could find and show
that they were I was like this is bizarre,
right? But that ended up being like having legs and Diddy ended
up going to jail later. It wasn't the same investigation or whatever,
but like some of the stuff claimed in there was about how did
he had like all the bodies of bottles of baby oil, how he was
people, how somebody got shot in his house. So, I do think there
was pieces of the story there that I sort of discounted cuz he
was looking into it, which was probably not fair.
So, I I will say there are things he says that sometimes I'm
like I'm hesitant to believe that do end up being true. So, I'm
not going to discount everything he says, just like the things
he claims and then can't back up at all or the things that he
claims and then says he can back up and then hasn't done that
one extra step of like, oh, is there actual like counter evidence
at all? Oh, yeah, there is. Okay, cool. Yeah, he tells you are
facts. Facts are what the FBI does along the way, what citizen
journalists do along the way, what videos come out, all information.
And by then, we had 24 hours of it. And that's all we needed
to know. You knew for sure they did it.
So, do you have ESP?
Are you omnisient? Do you have
>> See his uh rhetorical techniques here? This is like
uh this is actually just a Warren Smith stream, isn't it? It's
like a Warren Smith stream. Let's go,
dude. Can we get the Can we get the >> I don't think so.
This is a grift. >> Who do you think makes more money online,
Nick? You or me? >> This is a grift. It is intellectually
>> Then I presume that because you're not intellectually
lazy, you'll watch this entire video to the end and watch all
of the sources that I'm going to show you. And maybe you'll even
read some sources for yourself.
It is dishonest.
>> Nope. Haven't lied.
>> You are making assumptions that
you cannot rationally make. >> Let's keep that in mind.
Assumptions you cannot rationally make.
Rationality is going to be a big part of this conversation. And
if you want to destroy your credibility, that's fine. >> Not
bothered. Very proud of the content I put out. about to be very
proud of the content I'm about to put out. Have at it. Show us
your sources, Nick. >> If you want to destroy your credibility
by blaming Israel for the number one Israel defender in America,
that is your
But don't try to rope me into it and guilt me or whatever it
is you're trying to do, saying we we >> Actually, Nick,
I was trying to extend a hand to you under the assumption that
you're an honest and good actor.
to encourage you to look at the evidence before you
do this because we all know the evidence.
And you seem to be under the impression that I'm on I'm arguing
right now that Candace Owens is right about everything. And that
is not at all what I'm arguing.
And you're going to notice as you watch this video that none
of the evidence I'm going to present is Candace Owens saying
things. It's actually almost all sourced from before she even
said a word because she took a whole week off and we were >> uh
all the stuff you already sourced was some Cish
the Max Blumenthal stuff was all supported by Candace, right?
I think that came out at roughly the same time. >> We're
all busy figuring this out before she even entered the fray.
>> We're all on this side and you're over there. I've been
over here, bro. Where were you? I've been over here. I was at
>> Kind of a funny kind of a funny point, but you're right,
Nick. You've been in the game for a long >> Is it a funny
point? >> Long time. And you might have noticed that I
specifically praised you for how long you've been in the game.
>> Oh, hello.
>> Anonymous. Thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Thank
you. Thank you. >> I've been pretty outspoken in my support
of Nick Fuentes. I've been pretty um pretty into Nick's rise
and
you know, regardless of disagreements about specific things that
Nick says, uh I'm pretty much generally excited that Nick is
entering the mainstream and the normal conversation. I like how
Nick forces us all to challenge our ideas and forces people to
think more critically about ideas that we didn't even realize
we should be thinking about. I like that his ideas are controversial.
I see playing the VOD from his same stream. I like that they're
complicated and they're backed up by a uh intense Oh, the music
is from Warren Smith. Warren Smith uses music at the end of all
of his videos, right? And I'm like, dude, he's doing like a Warren
Smith bit right now. It's very funny.
Although, I think he to be in his defense, I do think he live
I think he live streamed this. He live streamed this one. Maybe
this is edited though. I think the problem with Warren Smith
is he gives like live stream tier commentary while doing edited
videos that like I think a lot of people can do that tier of
commentary on off the cuff and maybe even be better and Warren
Smith does like fully edited videos that just aren't great intellect.
And I like that he uh has the backstory of 10 years of hard work
to make it happen. There's a lot of things I like about Nick
and
obviously the >> a lot of things I love about him. I mean
Nick Fentes. >> The thing that most of us like the most
about Nick is his stance on Israel. I need to kind of amend that
statement now that you've made a more complete one.
>> Uhoh. We really admire and like at least I really admire
and like you're the intense intellect you apply to your opinions
usually.
Except this one is a glaring departure from that norm, Nick.
And it's kind of awkward. And that's why I'm saying this. Ian's
like, "Usually, Nick, you flip a coin and like 95 times out of
100 it comes up." And now it's like 50/50, not what the Nick,
what the [__] Because it's really weird, dude. It's
really weird.
And I know I'm not the only one that is noticing. Lest I remind
you, where were you in 2017? Were you at Burning Man? Sorry.
Were you in some commune in Portland? I was at Charlottesville
in 20 He does look like a hippie. Okay.
17. I love this part. Baseless. Baseless
ad homum. I think I don't know. Where's Queenman? He always reminds
me I don't know what ad hom means. I think it's just a baseless
character attack. Basic baseless appearance attack. Let's up
>> I actually I'll tell you where I was in 2017 in just
a second. And Nick's not super far off the mark, which I think
is >> He goes, "We're all over here fighting the good fight.
You and who?"
>> Um, real quick, let's just remember, you can be based,
you can be cool, you can be red pill distributing for generations
as far as I'm concerned, and you can make one wrong handshake.
Oh no.
He's comparing him to Jordan Peterson.
One wrong mistake
and sell your soul. And I'm not s Mr. Fuentes, you need to clean
your room. You are disgusted. >> Suggesting that Nick has
shook the BB hand, so to speak. That's not what I'm suggesting.
I'm just pointing out that plenty of based
have fallen off and Jordan Peterson. Hold on.
Didn't Jordan Jordan Peterson like super wasn't he like a super
Zionist like way before he ever really got involved with the
Daily Wire? I thought there was like a really old stream of him
basically people were trying to get him to like denounce people
and he's like the are special and you should respect them,
right? I'm pretty confident there's like a super old stream of
of that whole convers I remember like I think I I was browsing
like poll back in those days. Okay. I remember that coming up
of like, oh, looks like Jordan Peterson isn't based after all.
Now, I didn't take that seriously, okay, but I'm just saying
that like he that exists and he was like that from the beginning.
He was always going to be pro-Israel probably, I think. And just
cuz you've been here for 10 years doesn't mean you get a free
pass on telling everyone what we're supposed to feel about Israel,
Zionism,
Charlie Kirk, etc. You're going to need to show some evidence
each and every time because I >> he just said three things
he basically thinks are the same thing. Like his ven diagram
of Zionists
and people who are >> Israel has been here for 10 years
doesn't mean you get a free pass on telling everyone what we're
supposed to feel about Israel Zionism. >> He definitely
thinks that he definitely thinks the ven diagram of those three
things is a circle. Okay.
You can't tell me what to think about or
>> Charlie etc. >> Charlie Kirk. Okay. Actually,
never mind. All four of them are circle
or aspiration aspirationally.
Each and every time >> cuz I don't trust you. I don't trust
anyone and none of you should trust me. You should all judge
the tree by its fruits.
And when the tree starts shaking the wrong hands and hanging
out with some fetty,
you should ask some questions.
Um, now, as for where I was in 2017, Nick is going to love this
part, but
I'll tell you. Um, where did I pull these up?
Now, I think this part's hilarious cuz Nick's not super far off.
I mean, I grew up as a leftist. I was living in Washington State
before this and in 2017.
No, no, he got soul red.
IAN. NO.
Many such cases.
I'm pretty sure Tuck dude. Nick Fentes was Candace before it
was cool. He was just like he pondered the orb. He's like, I
think Tucker's a spy. I think Tucker's dad was a spy. And then
it comes out Tucker's dad is a spy and he's like, I think this
guy is a hippie loser. and he comes out. Yeah, I was from Washington
State. Yeah, this mustache is vestigial. It It was something
that was helpful to me in my previous life and no longer. Okay.
Not a lot of anti-semmites love the mustache, but I keep it.
I painted my Subaru Outback. Yes, that is correct. With a mural
of the mountains from where I came from and some [__]
trippy hipard on the top and I hit the road with all my rock
climbing gear and I went down to Utah. BRO,
EVERYTHING ABOUT THIS GUY'S APPEARANCE makes sense now
to Indian Creek. Pulled into the creek. Did a whole bunch of
crack climbing down there. Met a bunch of >> absolutely
completely and utterly soul red. There is just nothing else.
Dude, how do you post this and you don't think you lost? You
lost automatically that this guy just made a throwaway comment
about what a hippie you were and he absolutely soul read you
to this extent. It's over. Give up,
homies. I was totally solo. This is before I had a dog. Climbed
a whole bunch of red rock. Then I drove down to Mexico and climbed
in Potro Chico. Um, this was like across several months, maybe
three, four months. Um, took a huge fall in Potro Chico and hurt
my back. Um, [__] super. And that is when he learned
not to trust the Okay. Israeli company made his climbing gear.
>> Scary. Drove all the way down to Guatemala. I have a
photo of that here somewhere. Went down to Guatemala. hung out
in Guatemala for a while. Um, worked at a treehouse hotel avocado
farm down there for a couple of months through the
Stop. STOP. STOP. YOU GOT to stop. Ian, you got to stop. I don't
want to know more. Please stop. For the love of God, man. Please
quit. >> Christmas holidays. Had a crazy drive down through
Mexico on the Bro, we're not even going to make it to Candace.
This is actually good content way down there. This is like Candace
Owens mixed.
It's Candace Owens
mixed with our boy Warren Smith
but without any color mixing. Okay. Just like but super white.
Um I got stories we're not going to get into. And then on the
way back up I visited Yoseite and I went to a whole bunch of
music festivals on the way back up actually. And I worked harm
reduction at a bunch of music festivals where you roam around
all night and save kids that took too much drugs. Um, and it's
a really fun job and I'm super dude dude
dude dude dude we're good at it and I had a great By the way,
none of this makes him a bad person. Okay, none of it makes him
a bad person. I'm not like actually making fun of him for it.
It's just really funny that Nick Fentos was like, "Oh, go back
to Burning Man, you freak." And he and he's like, "Yeah, I am
like a former hippie total total burnout." Boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom. Like a thousand stories right out of
time. And um but I didn't go to Burning Man. Um Burning Man is
a whole other thing. Um and then eventually I made it back to
Bellingham and this was by then it was 2018. So that's where
I was in 2017. Nick, in case you wanted to know you and Canens
who was working at Daily Wire last year,
>> dude. Dude, the best part about that is that with how
researched Nick is, you didn't think he You think he didn't know?
Oh, no. He probably did know. But I think um it's just really
funny that Nick made a throwaway comment about him being a hippie
and he was like, "Well, yes, I am a hippie." And here's like
a ton of hippie stories. So, how about that, Nick? It's like,
well, you just made him look credible, actually. You just made
you made him look totally credible for some reason. I don't know
why you did that. Do you want to know just how accurate that
statement was, Nick? Here you here. Look, look at all these photo
albums. Look,
do you see? Do you do you see? Can we get the red dragon scene
with Nick Fentes and Ian Carol, please? Um,
red dragon slide scene. Yeah, slideshow scene. Can we get this
with Ian Carol, Nick Fentes?
>> Maybe not the naked part so much.
>> You let me go now. >> Wait, wait, where is it?
There we go. Yes, right here.
>> Nick Fentes here. Ian Carol right here. This is where
I painted my Subaru Outback. Do you see? Do you see now? Yeah,
I see you. Oh god.
Mrs. Jacobe in human form. Do you see?
>> Mrs. Leadeds in human form. Do you see? >> Let's
go. >> Sorry. We continue. >> You and Canens who
is working at Daily Wire. You and Tucker Carlson who is working
at Fox News in 2017. Actually, Nick, there's a whole bunch of
other people that you would we we would all know to be sort of
like in your camp, in the griper camp, in the JPL camp. There's
a lot of them that are on to what's really going on with Charlie
Kirk. And I'm not going to try to name everyone's names and pull
them into it. They can choose if they want to jump in here into
the mud with us or not. But yeah,
but I'm proud to be over here with Candace. I'm proud to be here
with Tucker. Proud to be here.
Oh, hold on. Why did that pause?
>> Anyone who's on the side of truth and evidence and information,
I don't care if they're feds. I don't care if they're I don't
care if they're black, white, new, old, whatever. Ben Shapiro
could come join us over here and I would be
I don't care.
>> 17 10 years ago, I >> Okay, that's not true though.
That's not that's that that's horrible discipline.
If somebody comes over as no reason to be on your side and they
start taking your side, wouldn't that you just made the argument,
hey Nick, isn't it weird that you're on the side of like all
these crazy people?
Wouldn't don't you think that same thing would apply if Ben Shapiro
went over to your side or if like Glenn Beck went over to your
side?
I that's that that's like not true. What he just said was stupid.
Oh, if somebody joins my side, I'll believe they're totally sincere
immediately.
No, I think you could ask some questions. You could be a little
little suspect. I was at Charlottesville in 2019.
I led the Groper war against Charlie Kirk, calling him an Israel
It is 2025.
Nothing has changed for 13 years. Actually, Nick, Charlie Kirk
got shot in the neck.
Actually, Nick, a few things have changed. X got purchased by
Elon. Think of that what you will. You got let back on X. you
started going all the mainstream podcasts.
All sorts of things have changed actually, Nick. >> Okay.
I think he meant with regards to
like nothing has changed with him. Like he still has the same
message. The message has been consistent. I think that's what
he's trying to say.
>> Maybe wrong. >> And that's kind of why we're having
this conversation, isn't it? years from the time Charlie founded
Turning Point until today, that organization was owned
by Israel. And ser this part is amazing cuz Nick starts actually
making my points for me without
really realizing it. I
I actually can't I can't handle it. This guy thinks he's breaking
new ground. Guys, did you know that Israeli bill like American
American Israeli billionaires, dual citizens, they've been funding
like pro-Israel movements in the United States for years? Did
you guys know about this? I didn't know about it until Charlie
Kirk got shot. It's like, brother Apac, what are you what are
you doing? Yeah, it's existed for a long time. This didn't just
come up.
Israel and everyone knows
my face when it's my first rodeo. Literally, it's literally my
first rodeo over here, guys. Don't pay any attention to me. It's
my first rodeo
that in June of this year, Charlie texted Desh Duza and said,
"Nick Fuentes is vermin. We've been fighting him for 6 years.
He's anti-Semitic." In August, he said, "I'm anti-Semitic garbage."
And
>> I mean, >> do you consider yourself an anti-semite?
A noted anti-semite?
>> I guess Charlie got that one wrong. >> I need
to be censored.
We've we've actually jumped the shark so hard that now he's going,
"Wait, you won't even own the label of anti-semite? You're a
complete loser.
You You won't even say you're an anti-semite when ass. What a
loser." Maybe Nick's like, "Oh, the last time I was like openly
owning that in the biggest platforms I could, they sort of cancelled
me again." Not He is though. He is. He absolutely is. >> They
never debate me. That was in August. People want to point out,
"Oh, well, he was leaning in the other
He wasn't leaning in the other
He wasn't leaning in the other direction. Donors play into all
the stereotypes.
I cannot and will not be.
This works really bad for him when I've already pulled up that
this exact group,
right? this exact group he was still participating in. He still
loved all these people. He still updated them on his schedule
constantly.
They still gave him a bunch of money, right? Sort of undercuts
this entire part where he tries to go back to this stuff specifically
and say this proves it cuz it doesn't prove it. Bullied like
this, leaving me no choice but to leave the pro-Israel
cause. >> I just realized this guy would go perfectly in
the H3H3 movement. Okay. If you love Ethan Klein and you think
that somebody saying they'll do something is significantly worse
than actually doing the thing,
you might be kind of just like Ian Carol. Okay. Actually, they
said they said they were going to steal views and I think that's
worse than stealing a whole bunch of views. Yeah. If you're like
one of those, then you fit with Ian Carol. Perfect. All right.
Nick Charlie saying that he's going to leave the pro-Israel movement.
Well, we should discount all of his work for Israel, all of his
continued work for Israel after those texts, right? We should
discount all of that and just look at those texts alone in Candace
Owens's word. Charlie came to me in a dream and they were going
to betray him. Oh my god,
Ian, you have to see
his right-hand man, Andrew Kul. >> I love this part. >> But
comes from Salem Media. We know
Andrew Kulovit, you know, the one that tried to cover this text
message up after Charlie got the one that we've all been suspicious
of from the start of this whole thing. Yeah. This Andrew Kulit,
right? To address some of the things that have been going around
on public, namely about a text, a group text chain that has been
known uh and released uh by Candace Owens. And I just want to
address it head-on because
uh you know that was a text grab, a screen grab that I had shared
uh with people. So it it is authentic and I want to go into it
because I actually am really excited that the the truth is out
there. >> No way. >> Can't you tell how excited he
was that the truth was out there now that he was exposed as having
had that text message for weeks? >> Oh, it's like it's
like so transparent, right? It's actually so transparent when
you know the end of the story, what he's like avoiding, what
he's not bringing up, that the rest of it was all there, that
Charlie continued to work for Israel, that Charlie sent a letter
to BB Netanyahu saying he wanted to help Israel, like move into
the future and be like a popular, loved country.
Every single element of Charlie Kirk's actions leads you to believe
that he loved Israel and he wanted to work to making Israel like
a more accepted and and awesome place.
But there's one text message where he was like getting really
mad cuz they didn't want to let Candace Owens come to their events.
And that means actually he was going to lead the pro-Israel movement
for sure. >> Letting the smears of Candace go on and on
and on despite knowing for a fact that Charlie had told the donors
that he was going to abandon the pro-Israel cause.
He just let
Josh Hammer and all of these chills,
Rob McCoy,
all of them try to whitewash Charlie's legacy.
Benjamin Netanyahu. He'd let Benjamin Netanyahu try to whitewash
Charlie's legacy. That Andrew Kovit, Nicknick, is that the one?
The one that
we might have some questions about.
Look at who's involved in Salem media. >> Oh, we have.
>> It is a Christian Zionist outfit. It is in bed.
Some of the people involved with Salem media are in the comments
of our exchange here, Nick, defending you because you're arguing
their points
>> with Israel. You want to know how I know that? Melissa
Strait used to work. >> Uh, so I'm being told that,
you know,
the transitive property in math
is being shilled by the they believe that you can, you know,
8 plus 9 is 9 plus 8,
right? Actually, that's not even the transitive property, but
don't worry about it. Is it commutive? I think it's commutive
there. Whatever. But like it's it's the same thing. Okay. They
basically show like regular mathematics. That means we have to
reject mathematics because the say math is right. They say basic
arithmetic is correct. So now we have to abandon that. Like that's
all Nick is doing here. He's just agreeing with the people who
he thinks are obviously correct. They happen to be in this case.
And nobody's more upset about that than him. There >> I
present >> from Prager University. She also used to work
for unit 8200.
>> Oh, we know >> in the IDF.
>> That's where Andrew Kovit comes from. And he was Charlie
Kirk's right-hand
>> Not sure what we're proving by saying that Charlie was
in a den of vipers surrounded by Zionists.
That's kind of the point >> that maybe because he built
the den of vipers. He knew exactly what the Vipers were and what
they believed and actually had a deeply like deeply and strongly
rooted belief in that same thing. I think probably that's what
it's suggesting, right? Farley picked out every one of those
Vipers. He literally was like, "That's the Viper I want. That's
the Viper I want. That's the Viper I want.
What does Ian think he's proving?" Point. Charlie Kirk appointed
Andrew Kovit to lead their struggle session about Israel after
the Turning Point SAS conference in July.
When Israel bombed Qatar in contravention of Trump's own foreign
policy, who did Charlie Kirk invite on the show to do Hazbara
and explain the party line? Ben Shapiro.
Nick acts like Turning Point is as simple to run as his show
and that there's no oversight. There's no joint decisions. There's
no complexity at all. It's just Charlie makes every decision
purely, purely, purely. I don't know how that decision was made.
Nick, >> can you wait? Really easy way to test this. Really
easy way to test this. How many turning point chapters push a
lot of anti-ionist propaganda? Ian, can you show me an a turning
point chapter? Since Charlie was like thinking about it, surely
there's some turning point chapters that had some anti-ionist
propaganda or anti-ionist talking points they threw out. Right.
Right. Right. Right. It can't go higher. I can't go >> What
did Charlie do when we were talking about bombing Iran?
>> Do you know what Charlie did when Trump was going to
bomb Iran?
>> Um,
are you going to say it's whatever? Are you are you going to
say whatever is printed in that article, the Max Blumenthal article
that's anonymously sourced again? >> Well, Charlie Kirk
played devil's advocate. He lended his platform to Ben Shapiro
to give Israel's position. And on Wednesday, the day he was shot,
Charlie Kirk, this guy is so committed to being anti-Semitic,
he won't even say
met with his rabbi
to prepare him to defend Israel at >> He also allegedly
sent a text. >> Get it? Like Lent, get it? Get it? >> Text
the day before saying that he was afraid Israel was going to
kill him.
>> Might have even said tomorrow, depending on what those
texts say. We haven't seen them yet.
I suspect they're out there, but we'll find out, won't we? >> As
he was writing his forthcoming book about the Sabbath, and this
is the guy that was martyed for fighting Israel.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is.
Because you damn well better kill him before he flips. And we
have all the proof we need to know that he was
>> Uhuh. Except he didn't at all. Not even a little. Can
we just like didn't Charlie talk a whole bunch right before he
died? What was he saying about Israel right before he died? Isn't
that like the the question? I think the what Charlie was doing
in my mind is very obvious. Okay. When he says stuff like this,
in my mind, even if he did the Trump like, "Oh, I don't think
you should bomb Iran." I think in his mind,
he was very concerned about these groper narratives. He's very
concerned about anti-ionist narratives. And he thought if you
look like you're just totally bowing to everything Benjamin Netanyahu
asks you to do, it's actually worse for Israel. I genuinely believe
that was probably Charlie's position. Like, hey, you can't just
do anything they ask or it's actually it works out worse for
everybody, right? What's Ian have to say about Charlie's May
2025 letter to Netanyahu? Well, we'll see cuz that apparently
and remember Candace said that letter to Netanyahu was rejecting
his money, rejecting everything about him that he didn't want
to go to Israel and so he only sent a letter, right? Is that
not Candace's line one to one?
Charlie refused to go to Israel and so he sent Benjamin Netanyahu
a letter like putting distance between them and then you read
the letter and it's basically him talking about folating Benjamin
Netanyahu and the entire state of Israel collectively.
Good one. Good one, Candace. Huh? But guess what? Me personally,
I was like, "Oh, this will finally finally people will realize
Candace is a total
a totally disingenuous liar. This will she's cooked now." Nope.
Plus 5,000 viewers. Oh, she's totally wrong on that. Plus 10,000
viewers. Oh, she totally made that up. Plus 20,000 viewers. No,
stop. Stop. Stop watching
That's exactly the time when Israel might kill him. Let alone
if he was offered a of money by Benjamin Netanyahu and turned
it down. If there was a quidd proquo in there. If there was something
disclosed to him about how that money might get transferred.
If he might have learned something that is not okay for him to
talk about.
That's exactly the kind of thing you
and the urgency with which you might need to kill him as you
watch this flip happen. As you see this text message go out.
That urgency is going to play into the evidence that we're about
to go over here.
Wait, do we have a date stamp on those texts, right? Those when
are those texts from? Those texts are from 2 hours after Charlie
blew off Steam in the chat. I joined a Zoom call with him and
a few others. The New York Post covered this Zoom call shortly
after Charlie's death. In short, Charlie sed to better communicate
the Israel issue on campus so as to be most effective with a
younger Gen Z.
So this was around no screenshots from both the day he before
he was killed. Charlie was blowing off steam in a private group
chat setting. Donors have every right to withhold donations and
okay so this was the day before this one the previous ones and
then he was talking to these same people like later like after
that. Uh this guy might have been a though. I can't tell if say
hi to your Antifa friends is like somebody being a in that chat.
>> If you think that I feel sorry for you
>> appreciate it bro >> because you are Ian. Carol
says, "We're all over here. Where's our general? Where's our
guy?"
>> I was just being kind, Nick. You're not our general.
You're just a kid in a studio.
We're all just individuals out here with cameras. And I was just
trying. You kind of really like Nick Fentes. That's not Listen,
many such cases, okay? You're not really our job. I don't like
you, you stupid [__] I didn't I wasn't asking you
out anyway, you ugly [__] I wasn't asking you out
anyway, you stupid ugly [__] That's the energy he's
throwing off here. I was just being nice and to extend a hand
to offer. I didn't really want to date you. I was just being
nice, you ugly, for you not to do this to yourself
because we all have the internet and we can all look up sources.
And a lot of people are going to agree with you, and that's fine.
A lot of people are going to call me names. That's fine. Not
worried about it because I site my sources
and I stand by them. And if you have a better set of sources
and a better
then I'll agree with you.
And you've convinced me of many topics in the past where you
had a great take and I looked up the sources to try to corroborate
your take and I changed my mind. So,
for some reason also, he said based on these text messages, Israel
realized they had to do something. Well, we've heard about a
whole bunch of planning that happened way before this, right?
This is from the day before.
How in the did they take these text messages? How' they plan
and execute this assassination in like a day?
Are you serious? Also, why were those planes following Erica
Kirk around for so long or something? I don't none of this is
like coherent to me. I need somebody to do a video just on like
the coherent vision these people have. But I know they won't
because they just have to signal vaguely a different like random
facts to try to pretend that this makes sense. But it doesn't
make sense. And something tells me that that's not what's gonna
happen on this one. >> I'm right here where I've always
been. Following the facts. Following the >> You sound like
Cash Patel, bro. >> I'm right here where I've always been.
Following the facts. Following the
>> Okay, that I'll say he does win pretty hard. Just painting
Nick as Indian. Uh, you're Indian. Hey, you said you went to
Charlottesville. Well, you know what? You're Indian. You're actually
the Indian now. This is like the soy jack thing that used to
happen on Reddit like 10 years ago. Okay. Um, you're the soy
jack. I made you the soy. Well, 5 years ago, I made you the soy
jack. You're Indian. You're the totally incompetent Indian. Look,
you're like the Indian FBI director, bro. >> Honey, Israel
honeypoted Indian FBI >> Looking at the information.
>> That's what got me looking at the information. Hey,
Nick. >> Hey, Nick. If we were sitting down right now live
and I asked you about the information of this case, do you think
you would know it? Do you think you would know any of it?
Would you know about the evidence that was mentioned in the affidavit?
Would you know about the various video recordings of Tyler Robinson's
car driving through the neighborhood of allegedly Tyler Robinson
walking through the neighborhood? Would you know about the timeline?
Would you know about the foreign plane? I again,
you might not know about all of these facts individually. It's
like you need to tell a coherent story here and you're not doing
that at all. You can't tell a coherent story. Like you you just
said this. Tell me. I have a question for you. What does the
video of Tyler Robinson's car have to do with everything? Right.
I've watched the video. I've seen the videos of his car of his
I I don't know when he's talking about the car if he's talking
about like maybe his body cam arrest or something or if it's
a different one. I think I've seen I think I've seen a car video.
Definitely saw the video of him like loping through the forest
or not through the neighborhood, right? It looks like he's almost
limping because he probably has something you would think in
his pants like maybe his rifle butt or something
like his stock rather the stock of the rifle. But like I just
I actually don't know what you got to connect, man. That's the
thing. None of these people connect anything. And have you actually
looked up that data for yourself? Would you know about the various
military experts, Green Beretss and such, who have been shooting
combat dummies with 300 sixes and every other type of round under
the sun to try to recreate this shot, which is not real. Would
you know any of this stuff? I mean, I've seen a lot of people
say a 300 6 would blow his clavicle off. I've seen that. Seen
a ton of that. Unfortunately, you just have to listen. I'm willing
to take anything that sounds even a little more reasonable.
anything you I just don't believe Ian has it or he would have
laid it out. You notice he didn't tell any coherent story here.
He just went like Nick said something and you go, "Oh, but do
you know about this? Oh, but do you know about that? Oh, but
do you know about this or that or that or this?" Like what? Cuz
I'm not sure you would.
I'm not sure you know the information on this case, Nick. Cuz
if you did, you wouldn't have stuck your neck out like this on
a take like this because it was just a bad move. It was dumb.
And you're not dumb. >> Which is why I was so surprised.
>> If you knew the information, you wouldn't have been
dumb. But this is dumb. And now I think maybe you're more dumb
than I thought. Dummy.
Let's go. >> That this was your response.
>> Got me here light years ahead of you, light years ahead
of Candace, light years ahead of Tucker Carlson. Now all these
interlopers are going to come in and tell us that our ideology
is about
That was a really interesting phrasing, Nick. Now all these interlopers
are going to come in and mess with my cult and tell us how to
think. I'm the only one that can say how we're supposed to think
about the
I think his general thoughts are you're like a federal agent
who is going in and trying to infiltrate to promote a bunch of
crazy conspiratorial and get people arrested or get them mocked
out of the room on whatever conversation. That's like his general
theory or that's what he stated,
right? Which like realistically,
I hate to say, man, I believe his conspiracy theory way more
than yours. Like I I'm sorry. The idea that Tucker Carlson might
be a spy and might be infiltrating this group to like subvert
it or control it from within, that sounds way more credible than
him just realizing that after his Russian grocery trip, he actually
really just hated the Okay, this guy's ideology ping pongs around
more than Sneo
and nobody points it out. That seems suspicious to me. That's
a weird phrasing, bro. And I'm certainly not. Can you Can you
tell me what you're not saying, Ian? Can you He's about to do
it. He's about to do it.
That's weird phrasing, bro. But I'm not saying, isn't he? Could
you I heard him start to say it. He's going to
>> listen. And I'm certainly not saying that I'm the one
that's going to tell you how to feel about the >> actually
find the tallest building in whatever hippie city you live in
and and just make a good decision. Okay. Holy
this guy.
I'm certainly not saying this or that or this or that, but you
know, it's just weird. Don't you guys think it's a little bit
weird how I'm not saying anything? Don't you think it's a little
bit weird of 367,000 views on this video, but I didn't say
I'm just a guy. I think you should probably do your own research
and come up with your own conclusions about how to feel about
the but you should probably be careful of gatekeepers
especially when it comes to a topic like
>> this is it's funny cuz he's doing the thing right he's
doing the Brett C that's the same thing Brett Cooper is doing
where it's like they just say oh everything should be open all
the time it's like no you when people are totally you should
be able to call them out you don't have to ban them from anything
you should just mock them mercilessly right just mock them mercilessly
ly until they >> So, just think carefully out there, guys,
for yourselves and don't let people gateep information. >> Is
this the same video from earlier? >> That was really weird
wording.
>> Yahoo and Israel's foreign policy and this kookery.
>> Oh, and actually, this is a good point, too. Let's rewind.
>> Years ahead of Candace, light years ahead of Tucker
Carlson. Now all these interlopers are going to come in and tell
us that our ideology is about Netanyahu and Israel's foreign
policy and this kookery.
Actually, Nick,
I specifically elucidated that that is not your ideology and
that yours is much more complex than that, much more interesting
than that. And it had actually changed my mind when you have
spoken about it. This specific issue right here,
this issue is the exact example of why your point, specifically
your point, that it's not just the Israeli government, it is
also American Zionists, American Zionists, and this network that
they have built inside of America on behalf of this foreign state.
Because that's what TPUSA is is exactly. If there's
Yeah. I don't He just thinks he's like convincing Nick. like
he actually thinks he's convincing Nick of this next he's going
to say I I don't know if you've ever heard about this Nick but
you heard of this thing called the USS Liberty Nick have you
heard of this I this will blow your mind Nick sit down Nick sit
down I need to tell you about this thing they call the USS Liberty
you're not going to believe it Nick it's crazy like okay Ian
okay Ian you go tell your little story buddy okay >> any
moment in time when America has a direct obvious example of what
you have been championing for years. It's right now with Turning
Point USA and suddenly everyone else has gone like everyone else
has gone off to fight it and you are not there. Right.
>> Well, I was just >> This is the perfect example
of your espoused ideology or at least what I've been hearing
you say on your show for the last months and months and months.
>> He's like saying um I'm saying Apac exists because we
know that because of Turning Point. Turning Point's kind of like
Apac. It's like totally just an Israel first organization run
by, you know, people with a big interest in pushing pro-Israel
talking points. And that means that they Charlie Kirk and Nick
is like, "No, they didn't kill Charlie Kirk. You've pre presented
no evidence of that." And Ian's like, "Well, but we like kind
of proved a lot about Israeli funding networks." It's like, okay,
who did you prove it to? What are you talking about, man? This
is a settled issue.
Yes, there are like Israel aligned groups that do a lot of political
funding in the United States that that try to get people on the
same page as Israel. What do you think the Discovery Oh, wait.
Hold on. Is it just Yeah, Discovery Warner Bros. Netflix merger
is? What do you think that is? Do you think that's them buying
the news, you idiot? No, it's not. It's so that when you watch
your documentary on ancient Rome or something, there's a little
section in there that makes sure you understand that Israel is
really awesome. Okay,
I'm not I'm not joking. That sounds probably a lot worse than
I wanted it to sound, but uh that is broadly I've seen a lot
of different people from a lot of different sides of the aisle
say that that's basically what they think the core reason is
behind this merger is that
Larry Ellison, David Ellison, they don't really want to buy news
networks.
Doing the news is like weird. They want to take the total like
gollop the gollop documentaries the goop TV shows and they want
to make sure that you know on those goap TV shows that Israel
is good. Okay,
that's what they want. Every documentary in ancient Rome is surface
level at best. Oh, I'm just going to tell you. They're going
to be like and the were there kind of just proving to you that
the lived in Judea like long long long ago and it's always been
their land and was destined to be given back to them. Like like
that's what it'll be. It'll be a throwaway line in a documentary.
Okay, that sounds conspiratorial, but I'm telling you that is
legitimately
just listen.
I could never say it as eloquently as somebody else did. So,
I'm going to let him say exactly what the Ellison
because I just can't. Okay. >> Okay. I didn't do the meme
than I am. >> I didn't do the meme. I'm just saying this.
Okay. This is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work for
Israel. Give me CBS. Work for Israel. Give me the American government.
>> Okay, I can never say it quite as eloquently as Shank
can, so I'm just going to let him say it. All right, just gonna
let him say it. I stole that talking point shamelessly from the
silly serious, by the way. I probably also delivered it a little
anti-Semitically. My bad. I was watching her stream. She streamed
a couple nights ago. She started streaming more and I was tuning
in and it was just about the CBS stuff. I actually could probably
just go look it up on her channel. Give me a second. Is it just
the silly serious?
Nope.
The silly serious blonde politics. This is the one. It was like
her. Do I go to lives? It's like this one. Yeah. Media consult
pitching to by Warner Brothers and they've had everything rejected.
>> Yeah. So, this is a cool video. She actually does research
for her stream. So, if you ever want to watch a stream that's
researched a little bit and isn't just like off the cuff rolling
with the punches doing whatever drama pops up, I suggest checking
it out. Okay.
Put in the chat there. Yeah, she started streaming recently,
so you can go check that out. Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep,
yep, yep, yep, yep. Um,
>> I think she said basically
they don't want the news networks, they want the discovery portion,
if I remember correctly.
>> Yeah, discovery part.
>> Oh, it's right here at the beginning. >> Now,
what Ellison really wants is CNN and HGTV
and the Discovery.
the discovery part of Warner Brothers Discovery. So Warner Brothers
has consolidated like a hundred times over the last 30 years.
Every >> Oh, maybe they do want news, too. >> Time
it sucks for Warner Brothers. Every time they've said it's necessary,
it has never been necessary, but at the moment you have Warner
Brothers Discovery. Now Netflix has made a deal to buy the Warner
Brothers part, but they don't want the Discovery part. They don't
want the cable TV. They don't want the
all of all of that stuff. They don't want CNN. They don't want
what they all the discovery shows.
The Ellisons want the discovery shows. And let me explain
why they want them, which is
when you watch the news,
you know, you're watching the news. Your brain is like, I'm watching
the news. You turn your crit, well, I do and I assume some of
you do. Um, you turn your critical thinking on. You're thinking
like, what are the news? How are they presenting this? What are
they focusing on? or people do to a certain extent, right? They
understand that what they're watching is news, what they're watching
is political.
When you watch a documentary on the Discovery Channel, you don't
necessarily do that. When you watch a cooking show, you don't
necessarily do that. When you watch Dr. Phil, you don't necessarily
do that. So actually the gemstone, the
for
the Ellison in terms of the media environment is the non-critical.
>> See see that's what I was I was like I probably said
it too anti-semitically. I probably just said it, you know, I'm
like Chank. Okay. I can't control myself. I'm like talking about
what they're doing and I'm doing the Larry Ellison while I'm
explaining it. It's not healthy.
the passive kind of
um media environment where these things aren't overtly
political.
Okay, I'm not watching this because I care about the news, but
if every time I'm watching this show, they talk about, you know,
well, this was different before immigrants, you know, they start
to the same way that they put Barry Weiss in as the head of CBS
and like this is what the news looks like now. We're just going
to do this like light. These are all things I talk about, by
the way.
Yeah, the very Oh, the very
This isn't even the news. This is a big >> What I should
do, what I think would actually be a fun stream, maybe we can
do this at some point. Maybe we could do it like tomorrow, is
I should go and I should watch the rest of this segment because
I only watched the first like five minutes or something. I think
I I I had to build my docket so I couldn't watch the whole thing.
But I should watch this on stream. We should watch it. And then
we should watch Fuentes cuz Fuentes just did a segment on this
as well. And I want to see what the differences are
cuz when I talked about Oh my god.
Is it like this? Will that work? No.
Nick J. Fente. Okay. Rumble, stop. I don't care. It's off, man.
Thank you. He just did the
Mafia initiates hostile takeover of the media. Mafia initiates
hostile takeover of the media. What is this thumbnail? It's time
for me to
Funny. Ian Carol and the conspiracy theorist. Bro, he using the
AI in his thumbs.
Damn.
Elon Musk says are peak white,
bro. His his thumbnails are good. The His thumbnails are great.
That's crazy. Okay. All right. Yeah. I Dude, the crazy thing
about this is
one, I don't remember where we left off that I switched over
to Joe streaming about this stuff. Okay. And two, well, I do
remember that we were about to go through like this one Nick
Funes clip that we stopped 2 minutes in out of a six-minute clip
and then we watched three hours of Ian Carol.
But I do remember that part. Okay. I actually really just wanted
to hear Ian Carol give his like deeper thoughts on why he believes
Israel Kirk. And surprise surprise, they're completely ironic.
Who who could have guessed? Who could have guessed that? They're
just
Well, he's almost finished the clip here. We're not watching
example
of American
subverting America from the inside, from within our institutions
using their American money on behalf of Israel. And it is the
perfect example of why the issue is more complex than just the
government of Israel. Just BB Netany and Yahoo.
We're going to go back to the Fentes stuff. This is all leading
to the Erica Kirk Candace Owens confrontation
did me dirty and didn't say. >> So we're back to Fentes.
I'm going to roll it back just a little bit. This is him reading
his text messages with Ian Carroll after Ian Carol's video. I
think the most recent one. >> Okay. But you you're not
attacking my credibility. You're calling me a fed. Go rewatch
your live stream segment about me. Did you think I wasn't going
to respond? You asked for evidence, so I produced it. >> This
was a little weird. >> I said, you are saying, "Has Fentis
flipped? Disagree all you want, but insinuating I work for Israel
or the FBI? You are a total piece of [__] When people
were attacking you for your Cabala bracelet, I called that out
as paranoia and said they were being ridiculous. Now we disagree
for the first time." and you immediately jump on bad faith accusations
saying I'm controlled op. You are trash. You agreed with me that
can Owens did me dirty and didn't say anything because you didn't
want to offend her. There was nothing honest about you.
And that's true. By the way, when Candace trashed me, he called
me up and said, "You're totally right about her, dude. She treated
you terribly, but I don't want to say anything cuz she was nice
to me."
He replies, he goes, "This isn't about you, Nick. Someone killed
Charlie Kirk and it wasn't Tyler Robinson. This is one of the
most important moments in our nation's history in our lifetimes.
Second to 9/11.
Are you kidding me? This is one of the the St. Charlie is basically
9/11. It's like a second 911, Nick. And you're not here on the
side of the Americans for the second 911. most important moments
in our nation's history. In our lifetimes, second to probably
only 9/11.
In our nation's history,
I guess in our lifetimes.
Yeah. This is bigger than the Trump election and like co and
Yeah. Are you kidding me? You're an idiot. You're a idiot and
you suck.
Nick's so close to getting baited into just being like, you know
what? Actually, Charlie Kirk, I'm glad that dead. He's so close.
He's like right there. These people, that's what this all was.
It was just a scop to get Nick to get enraged enough to say his
real opinions on Charlie Kirk for him to just go, "You know what?
[__] it. I'm glad he died. I celebrated when he died.
You know what? I drank for the first time. I had alcohol. I got
champagne. I popped that and I had a drink with all my favorite
friends. Okay, we all got in a Zoom call and we laughed at this.
We watched the clip and we laughed." That's what Nick is like.
They're trying to bait Nick into doing that and he doesn't want
to do that because that would be up. Okay. >> And I hate
you.
>> Figure your out and get your head in the game. Get over
your vendetta with Candace. This is bigger than you or me or
any of us. These people are crazy and we have a narrow window
of time to do something about it. What are you going to do about
it? You've chosen to pedal Cash Patel talking points with no
realization how dumb and vulnerable that makes you look. He keeps
saying I'm vulnerable,
which to me indicates you're not familiar with the evidence in
the first place. Assuming you're not blackmailed, I'm sure you'll
grow through this and come out the other side and I'll support
the great work I'm sure you'll do on the other side of it. If
you are blackmailed, I'll support you even more coming out the
other side of it. Whatever's going on right now, well, I made
a 2-hour video. I said, "It's about me because you're accusing
me of being compromised with no evidence because I disagree with
you. You're talking past that because you know you're lying about
it. Elon, Candace, Tucker, and you are all attacking my credibility
simultaneously.
Of course, it's about me. I'm letting you know you are dead to
me. I will repudiate your support now and in the future because
you are a dishonest, stupid piece of
He replied, he said, "I addressed the fed stuff." Okay. Like,
uh, someone get me. Can we We got to watch this gay clip that
he had. Okay, we got to watch that gay clip. I got to go find
that cuz I like I'm sorry, but look at how different this is
from Brett Cooper, right? He's actually just like, "Fuck you.
I'm never talking to you again. You bridge burned."
Just is more refreshing, okay, than people just being like, "Well,
I don't know if I do gangsters control America." Well, I don't
although we agree with it. I kind of, you know, maybe not all
the way. Seems like you didn't watch the video, but you do you.
There's a joke about 107 friendships out there somewhere. I'll
support your work when it's good. I hope it is. I said, "Yeah,
I've been backstabbed repeatedly, including by you. I backed
you up and defended you, then you switched up on me because of
the heat of the moment. You can shove your support up your ass.
It means nothing to me. You have no integrity as a person." Now,
I will say he took shots at Ian first or at least he took shots
at Ian like while Ian was just doing his conspiracy theories.
So, like realistically
probably the positive networking was like uh more of like disingenuous.
Like I'm not sure he ever respected e Ian. He probably just liked
that Ian was supportive of him. So maybe a little bit of R Cooper
in there after
So this is like that
you tell me. But that's a weird conversation
and I'm not crazy. though I I'm going to say maybe he's just
stupid, but that's like a weird conversation. I because I'm telling
him repeatedly, you're making an accusation with no evidence
after I defended you. You're betraying me. And he's saying this
is like 9/11, bro. You're vulnerable.
And I'm like, it's really simple.
I
not sure if complete or gaslighting. Can't tell. Very difficult.
Is this guy completely dumb or just gaslighting me? >> gave
you the benefit of the doubt. Am I not owed the same thing? I
disagree with you. You jump to I'm a bad faith actor. >> You
misheard ear. You misheard. But if you got my Glen Greenwald
clip again, I just have to point out that that clip gets posted
everywhere. That's my clip. I clipped that. I clipped that cuz
I watched that stream and that was like the funniest segment
I've ever seen in my entire life. >> Isn't that a little
hypocritical? You went through the exact same thing and I defended
you.
Now the shoe's on the other foot. You throw me under the bus.
You're terrible. And he's just saying all this other stuff. I'm
like, I don't It's weird. It's weird. Weird stuff is going on,
man. And this is why I say I don't trust anybody. Anyway, that's
just a little taste of that.
That was our conversation.
Wow. Okay. I was looking at my other monitor here. Sorry.
Somebody link me this tweet. Hold on. Hold on. Ethan Klein responds
to Taylor Lens's claim. There's no such thing as social media
addiction. There's no such thing as social media. It's 2 a.m.
You just spent the last 15 hours feverishly writing your 85th
tweet for the day. She really did tweet 85 times yesterday. We
counted. You're the most obedient slave to Twitter's algorithm.
Constantly in a state of unrest and anger. And then you cap it
all off at 2 a.m. proclaiming there's no such thing as social
media addiction. You sure?
I mean,
is Ethan really saying that? I think I think it's at least at
least she got the app installed, bro. At least she interacting
on the app. You constantly interact with tweets and you don't
have Twitter installed cuz you think it's toxic. I'm sorry. That's
like far more
The is he talking about? Feels like you talk about Ethan constantly.
Can we get a break from that? Where do you get off you actual
sub80 IQ?
Oh, this is saying um the lunar clips are about who? Hassan.
A lot about a lot of stuff about Hassan apparently from the lunar
box stream.
See, but here's the thing. This is this can be like what like
Riyle's channel looks like sometimes. But it turns out that when
an editor is doing content for a channel they own that they get
a lot of they get either all or most of the revenue from, they're
going to pick the highest revenue earning stuff and for Loner
Box that's going to be Hassan stuff. For my channel that's going
to be Destiny commentary, right? So, they're they're self- selecting
to the things that will get the most money in the algorithm.
And that happens to be like probably big figures, right? They
build up a channel, you're like anti that big figure, and then
they and like that was the Riyle channel was mostly building
money off of that, right? Was like Destiny Jason content. I think
it just makes sense. It's not like L I can't tell much about
Lbox's stream from this. Well, except for his opinions, like
what he thinks about Hassan,
but like I can't tell how much of his content is just about Hassan.
I think that's probably what Spider cares about more than anything.
You guys probably don't even bunch of people here probably don't
even know who Spider is. Damn. Okay, with that, we've got one
more clip. One more Fantas clip. Okay, and then we're into the
Erica Kurt commentary. We're right there, guys. We're right there.
We're right right there to the turning point. Okay. Uh this was
last night. Nick Fentes doing a live stream on December 15th
covering the TPUSA stream, responding to Candace Owens. Nick
also says he may jump step in and expose Candace if they don't
do a good enough job. Everyone's afraid of a black Karen, but
I'm not. I'm a groper. Wait, what?
I'm looking forward to the Turning Point live stream where they
respond to everything.
I'll be I plan on live streaming that.
And depending on how they do, if they don't do a good enough
job, I think I'm going to have to step up and I think I'm going
to have to expose Canons for what she really is. I'm going to
give them they have the opportunity because they are involved
in all this.
But I am so frustrated with how people are handling it.
They're losing. If Turning Point doesn't do a good enough job
on December 15th, I'm going to have to step up. And just like
I exposed Tucker Carlson and just like I exposed JD Vance, I'm
gonna have to step up and I'm gonna have to blow the lid and
expose everything about Candace Owens and reveal who she really
is, who her husband is, who her donors
And unlike her, I will be naming names. I will be coming with
receipts.
Okay, that's so easy to say. How about you actually do it? That's
what Candace says too, though. Unlike everybody else, I'm going
to actually say something. I'm going to actually prove my thing.
Unlike everybody else, I'm going to be different. So, prove that
you're not the same basic Candace is. And actually do it. Don't
just say it. Do it.
What's the wait for? I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. That's
It's like, dude, it's so It's such
like, oh, well, if they don't do a good enough job, I'm going
to expose her. Uh, just do it now. Do it right now. You say you
know, do it right now. I will blow the lid on the whole thing.
and I'll give her the Tucker Carlson
treatment, but I'll wait and see how the Turning Point USA stream
goes. I think they're going to do a good job, but if they don't,
then I'll finish it for them.
>> Nobody else will do it. Everybody else is afraid of
Canis Owens. I'm not afraid of some ignorant black. Okay.
>> Everybody's afraid of a black Karen. I'm not. I'm a
groper.
Okay.
Black are a specialtity.
Okay, so Turning Point, the whole conservative movement, they're
all in fear of Candace. Nobody wants to step to her and her insane
cult of followers.
I'll do it and I'll win.
But I look forward to the Turning Point stream. I'm planning
on simo casting that or simultaneously streaming it. That's next
Monday, I think. Right. So, I'll be live streaming it and we'll
see how it goes. And if they don't do a good enough job, then
I'll be coming back for the season finale of 2025.
And I'm gonna put her in a coffin. Metaphorically speaking,
I'm going to do it for the vine. I'm going to put >> I'm
going to Charlie Kurt this. Metaphorically speaking, >> in
the coffin is going to be over for the book club. Okay, we're
closing.
We're turning the page on the book club.
>> uh Okay. All right. Think most people already know that
Candace is shady. This is more about whether she is right about
Charlie Kirk. We don't much care about talking heads at this
point, just the facts of the case, which point to Israel. Every
Israeli connection and official narrative flaw to Charlie Kirk's
assassination.
>> I'm looking forward to the turning >> Shut up.
Okay. He's like the rabbit. He's like the rabbit.
He's like the rabbit that points the clock. He's just a Oh my
god. He's just like the rabbit.
No way.
Okay, finally. Let's finally finally finally we're here. Okay,
how much time we got? Ah, we got whatever time we got. Okay,
I might start with this stuff again tomorrow if I don't get far
enough through it. But we'll do it now cuz I said I would do
it tonight. If you guys stuck around through the whole stream,
>> if you guys stuck around through the whole stream just
waiting for this and I hadn't done it, I I would be like a total
total scammer. Okay, I'd be a total scammer. So, we got to do
this first. Maybe I'll do it again tomorrow if um yeah, I might
do it again tomorrow. We'll see. We'll see. Okay, this is Erica
Kirk on Fox News today talking about people who are benefiting
making money off of her staff's pain at TPUSA and her husband's
death. Let's go. >> A mom >> and a battle tested
American.
>> Good to see you again today.
>> Talk to me about this part of the conspiracies that
are out there. this disturbing part that people are trying to
guess where Charlie is. >> Can I have one thing? Can I
have one
>> Can I have one thing? I don't know. What is it? What
do you What do you What? Wait, what the So, this might be something
that helps us understand why Ian Carol was saying some people
are saying Charlie's not even in the ground yet, right? So, apparently
Oh, they're not saying where his body was buried.
Can my children have one thing?
Everything was public. We will be building the most beautiful
memorial for my husband at Turning Point USA. And it will be
for the world to see. And it will be spectacular. And it will
have
basically museum style for our Charlie, for my Charlie. But can
I have one thing? Can my babies have one thing? Where we hold
it sacred? Where my husband is laid to rest? where I don't have
to be worried about some secular revolutionary coming and destroying
my husband's grave while my daughter is sitting there praying.
One thing that this is my husband. >> Yes, he was Charlie
Kirk to the world and I know so many people love my husband and
I am grateful for that. But this is my husband. >> What
are we talking about? So, she wants a private burial site that
is not announced or publicly known so that she can go to the
the burial site with her kids. Um,
this of course is going to lead to people stalking her for that
burial site. I Which is weird. That's very weird. But I guess
this is what she would rather have like Lenin.
Is that true that they don't know where Lennin's buried? Is that
like widely unknown? That would be weird to me. But >> and
I want to be able to have one thing left that is sacred to our
family, to my in-laws, to my babies, and to my parents. One thing,
what are they taking from you right now? >> Nothing.
But I will tell you what they are doing.
It reminds me so much of chapter 6 in the book of Nehemiah.
He is building a wall and the town's people are at the base of
that hill saying, "Nehemiah, calling him all these names, saying
all these things, come on
Every single time he had the same message four times in a row,
I cannot come down. I am busy building. That is how I feel. I
do not have time to address the noise. My silence does not mean
that I am complacent.
>> My silence does not mean that somehow Turning Point
USA and all of the handpicked staff that loved my husband and
my husband loved them is somehow in on it. >> So, she's
clearly talking about Candace. She shouldn't be public facing.
No, she's terrible at this. I called it instantly. I'm sorry.
I called it [__] instantly. Took one look at this
woman was like, "Nope, nope. Nope. No shot. Nope." I I literally
watched her do her whole I watched like 30 seconds of
her doing her like crying stream after his death when she was
doing like the eulogy or whatever and I immediately was like,
"Nope, she can't do it. Nope. Nope." And then I shut it off and
I said, "Listen guys, if I watch that, I'm going to talk a bunch
of and a bunch of people here are going to get very mad at me.
You're gonna get very mad if I comment honestly on this." Okay?
So, nope. And then for like a week and a half, I just avoided
anything to do with her cuz nope. No thank you. >> We are
busy building. And you know what I thought? I thought these people
are human. We are all grieving in our own way and they are trying
to find the answer to something that happened that was so evil.
They are. >> He got the intellect of a of a what do you
call it? Like MissUSA model. Okay, that's what going on here.
>> Trying so hard. And I get that. We're doing the same.
Anytime we hear a lead or anytime we hear anything, we send it
to the authorities. Please dig into this. No rock will be unturned.
I want justice for my husband, for myself, for my family more
than anyone else out there. So for me, you want to keep telling
me to come down while we're we're building. I don't have time
for
>> But here's my breaking point on that. Come after me.
Call me names. I don't care. Call me what you want. Go. >> I
don't think Candace ever did that. >> Go down that rabbit
hole. Whatever.
But when you go after my family,
my Turning Point USA family, my Charlie
>> Oh, well, she's been going after the Turning Point USA
family forever. and you haven't talked is >> show family.
When you go after the people that I love and you're making hundreds
and thousands of dollars every single episode
going after the people that I love because somehow they're in
on this.
>> Okay. So, that makes it pretty obvious that there's
only one person that that applies to, right?
Literally only one possible person that could apply to.
>> You know, I have to say it. I've never seen you like
this. No, I'm I'm very I this is righteous.
>> I am I am
>> anger because this is not okay. It's not healthy. This
is a mind virus.
Yes. I believe in our judic
judicial system. >> Oh no.
OH NO. >> I do. >> Oh boy. >> We have a hell
of a team working on this. Excuse my French,
but this is not okay.
So, you want to put these people back in the >> It hurts
to watch. It hurts to Candace watching this like
That's That's another 15,000 live viewers right there. Mhm.
Mhm. Yeah, that's a another 15,000 live viewers right there.
Thank you very much. You stupid [__]
You stupid.
>> Box where they've been creeping from. I don't care what
box you're in, but just know that your words are very powerful
and we are human. My team are not machines and they're not robots.
They are human. We have more death threats on our team and our
side than I have ever seen. I have kidnapping threats. I have,
you name it, we have it. And my poor team is exhausted. And every
time they bring this back up, what are we supposed to do? Relive
that trauma all over again? They watched my husband get murdered.
I have no idea how I would have reacted if I was there that day.
And thank the good Lord that I did not have to >> wait.
You understand that that might not be insane, right? She has
the most live viewers I've ever seen on any sort of consistent
basis on YouTube ever. And she's getting all of those super chats.
She's getting all of those ad views. And she does her own sponsors
on top of it. Okay. Okay. Okay. Cuz I'm like, dude, I'm like
that might not BE THAT MIGHT NOT BE OVERSTATING IT. She might
be making like $200,000 an episode of her 2-hour long show. It's
crazy >> to see that happen. But my team, they are rocked
to the core. So why every single day did they have to be dragged
through the mud, analyzed, hyper
>> You know, the conspiracies that are out there, all of
the like, do you think that there is more of it now because you
do shine your light? I mean, did people just expect you would
just go away? >> I don't know what they expected.
I don't know what they expected. >> They pick on you because
of your accessories. I mean, I've seen some of >> Oh, yeah.
No, I at this point, it's what the conspiracy collection.
>> Get it before Christmas. Like, seriously, it it you
will if you want to find and pick me apart, go right ahead. I
do not care. I don't. This was happening before Charlie was murdered.
Both of us have been through the ringer of people will call you
whatever they want to call you. >> She's reading. People
just keep announcing she's reading. Yeah, she's probably reading
off a teleprompter. Yeah, probably.
I Yeah, I don't know. It's in her watching the footage every
other day. I don't think so. No, I don't think so.
Okay, so she threw that out. Now, there's two different paths
we can go down. We can go down the Tucker stuff because Tucker
had a really weird So, he had a kind of weird moment on
the Theo Von show. Okay. But he had a really weird video he put
out today. Right after Erica Kirk finished speaking like literally
within hours of Erica Kirk speaking, he threw this video up
which was like baffling to me cuz she was basically saying, "Please
don't." And Tucker was like, "Uh,
how about you? How about you, Erica Kirk?" "Hey, Erica Kirk,
how about you, you dumb bitch?" Sorry, I'm saying a I'm saying
[__] a lot today, but you know, I'm like, "Wait,
why did why did you do that, Tucker? Why? Why did you go live
and just go, "Yeah, Candace owns you, you stupid bitch." I That
seemed really bizarre. That seemed like outside the bounds of
normal etiquette. I thought you guys were all Christians. What
the
heck? Okay, hold on. Okay, we got that.
I had the funniest post, too. Hold on. What is this? Yeah. Okay,
dude. If you want to see the most skitso post you've ever seen
your entire life, Project Constitution. Project Constitute. Okay.
Erica Kirk just went full deep state script on Fox News and now
I'm a thousand% convinced she's part of the cover up today. Erica
Kirk sat on national television and delivered the most rehearsed
weaponized grieving window performance I've ever seen while simultaneously
begging us to stop investigating her husband's murder, claiming
the FBI is doing a hell of a job. The same FBI that paved the
crime scene on a Sunday.
Did Did the FBI really go to this college and do a pave job?
Really?
Okay. So, anyone who questions CP USA is traumatizing her staff
and making money off of trauma. It's dude, it's like the most
insane
post I've ever seen in my life. It's like this is I guess this
is the bar for Twitter at this point. Okay. Patriot Princess
agree
except for one thing. There were no actual tears. Very tur. Also,
notice I didn't see your ank
as a crutch either. It's like fake mistakes because these I feel
like they're both AI. Project Constitution. Yeah, it's Charlie
Kirk profile pick and then Patriot Princess. This is definitely
going to be an AI account. Patriot Princess. Wow.
W Oh, maybe not. Maybe it's just some
just some woman. Okay, whatever. It's just all
Bro, it's like so much more cringe. Do you remember how there
was a while with um No, I don't want to I don't want to go deep
diving on Twitter accounts. Um, do you remember how there was
a while where like zoomers were acting in a way that was like
reflecting sort of like Tik Tok and streamers and it's like dude
they like they they're acting it wasn't even zoomers like Gen
Alpha. They're acting like it's a performance when they're in
real life. Well, actually
Twitter has now turned like boomers into that where they're doing
like this performance, this over-the-top performance at all times.
It's like real life interactions or at least online interactions
have just become kayfabe like on all sides. Everybody, it's just
infinite kayfabe in every direction. I'm so confused at all times.
Same guy cited in the Hindustan Times article about the pave
about paving over the site. There's a video
from the Hindustan Times. E
can't make it up. >> Hold on. I do have to see. Says it's
from the United States. >> A lot of construction
um smoke going on. Oh no, they are
constructing.
>> Okay, I can hear it.
I'm sorry, but I can hear you speak. I Dude, no way. >> Let's
see what >> Okay, never mind. Never mind. No, no, no. It's
not the guy. It's not the guy. It's some guy named Samir Massie.
Okay, Samir Massie 64. No, no, no, no, no, no. It's not him.
It's not him. It's not >> because I see a lot of construction
um smoke going on. Oh, no. They are
They are taking off. You have to listen to me. You have to listen
>> where he was sitting
and they are constructing a new one as you could see.
So that's what the
change is. And guess what? The killer was there at there. And
there was a video taken from here. And so these are FBI agents,
are they?
Look, Tyler Robbins's dad owns the construction company that
paved over Charlie Kirk's blood. Retweet if you demand answers.
Gro says, "Precision Granite Marble LLC owned by suspect Tyler
Robinson's dad, Matt Robinson. If true, bombshell cover up."
Okay. Wow. Tyler Robinson's father paved over it.
Whoa. Wow. Wow. Wow. Okay.
Got the Tucker thing. The other direction we could go is just
going right into Candace's response. I kind of want to go timelinewise,
which means I should have led with the Tucker thing before this.
So, we're going to do the Theo von Tucker thing real quick in
the middle. >> Um, but know that this was before >> this
was before Erica Kirk went on Fox News this morning. >> Oh,
yeah. And uh and I love his wife and know his wife >> well
and so I feel emotional about his own, you know, I just haven't
>> this is the first time he's talking about Charlie's
murder in a way that's not like supportive of every everything.
Okay, one sec. >> Wanted everything to do with it. But
I will say a couple of things. I don't understand the official
story at all.
Uh, I assassination. >> I don't I don't I don't understand
it and I want to make sure that there is a like a truly rigorous
and honest federal investigation of it and I'm definitely concerned
about that. A B
the I I think that um one of I You think Tucker is a spy? Probably
some kind of he's something. I It's probably he's like Russian
involved somehow. It's just a it's a question of how sincerely
he's involved with the Russians versus the >> Don't know
many of the details, but I know that uh recently Candace said
that
uh Egyptian registered aircraft were following uh Erica Kirk
Charlie's widow around for a number of years in different places
in the world. That's one of the weirdest things I've ever heard.
And I just want to say that that is factually true.
>> That's true. So that's like the one data point that
I happen to know is true. What does that mean? I have literally
no idea. I can't even guess. But that's very very strange. >> And
what does Egyptian could mean? Aircrafts from Egypt. Who knows?
>> I think that they were registered in Egypt. And um so
but that that fact is true. So I >> that enough
um and and it also her claim that you know there were kind of
a disproportionately large number of foreign registered cell
phones. I mean, no doubt he's like looked at some of the stuff
Candace has produced, right? >> Causing a lot of turmoil.
Is it true or not? I can't assess it. I'm not the FBI. I'm a
freaking podcaster. But I do know how the system works. And it's
really simple. The FBI
and isn't the FBI?
>> The what? >> Has this case? and of course the
state of Utah. It's their job to not only find out what happened,
present it to the public in a way that restores some confidence
that you can like have justice in this country that we have functioning
law enforcement. I I don't have confidence in that because there's
a lot of evidence that we don't have that. So restore confidence
by being honest and telling us. So again, I just want to know
what the evidence is that Charlie Kirk was murdered by anyone
else but Tyler Robinson for the exact stated reasons that were
given. That's all. That's I just want to know that. That makes
sense. So why? And if they don't do that, and they haven't done
that, they have not done that, how can you be mad at Candace
Owens or anyone else for filling a vacuum that they left?
>> Well, Candace is Okay. No, the people with the authority
are the ones >> like let's say hypothetically
and I I can't say this for sure or not, but what if there was
like a security company that they were paying for that was also
flying private somewhere around them or something like that
basically tailed them cost them a certain amount of money and
they were like a disconnected security team or something. I have
no idea. I mean that sounds like way too expensive. Taking actual
chartered flights
to
like behind Oh yeah, that sounds way too expensive. But what
other explanation is there? I guess I have to see. Dude, I really
have to go watch the entire Ian Carol stream of like what does
he mean when they say the the planes were following them?
What does Candace means when she says the planes were following
them? I actually don't know. And I suspect based on every single
time I look at the sincerity of the claims that Ian Carol or
Candace Owens makes, I find out they're massively overexaggerated
or just entirely fabricated.
Search it on Grock. No, I don't want to search it on Grock. I
just want to I just want to
the love of God. I didn't want to have to look into the plane
thing cuz it's just so stupid. >> Responsible. And >> do
we need to go check flight radar or what? Well, that's what Ian
Carol did. That's the problem is they never know how to state
their claims. >> They're the ones who should be held responsible
when there's a failure. Not some podcaster, not me, not you,
not Candace, the people whose job it is. And their default assumption
was we acted alone. Really? Why do you think that? What about
life suggests that people typically act alone? When was the last
time you acted alone in anything? I don't go, you know, right?
So, a b
last time I ded off
something that I do alone,
I acted
Is that hard to understand? Oh, hold on. So, I was try watching
anything else today morning and I was toldical
was DG of the year 2024 and he tries to sabotage Destiny and
trying to get Pisco to take to make content. Either DG is actually
brain dead or Santa is a snake.
Oh, well, we don't have to really question which one that is.
Wait, when is that uh when is that clip from? You had a time
stamp for that? That would be funny. I'd watch that. I didn't
do anything to Pisco. I I I think I said, "Oh, you guys don't
want Pisco to look into this because like if he starts looking
up facts of how Destiny's acting and he's aware of them, well,
I don't think he can really stand by Destiny, right?" Like I
think the way Destiny's acted in the wake of stuff sort of
as soon as people become aware of that and it's just difficult
to make them aware of that. But when as they become aware of
it, I think there's like I think he's kind of hooped for serious
people. I think although I guess there's a chance he builds up
his platform big enough that it won't matter.
He'd need like a Fentes like resurgence. He needs his generational
run. He wants that to happen. Is Pisco returning to Destiny?
No, I don't think so. We covered a tweet thread today where some
DJ was accusing him of being like a hypocrite and he was like
kind of kneeling on them. So, it was kind of funny.
We know that >> uh go to the Discord PJ forhead if you
for knowledge of this because they posted about it on X and said
Charlie Kirk is going to be killed on this date and he was. >> Is
that true? >> Yes, it's true. >> So, were they just
guessing? Was it a guessing thing where every day? >> Maybe.
Maybe. Have those people been interviewed? Have they been hauled
in to FBI HQ and
had a long
>> It would be um It would be weird if Dan said that though
because at the time Dan told me that he had no problem with people
who had that take. that he agreed that Destiny did all the things
he was accused of and that he'd like no issues with it. So, I
wonder what's changed that he would call me a snake now. It'
be kind of weird.
Would be kind of weird. No. Wouldn't that be weird? >> It's
not enough to tell me. Oh, trans. I'm not pror, by the way. Um,
>> but was that the guy or his boyfriend? >> Well,
exactly. Exactly. Right. Tell >> it was the boyfriend.
What do you mean exactly? Theo Theo was like, I followed this
vaguely. Wasn't that the boyfriend? I I didn't think that was
like It was the boyfriend who shot him, right? There's the there's
the partner who is >> This guy
>> became so radicalized that he murdered a stranger. Just
I'm not saying it didn't happen. I'm saying I want an explan.
>> I mean, it sounded like this guy was kind of a like
totally badass lone wolf kind of guy and then he decided that
I hate Charlie. It sounded like he spent his entire life training
to solo lone wolf somebody without realizing it cuz that's just
called growing up in middle America in a family that shoots guns
and he spent his whole life training for it without realizing
it and then he decided that he hated someone enough to do it.
I don't know what to tell you. Man, this guy used to go on like
this guy used to go on like multi-day camping trips by himself
where he would like it would just be him like canoe like kayaking
down a river and setting up his tent every night and just living
out in the wilderness in Utah just by himself.
There's like a certain kind of guy who does that and shoots guns
and plays video games on Discord. Okay, that is the most dangerous
person in America. And there's a lot of them. Well, there not
that many, but there's a there's a couple of them. It's terrifying.
Okay. >> Explanation for how it happened. Why wouldn't
I? >> I agree. >> Why do people like Candace so much?
She's an amazing broadcaster. Yes, because they sense in her
she might be wrong. Is she lying to me? Not on purpose. They
sense. >> Uh, all right. It was about it and wanted to
rent. I'll check tomorrow for your response. I'm not tracking
the situation, but it's disappointing that you would ask people
to attack Destiny while he is in the middle of a court case.
Oh, you might be looking at like the thing where some maybe they
might look at the thread where some DGER said, "Oh, I wish Pisco
would comment on this." And I'm like, "Oh, you don't want Pisco
to comment on it?" Maybe. But I wasn't tell I wasn't saying Pisco
has to talk [__] about Destiny. I was saying I think
Pisco
I think Pisco
You wouldn't like Pisco's comments. I just don't think you would.
>> Yeah, I don't think so. >> The purity of her intent.
That's the truth. And I can say as someone who's dealt with government
officials my whole life,
I'm not vouching for everything Candace claims. I don't even
know a lot of what she claims cuz I'm working on other stuff
and it makes me sad also. But the point is,
do I trust? You're asking him to investigate Tiny. Oh, like jokingly
I'm like, Pisco, please go. But it was all referencing a tweet.
I was like, oh, please Pisco, look into it. That would be really
funny. I'm pretty
you weren't serious, but the essence of what you said was you
guys should totally go tell Pisco to check into it because it
won't work out for you. Yeah, that's what I thought. Yeah, I'm
pretty sure that's what it was. >> This more than I trust
your average
>> DOJ official. >> But it wasn't that I brought
Pisco up. It was that somebody was accusing Pisco of being a
hypocrite and they were tagging Pisco like under something I
was like under the thread, right? I was reading a tweet where
they were um what do you call it? Um I was I was responding to
some tweet from some DJer.
Are you joking? >> That's not even close, dude. Yeah. >> Oh,
cuz they're making fun of Pisco's motivation. And that'll be
what Dan was mad about, I'm guessing. I I think Dan would be
upset about that. These years have been bothering Pisco about
it before you said anything. Let's go. Nothing like some good
oldfashioned harassment.
Okay. All right. So, we have this response was to was from
The Von and Tucker Carlson. And then we had the Erica Kirk bit.
And then we get Candace Owens doing like a little impromptu response.
Okay. A little impromptu response. >> Okay, super fun show
today. You're probably seeing the clips, but Erica has >> Hey,
Laauo.
What is this lens?
Holy sh Dude, what the [__] You guys see it? You
guys You guys see it, right? I can't be the only one who sees
it.
Bro, what is happening with Candace?
What is happening with Candace Owens over here? What is What
is she doing? What is happening? off on conspiracy
>> What is this lens?
Hello,
Candace. Are you okay?
>> Obviously, every journalist
out there is emailing me because it's it's about me. It's indirect,
but it's also about me. And don't worry, in case you think it's
not about me, she is going >> How long till Destiny starts
posting Pisco? Oh,
well, funny you mentioned >> Going to name check me on
stage with Barry Weiss on Saturday. How do we know? Because our
mommys
be everywhere. And they recorded the town hall today. And as
soon as the town hall concluded, we got a flutter of emails.
And what she says about the Egyptian plane.
>> Wait, what? Well, like nothing. >> I'm sorry.
Not going to lie. It's a little suspicious. It's weird. It's
>> What's that mean? Um, probably because nobody's been
honest about what has happened in like any of these situations.
people like uh Aerodite, people like Counterpoints, people like
all of these people. Probably because these people have refused
to be a honest about anything that's happened here. I'm feeling
like I might have to do a whole accounting of facts and I'm just
going to be very honest about everything that's been posted when
it was posted and how it totally excavates me like or excavates
it totally exonerates me. Right? Basically, for all of this doxing
stuff, there's almost no possible way you can claim that it's
my fault. And unfortunately, nothing but a total accounting of
when everything happened will do that. So now, because nobody
else can be honest, I feel like probably I'm going to have to
go and stream about it and talk about it. So, we'll see. We'll
see if anybody else, you know, is going to be honest about anything.
We'll >> It's a weird response. Um, so look, we got to
go there. Okay. Super fun show. >> Wow. We got to go there.
We got to go there. So, you're going to do a manifesto? No. I'm
probably just going to go look how obvious this is.
Look how obvious this is. It's going to It could be like an infographic.
It'll take like 30 seconds. Look how obvious this is. I just
want I just thought other people would be honest at some point,
but they weren't ever.
And
that's that's what they're incentivized to do, I guess. >> Okay,
you guys. Now, I wasn't sure about Erica. I was waiting. Okay.
So, from there, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Did I get Oh,
okay. So, then we get that Candace response and then we have
finally the Tucker Carlson response. Okay. Tucker Carlson posted
that this this Tucker Carlson posted this this morning shortly
after the Erica segment and shortly before Candace went live.
>> In the 3 months since Charlie Kirk was murdered, I've
really tried not to comment on the murder investigation in public.
And it's not because I don't care, of course. I love Charlie
and knew him well since he was a was a teenager, but I haven't
said anything about it. I really tried not to say anything about
it. First, because I don't really know um anything that everyone
else doesn't know. I've asked around, but of course, how do you
know what the truth is? Um but the other reason I haven't said
anything is because I know personally a number of the people
uh involved in what's now become a very large story. I know them
really well. Um, and and I really think a lot of all of them
on every side. Um, Candace Owens, I've known a long time. I love
Candace. >> No, I think probably with like these communities,
I don't know how you can get around. What? What? Why? Why dance?
Why dance? I I don't know why you'd have to dance around anything
to be honest with you. Probably probably not a kick stream to
be honest with you, but we'll see. Blake Nef at >> I think
I think a Substack post just taking into account everything would
be very appropriate. We'll see. >> USA once worked for
me at a couple of different places and I love Blake Nef. Erica
Kirk I've known since she was dating Charlie Kirk and I I love
Erica Kirk and I think these are all really really decent people
and so it's been my desire for 3 months not to get involved in
any of this and in general to think to myself anybody who is
earnestly searching for the truth whether they're right or wrong
but as long as they're motivated by a desire to find out what
happened and they're >> realistically I'll probably do
a version that's anonymized like really heavily so that I don't
have to like basically give any info about people. But then I'm
going to eventually like I'll have a version that's like I'll
basically censor things and then I'll have the actual version
because I know people won't believe the censored version, right?
It's the unfortunate facts
Yeah, but I I doubt I'll ever I doubt I'll ever post the uncensored
version. I just don't think so. But unfortunately, you need like
everything written out really really purposefully, right? Are
you bl Are you are people blaming you for doxing or something?
Yeah, Destiny and a bunch of his like friends try to say that
like my community doxes and it's just never happened. Um you
get banned for it in my community. There's never been anybody
that like they also say it's like a Kiwi Farms community or something
when Kiwi Farms is like banned from being linked and
right. It's just it's all nonsensical. And it's especially nonsensical
because for the vast majority of people around Destiny who were
doxed that I'm blamed for, they were doxed before I'd ever not
been on the same page as Destiny, right? Like I was literally
streaming as a part of his
when all of these people were being doxed and harassed.
And then I just keep getting blamed for things that happened
way before that.
is very it's very goofy, very obvious,
but I kind of didn't want to just direct people to it, but it
seems like nobody
nobody's gonna be honest otherwise. So, just need to put it out
there. >> Charlie's memory by getting to justice. Anyone
who's doing that, I'm not going to criticize. Again, no matter
what track they're on, lots of us, and this has certainly happened
to me, have good moments, but good motives and but wind up in
the wrong place. But it's a sincere mistake. So that >> I
don't care about mo dude I can't mind readad people. I don't
care about their motives. I care about the like effect or maybe
I care about their motives a little bit but unfortunately the
effect is like really bad. And the effect for Candace which is
hundreds of thousands of dollars per hour up to $100,000 per
hour. That really questions my ability to understand her motives
or qu I mean it makes me question her motives. Sorry. like I
I don't know if she can actually purely evaluate her own motives.
>> That that definitely happens. I have done that and so
I've just wanted to stay out. >> And then the other day
conversation with Theo Vaughn and it was not about Charlie Kirk
or anything related to it, but that topic came up. >> Um
and I said in effect, you know, I don't trust the FBI. Um, and
that gave some people the impression that I was, you know, accusing
them of being involved in Charlie's assassination. And of course,
I wasn't. Uh, and I certainly didn't mean to. Um, but it gives
me the chance now to say what I think, which is that we should
not necessarily trust the FBI. And by the way, why would we?
It's not an attack on, you know, the political leadership of
it. I known Dan Bonino for example for a long time and like Dan
and don't imagine he would ever be involved in intentionally
covering up a murder of somebody. I don't believe that. But
>> like it's pretty paint by numbers. But the Russia thing
could be as simple as
what do you call it? I think it could be as simple as like well
Russia likes to cause chaos. They like to people cause chaos
a lot of chaos, right? And and like are is he just getting paid
to like call into question as much as possible every US institution?
Is that like Tucker's goal ultimately to just degrade all trusting
institutions as much as like maximally?
Because I feel like that's the effect of stuff like this. But
I don't know. >> Dan Bunino and Cash Patel for that matter
or at the top of the org chart, but this is a huge organization
and parts of it act independently from leadership. That's the
nature of bureaucracy. So saying, "Well, I like Dan Bunino and
don't think he would do something wrong on purpose," which is
how I feel, doesn't mean that I trust the FBI or have to trust
the FBI. And again, why would I? If there's one lesson of the
last election, the 2024 election, it's that a lot of our biggest
systems, our biggest institutions, >> Jesus Christ.
So, I guess we're just finishing up Tucker Tucker's
>> in them and that needs to be Guys, the FBI. Like, I
don't trust the FBI. There's an Indian guy in charge. Why would
I trust the FBI? Oh my god. I didn't say I was I didn't say anything
bad about Indian people. Are you insane? Are you insane? >> And
as if we needed more proof of it,
we'd learned what a lot of us suspected for years that January
6 was in effect a setup and the FBI was key to that setup. And
it's still not clear that everyone involved in that setup at
the FBI has been fired or punished for that.
So no person, no American is under some moral obligation to believe
everything the government tells you. >> Come on, man. >> Purely
institutions or agencies that have a long document. >> Oh
man, I'm just glad they gave me I was leaving Mr. Mootin alone,
but I'm going to go comment on that stuff now.
Aha.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Also,
does anybody know like what I did to really upset them? Like
what part of my They say I like lie or something, but I'm like
what's the lie? Where's the lie?
I I would just be curious like where's the lie? Like everything's
so vague. Yeah. Okay. mented factually documented track record
of committing crimes, participating illegally in our political
system, for example, as the FBI has done, manufacturing crimes,
setting people up, distorting justice. That's the opposite of
their job, of course, which is to get to justice through facts,
and then to tell the rest of us how they arrived at this conclusion
to prove to the rest of us that the right people are being
So, we're not under any obligation.
Of course, we shouldn't like invent
theories to discredit the FBI, but it's not enough to have government
officials tell us, well, this is the truth. We have a right,
probably an obligation to say, well,
can you prove it? And if you can't, I don't have to believe you.
So, if there's one thing that bothers me above all about the
investigation into Charlie Kirk is that that is getting lost.
as people argue over what happened. We are
potentially
>> Oh, I don't think of him as like open game or something.
I'm just I'm laughing that like Well, I tried not to cuz Pichu
was so supportive in the aftermath. I just wonder like what's
changed? Like genuinely, I wonder what's changed. What does he
think is different? Yeah. I But surely they would just talk about
it too, right? Obviously, they would just talk about it
>> letting our
our largest federal law enforcement agency off the hook. It is
the job of the FBI to find out what happened and to tell the
rest of us, not hide behind.
>> I wonder on >> Well, it's national security confidential
sources. No, tell us what happened. Show us what happened. Convince
us what happened. That's your job.
And we shouldn't accept anything less. And by the way, when we
do accept something less,
then you know, new
explanations fill the vacuum left by the FBI, which we pay to
explain to us what happened.
And so, I'm going to really do my best not to talk about things
I don't understand,
state things as though I know them when I don't know them. I'm
going to do my best to stay out of it because I love Charlie
and I want justice to be done in this case, but the rest of us
should remain skeptical. We have a duty to remain skeptical and
we should not be ashamed of our skepticism.
>> Um, yeah, but your skepticism should be warranted and
well like wellounded,
right?
Other than K other than Cash Patel's
complete ineptitude, you have no real reason to to distrust the
FBI. him like announcing stuff early for that investigation is
the only thing that leads us to believe that that investigation
was inept. If that investigation had just proceeded normally
and they'd waited to announce stuff until they knew things for
sure, nobody would have a problem with it. Wouldn't even be an
issue.
But Cash would tell us a so unlucky.
Okay, finally. So that's Tucker coming out right after right
after Erica says, "Hey, can you stop going after us?"
And Tucker's like, "Yeah, Candace is doing great work. Her heart's
really in the right place.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
And of course, Candace was
electric. Okay. Candace was ready to go.
175,000 live viewers today at least. I think 177,000 is my screenshot.
I'm not sure I saw a better one, but I think 177K.
Yeah, 1764.
176.4
watching
Anyway, let's let's get to it cuz we got to finish up this Candace
stuff before we got to go to bed. >> Kind of a situation
for her to be in. Obviously, having lost her husband,
uh, becoming the CEO and the chairman of a company. It's just
a lot of transition and it's nice to
>> We're talking about it like he how Nux talks about chill.
I don't think so. wait for more information
before you prejudge or some, you know, just assume, make an assumption
about somebody and it maybe is not based in reality. >> Well,
we are getting a lot more of Erica Kirk this week. I'll tell
you that because she has been doing the rounds in the media really
over the last couple of weeks and she just gave an interview
live with Harris Faulner on Fox News where she finally addressed
the quote unquote conspiracy theories. And I have to say this
because it's true,
but it completely missed the mark for me. I am sorry. It just
has. But the good news is that she is now unmmering the water
in terms of her intentions with this massive political organization.
That's good news truly because we knew Charlie and now we are
getting an opportunity to know Erica.
Plus, later on in the show, it's knives out for Tucker Carlson
as always. He's trending right now because he has officially
waited into the who killed Charlie K. Look, I have been very
patient. I do tend to focus on the evidence that's in front of
us. Obviously, asking questions, we come up across something
that someone has said and it doesn't add up or if they lied,
create a list. And you guys were coming after me cuz I >> She
has that many viewers on YouTube. Yes. Two hour stream, one hour
stream, 1.4 million viewers. 1.4 4 million views streamed 9 hours
ago. And like realistically, you'd expect the views to drop if
they were botted. YouTube removes the views if they're botted,
right? Like they YouTube does not let you just keep views that
are botted. They've never been like that. And if you look at
our live streams, they've been hitting millions of views and
they're not getting reset at all. I don't think I've ever seen
it take more than a week to get reset. These are all like hourlong
streams, live streams that are doing millions and millions of
views every single time. And she's making hundreds of thousands
of dollars. Although the super chats are not as impressive as
you'd expect. You'd expect the super chats to be better, but
they're not. Or at least maybe they're not public. >> I
was saying, look, you can >> you'd expect her to be like
at the top of Playboard, right? Like most live viewers. Oh, nice.
Most live viewers weekly. Maybe she's just not picked up by Playboard
or something cuz why wouldn't she be on here?
Most live viewers typical gamer 180,000 this week daily. Is this
guy Oh, I I'm going to run. I don't have a subscription to the
site. So, most super chatted.
No, not in Canada. [__] Oh, that's why it's Canada.
Oh, gowide. Okay, never mind. Candace Owens. >> Erica is
thinking how she's feeling or what she should be wearing, but
she hasn't actually said anything yet. Right. That was my stance.
She hasn't actually said anything yet. Give her a chance. Okay.
And now she's making the rounds uh in the press because Charlie's
book, this posthu humus book is coming out about the Sabbath
and she's speaking about the quote unquote conspiracies as she
sits down with a lot of these news >> So, first and foremost,
she's sitting down here with Harris Faulner and I just want to
show you a couple of clips from this sitdown which is now trending.
And she begins by addressing the question which has been in the
air regarding where Charlie Kirk is buried. That question resurfaced
this week in a big way because Milo Yiannopoulos and a few others
have asserted with absolute certainty that Charlie has not yet
been buried. That's what they're saying. They say they have proof
of that and at first Harris Faulner is asking about that claim.
Take a listen. >> Talk to me about this part of the conspiracies
that are out there. This disturbing part that people are trying
to guess where Charlie is. Can I have one thing?
Can I have one thing?
Can my children have one thing?
Everything was public. >> They are hungry. Can my children
have >> We will be building the most beautiful memorial
for my husband at Turning Point USA. And it will be for the world
to see. It will be spectacular and it will have basically museum
style for our Charlie, for my Charlie. >> But can I have
one thing? Can my babies have one thing where we hold it sacred?
Where my husband is laid to rest? where I don't have to be worried
about some secular revolutionary coming and destroying my husband's
grave while my daughter is sitting there praying one thing that
this is my husband yes he was Charlie Kirk to the world and I
know so many people love my husband and I am grateful for that
but this is my husband and I want to be able to have one thing
left that is sacred to our family to my in-laws to my babies
and to my parents one thing
okay so on its face I actually agree with that I think that when
people are being buried and where they're being buried and how
their funerals are. >> Listen guys, I just want to say
on that I agree with Erica. Okay, let her have one thing. Let
her have I love Erica and this is totally reasonable.
You can tell by how nice she's being now. This about to flip
this about that is that is a very private matter. Okay, so objectively
I agree with what she's saying. Okay. But subjectively, because
we are dealing with the subject of Erica Kirk, uh, and what transpired
immediately following Charlie's assassination, this is going
to be read as Meghan Markle syndrome. Okay? Megan Markle syndrome,
where you want privacy when you want it, but you want publicity
whenever you want it. And that just doesn't work. Okay? It doesn't
work that way. I honestly think it was said best by Bethany Frankle,
not related to the situation. Uh Bethany Frankles on Real Housewives,
a real um a a a show, a reality show. And she was referring to
one of the housewives who lived her life very publicly, showcased
her marriage, was buying tons of Louis Vuitton bags, and they
had tons of money. And then when the relationship soured, the
housewife basically asked the public for privacy. And Bethany
was like, "No, this isn't how it works. Like, we were riding
with you on the way up. We're riding with you on the way out.
You don't get to like pick and choose when you want privacy and
when you don't want privacy." And subjectively as it, you know,
in the matter of Erikica Kirk, this is the same person who recorded
had somebody record her over Charlie Kirk's casket. That was
not our business truly. And I can say that decision was made
by her and it there is yeah some credence to the claim that everybody
grieavves differently. I wouldn't even record myself over a casket
ever. Okay. Some people maybe perhaps want to have that memory.
But the decision to publish that, you crying over your husband's
casket and to publish his dead body on Instagram was a decision
that was made by Erica. And we can watch that. Take a >> Oh,
I love >> Oh, no. CANDACE, NO.
OH, THIS IS already brutal. This already [__] up.
Don't show me Charlie's hands. I don't want to see his hands.
No. Gross.
GROSS. NO. DON'T KISS. NO. DON'T KISS.
>> Call it a mannequin. Say it's a mannequin, Candace.
Say it's a >> That is an incredibly personal and an incredibly
intimate moment. an intimate moment that you invited the public
into. Okay, you that there's there was no reason to do that outside
of wanting to share something that was very private with the
public. >> And now you fast forward 3 months removed and
it's why why does the public want to know where where he's buried?
It doesn't work like that. You you have to make a decision. I
want this always to be private or I want this always to be public.
That's that's my personal feedback there. Later on in this same
interview, she launches into a strong defense of Turning Point
USA employees who have just as a matter of fact told many lies,
many inconsistencies. These are verifiable. So they are currently
lying to the public or they have lied to the public. But she
is going to deliver quite an impassioned defense regarding these
particular individuals and the organization as a whole. And I
want you to hear her passion. Take a listen. >> How is
that disgusting? Cuz his hands are like green. I'm sorry. And
also just recording it. And also
playing it up a little bit for stream. Not a lot though. It is
pretty gross. He's like dead and
and Yeah.
I'm sorry man. It's a Yeah, kind of. It's kind of gross, man.
>> What are they taking from you right now? Nothing. But
I will tell you what they are doing. It reminds me so much of
chapter 6 in the book of Nehemiah.
He is building a wall and the town's people are at the base of
that hill saying, "Nehemiah, calling him all these names, saying
all these things, come on down." Every single time he had the
same message for >> You're the next contestant of The Price
is Right.
NEHEMIAH, COME ON DOWN. You're the next contestant on The Price
>> Times in a row. I cannot come down. I am busy building.
That is how I feel. I do not have time to address the noise.
My silence does not mean that I am complacent in the studio.
>> My silence does not mean that somehow Turning Point
USA and all of the handpicked staff that loved my husband and
my husband loved them is somehow in on it. >> We are busy
building. And you know what I thought? I thought these people
are human. We are all grieving in our own way and they are trying
to find the answer to something that happened that was so evil.
They are trying so hard and I get that. We're doing the same.
Anytime we hear a lead or anytime we hear anything, we send it
to the authorities. Please dig into this. No rock will be unturned.
I want justice for my husband, for myself, for my family more
than anyone else out there. So for me, you want to keep telling
me to come down while we're we're building. I don't have time
for that. >> But here's my breaking point on that. >> Come
after me. Call me names. I don't care. Call me what you want.
Go down that rabbit hole, whatever. But when you go after my
family, my Turning Point USA family, my Charlie Kirk show family,
when you go after the people that I love, and you're making hundreds
and thousands of dollars every single episode
going after the people that I love because somehow they're in
on this.
Candace's Did I do that face is so funny. Did I do that? Did
I do that? Am I making that money? Did I do that? I'm sorry.
It's just I just She makes this face all the time at this really.
I wish it would. >> I'm sorry, but that that whole thing
right there is frustrating. And I'm going to explain to you why.
I just I just do not accept any of that. First and foremost,
the idea that she does not have time. Okay, she definitely has
time. Okay, she's done Hannity. She's >> Are you moving
her eyeballs? I'm moving one frame back and forth. >> I'm
just moving one frame back and forth my keyboard. And it was
like within the couple frames she' moved her face. idea that
she does not have time. Okay, she definitely has time. Okay,
she's done Hannity, she's done the five, she's done Fox and Friends,
she's done outnumbered, she's done me and Kelly live, she sat
down with the New York Times. She made time, by the way, in case
you don't remember, to fly to DC for Sergio Gore to be sworn
into the ambassador to India as as the ambassador to India, which
feels kind of obscure and not necessarily related to Turning
Point USA affairs, building affairs or whatever it is, but sure,
that's fine. I mean, obviously, you're also allowed to be a >> Uh-oh.
India about to be involved in Charlie Kirk's murder next week.
This just in, guys. The writing room had a genius. A stroke of
genius. Okay, we bring India into it. Which is why Cash Patel
is this up so badly. All right. Because the Indian government
is pressuring him. All right. Oh my god. Cinema, let's go Candace.
You can roll it in. I believe in you. >> If that's the
homie and that's what you want to do. Sure. But we are indeed
speaking about a a coast to coast flight to stand up to next
to somebody and basically say Charlie Charlie loved you. That
was like the whatever 15-second speech that she gave. Right.
Here's here's actually we have a clip of that speech that she
gave. >> Well, he was also very good friends with a guy
named Charlie. We just knew Miss Charlie and his uh wife who
we love so much is here with us. And maybe uh you know how close
they were together. Maybe Erica, you could say a couple of words,
>> Charlie loved you. It's hard not to get emotional because
I know that he would have been the first phone call when he found
out that we were going to be taking this position. And the way
that I was able to witness the two of you work together for years
and to champion and support the president was absolutely humbling
to witness. And I am so proud of you. And Charlie is going to
be with you every single day. >> Who's the ambassador to
India? Is it the huge Is it the huge nose big and tall guy or
is it the actual Indian-American looking guy? Old Vivvec.
Bro, this looks like VC's hairline and his like face and everything
except the facial. Sorry. Except the facial features. It's like
you copy pasted some random white dude's face onto an Indian
guy. Like all the facial features. That's like Sylvester Salone
right there. Copy pasted onto Vivec Wamasami's head.
Why
day um in spirit and I will be praying for you every day because
I know that this is just the beginning of an incredible opportunity
for you and and sir, thank you for um allowing Sergio to have
this beautiful moment. >> You don't see You don't see Wait,
no, no, no. Oh, no. I meant I meant Alpuccino. I meant Alpuccino.
I meant Alpuccino. I meant Alpuccino. Sorry, wrong Italian. I
meant Alpuccino. He looks like an Indian Alpuccino. Sorry. I
meant Alpuccino. It's like Indian Alpuccino right here. The
>> Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank
>> That's just an ambassador to India swearing in ceremony.
Again, if that's your friend, you want to be there, that makes
sense. She's also a person. Um, and she can decide what she what
she wants to do there. But the point that I'm making is that's
a coastal flight that she made to be there to watch a paper get
signed. She has also made time for an upcoming CBS News town
hall sit down with Barry Weiss which was filmed today. So Erica
Kirk has time. She has time. It is just what she means to say
not her priority which is you are allowed to prioritize things
in your own life but the this is not a matter of time constraint.
It is not her priority to respond to the majority actually the
majority of people >> she did a whole interview with Barry
Weiss. Apparently >> think of this as BS. The majority
of Can Candace fall off already? Uh, you just added 1,000 concurrent
viewers to her view count. Okay, she's at 176,000 today, she'll
be at 180,000 tomorrow with comments like that. Okay, you criticize
Candace, that's 1,000 more viewers. You You say Candace is stupid,
that's thousand more viewers. You prove her wrong on something,
that's 2,000 more viewers. >> People think Turning Point
is acting suspicious and she does not feel that it is what she
wants to do um as a matter of priority responding. Okay, that's
fine. Now, to that point that people are making hundreds and
thousands of dollars,
I just don't get how there's not someone on this uh very large
PR team as we're seeing these PR campaigns. Well, doesn't go,
hey, maybe we should strike that, you know, like, you know, they
made 40 $40 million like two nights ago at Mara Lago. Maybe that
feels kind of a little bit like, let them be cakeish. Oh, and
we've made more than separately from Mara Lago, Turning Point
USA since Charlie was, just so you guys know, this is a fact,
has made more than $100 million. Oh no, >> that is separate
from the >> Candace. Candace is pocket watching. Oh boy.
You want to pocket watch me, Erica?
Well, two can play that game.
Two can play that game, [__]
$40 million they made at Marago the other night. So since Charlie
has died, that organization has taken in $140
million.
But gosh darn you people that are making hundreds of dollars
every day on YouTube talking about Charlie Kirk's assassination
and the BS narrative that is being fed and the very obvious psychological
operation that is being employed to make you accept the BS that
they are trying to sell to us. Gosh darn you. Thousand. Did you
make $1,000 today speaking about Charlie Kirk? Well, you should
be ashamed of yourself, says Turning Point USA, who in large
part made that money because of those very people who gave to
the organization immediately following Charlie Kirk's assassination.
And that the thing that is especially absurd about that is trying
to like almost like I want to be clear that Turning Point USA
is my family. The Charlie Kirk show is my family. You know, like
she's she's just expanding the wings of people that we're not
allowed to critique because they're in the family. If you call
them fam, you can't you can't critique them, right? Oh, I'm sorry.
Uh, we actually are showing a clip of Rob McCoy defending trying
to like launder the repetition of
that's fam. That's the CK show, fam. Oh, I'm sorry. Uh, we are
actually pointing to the fact that we know for certain that this
person organization is
>> I don't I don't really think she was thinking about
it that deeply, Candace. I think she was just like, could you
stop? Maybe. I don't think she was like doing a super deep like
critique or takedown of you, but hey, whatever. >> That's
fam. That's my bet is my Don't you get me upset. I know that
this is a now $150 million in the last threemonth organization
and we employ tons of people, but you can't you can't critique
you can't critique the fam. And I hate to say this, but I'm going
to be very clear here. This is why there are many people who
do not believe that women are equipped to lead companies because
what you are watching here is an what? No way. She just went
there.
You're a discredit to your gender, you
Bro, what? >> Unbelievably emotional response that is absent
of any logic. Okay. If you really care about your team, answer
the questions. Okay. Just demystify the entire event. Answer,
come out, sit down, answer the questions so people don't think
Turning Point USA looks so suspicious. Don't try to like mom
the organization and say, "Well, mother's upset because people
are coming after her kids and all of the subsidi multi-million
dollar subsidiaries. That's my children." Okay. the the multi-million
dollar subsidiary turning point like turning point action all
those are my kids so you can't critique them not a good idea
>> critiquing turning point action >> yeah okay it
may work in PR world you guys I know have it's an obvious PR
campaign it's never been more obvious of a psychological operation
I actually wish they would put me on payroll so I could help
them make these things look more organic than having every single
person that has been telling us to stop asking questions all
make the exact same video within 4 seconds of each other being
like WHOA
WHOA ERICA KIRK SHUTS DOWN the no she didn't even respond to
one of the conspiracies. She gave us emotion. She gave us emotion.
She said, "I'm a mother. I am a wife." >> Erica Kirk didn't
respond. She reacted like a [__] woman. This is why
people think women aren't fit to lead. Okay. That's why women
That's why people think women aren't fit to lead because women
like Erica just react emotionally. They don't even react with
logic.
Damn. >> And we never asked about whether she was mother
or wife. We want to know if she's a CEO and a chairman. And a
CEO and a chairman has to compartmentalize. A CEO and a chairman
cannot respond to valid questions and critiques about finances,
about shady actions that are being taken by people that require
presidential pardons. People that are meaningfully asking uh
why we are not getting a clear answer of what took place in September
10th. A CEO, okay, does not get to respond and say that's my
family. >> I mean, she does. I just feel like she should
have reacted. She should have done Listen, people talk about
the gaslighting over mental illness, but it should have just
been I'm really concerned for Candace's mental health. I think
it's very important we get her help. Okay, Candace, you're crashing
out. Candace, you're mentally ill. Candace, you're crashing out.
People really discount how much that to the >> Okay, that's
my that's my that is what I that's the energy of what I would
>> Candace, wake up. Wakey wakey, Candace.
>> From a mother speaking to a teacher, which I I was this
mom like that's my kid. Okay. And there we'll shut this down
right now. That's my child. This is not a child. Turning Point
USA is an organization and Erica already had an uphill battle
to climb. Like that she had to climb this because by the way,
just because if if this was Goldman Sachs and the president of
Goldman Sachs or managing director over at Goldman Sachs died
in a horrifically violent way, the Goldman Sachs family
uh might mourn for a couple of months, but they would have instantly
had someone to replace that individual. And beyond that, they
would have never
the the public and and the people that um are investing money,
they would have never accepted, well, he's gone, but here's his
wife. She already had an up hill to climb here, right? Like,
this does not make you qualified because you love someone to
take on their job. I am not qualified to do what my husband does.
That's why I said I would I wouldn't want to be the CEO and the
chairman of a company. Actually, there's a great clip of Jordan
Peterson asking that very question. Like, why do women want to
be like, why would you want to have it's actually a lot of work
and it's very stressful and it's a lot of numbers and you're
crunching numbers and you have to be everywhere. Okay, if you
want that, great. If you built a >> Didn't she work at
a hedge fund?
I thought I thought she worked at like a hedge fund. Hold on.
What? That's That can't be I must have misremembered that. She
must have never done that, right? In the conservative blog. Oh,
maybe not. I thought she worked Oh. Uh, she took a job in 2012
as an administrative assistant for a private equity firm in Manhattan,
later moving up to becomes vice president of administration.
Okay. She was an executive assistant. Okay. Okay. Never mind.
Never mind. Never mind. Never mind. I She did work in private
equity, but it was as an assistant. Okay. Oh, my bad. My My bad.
That's a little different.
>> The company and you're in the room like Charlie Kirk
did and you have proven to the public like, "Hey, I built this
company. I didn't even go to college and I've been doing this
for over a decade
>> they need to pull up the doctors to win against Candace."
But they can't say the
the race of the doctors or at what hospital and who owns the
hospital.
It was a doctor. >> Well, Kirk did. You've earned that
street cred. Okay. So, she already had a hill decline because
now they're saying, "Well, this is his wife." And so,
you know, that's it. Well, now you're going to have to prove
that you have the ability to be a CEO and a chairman and not
just a wife who we expect emotion from. And you have you're rightful
in that capacity. You are rightful to have emotion. You are rightful
to be the agreved widow. But you don't get to just be widowed
into the position of chairman and CEO. don't get to respond to
well in this case investors, donors who have given money and
are asking meaningful questions with no you don't you you don't
you don't get replies right now cuz this this is the Charlie
Kirk show fam doesn't work this way. Okay. Um and the broader
point removed from Erica which a lot of these mocking bird influencers
seem to be making is essentially they're saying to us that scientific
inquiry and investigation in and of itself is now patently wrong.
Right? Essentially we should just trust the states. Don't believe
your own instincts. Don't believe your own eyes. Don't ask any
questions. And I really want to stress you guys how utterly ridiculous
that logic is. Right? Because if we follow that logic in any
other situation, there would never be a crime solved ever. Okay?
If we just subscribe to the idea that scientific investigation
is on its face wrong, it would not work. I'll give you a crappy
an analogy here, but imagine if there's like some young mother
and she dies suddenly in the middle of the night, presumably
in the middle of the night, and her husband is the first one
to report it in the morning and the cops show up who happen to
be his buddies. They get there and then they dramatically close
the case in 48 hours and neighbors are like, "Wait a minute,
wait a minute. Excuse me, officers. Actually, you might want
to know some other facts here about this guy." Like, you know,
he's in the mafia. These people would be like, "How dare you
question the people closest to he loved her. That's his wife.
Being a gang member is not evidence. Why are you saying he's
a gang member? It's not evidence. And you had another nosy neighbor
who produces evidence that in the middle of the night before
she died, he saw the guy uh outside, the husband outside, removing
cameras in the front yard. That's not evidence. Yeah, but I saw
him go out in the middle. He put something in his car in the
trunk. He was looking shady. That's not evidence. How dare you
find that to be suspicious?
More nosy neighbors start discussing and they were like, "Hey,
we heard him." They were having actually a heated argument before
she was found dead. It was I think it was about money. Is >> she
doing like a hypothetical about her situation? like that's what's
happening.
she understands she's doing like the disturbia meme and I think
in the standard version of that
uh not the standard version I think it's some versions of that
you find out that like it really is nothing like you can the
people use that story to tell you like to explain how you can
like see patterns that aren't there because of tropes and stuff
like that's at least that's how the Simpsons did it right remember
the Ned Flanders episode where he's like they thought he was
chopping up his wife but he wasn't >> all of a sudden next
thing you You know, you got Alli Stucky from the HOA. She blasts
out an email and she says it's unbiblical. It's unbiblical to
gossip. Hearing an argument is not hard evidence. You have no
right to discuss it. Yeah, we're the nosy neighbors. Okay. We
put together a list of 20 verifiable lies that have been told
in the weeks following this sudden death event. And uh yeah,
we we have some questions. So, we're not going to accept Tim
Pool jumping on the airwaves with big estrogen energy telling
us we're evil because we have like school board elections next.
>> I don't think she's evil. think she's like [__]
and I think she's like the perfect capstone for she's the perfect
gravestone for democracy
that people can't like inform themselves anymore that it's just
like over completely.
It's I don't I don't even think she's evil, man. I just think
like she's just proven that people are too
like the democracy thing isn't working. We need a different system.
Don't have a better suggestion. I'm going down with the democracy
ship. I'm just saying. Seems to be pretty >> Thursday.
We're the nosy neighbors. We don't care about the elections coming
up. We want to know whether or not we are in bed with people
who are capable of murder. People that are capable of covering
up murders. Actually, we the nosy neighbors feel a little bit
less safe in this neighborhood until we know whether or not there
are some psychopathic killers in our midst. How about that?
That's how I feel. I think that's how a lot of people feel, right?
>> Yeah. But you're putting your feelings on everyone else
and you're really compelling about it. Apparently, a lot of middle-aged
women feel your feelings and then they it's contagious and I
don't know what to do about that. Candace, very, very, very disturbing
to me. And I don't know what's to be done now. So, I want to
express that. What the [__] do we do? >> And
this psychological campaign filled with emotional manipulation
and how dare you and oh, the you know, the agreed widow speaks
and so we you're not allowed to question $150 million organization.
No, I reject it. I reject that 100%.
Uh, which is why I will say it has arrived as a blast of fresh
air that on this very same day, Tucker Carlson is is standing
up to the nonsense. He's not speaking about Erica, obviously,
he is friends with Erica, but just the nonsense of what the FBI
is saying. He's waiting in. >> Isn't that really weird
timing for him to be friends with Erica and put that >> saying,
"Yeah, the FBI is not being clear in what happened." And I have
questions uh because and I think it feels like a fresh air, a
blast of fresh air because I and I know many people live recording
for this. We're seeing all of these people that we followed and
we thought that they were hero heroes and suddenly the assassination
has exposed them all to be frauds, you know, like for the right
price, they will join operation mockingb bird. For me personally,
that is how I feel. Okay. Like people in the military that I
thought were forthright, people that were um uh journalists I
thought were
>> I just am so let down and I don't think I would have
been able to to handle if Tucker Carlson was among those people.
The you need hard evidence
as if the killer was going to walk in. But okay, here's how I
did it. Okay, I'm going to give you hard evidence. I was here,
here, or there. Like, what?
Instead, Tucker Carlson is coming out and he is blasting the
corporate and the Fed narrative with common sense. Uh, he joined
Theo Vaughn and here is what he had to say. Take a listen. >> I
don't understand the official story at all. Uh, I assure
that there is a like a truly rigorous and honest federal investigation
of it. And I'm definitely concerned about that. A B the I I think
that um one of I don't know many of the details but I know that
uh recently Candace said that uh Egyptian registered aircraft
were following uh Erica Kirk Charlie's widow around for a number
of years in different places in the world. That's one of the
weirdest things I've ever heard. And I just want to say that
that is factually true. >> That's true. >> So it's
factually true but like what uh
like how much over how many years? the one data point that I
happen to know is true. What does that mean? I
>> literally no idea. I can't even >> I'm so angry
that I have to go and watch and like try to figure out what this
all means if it means something. >> Yes, but that's very
very >> And where's Egyptian could mean aircraft from Egypt?
Who knows? >> I think that they were registered in Egypt
and um so but that that fact is true. So I that enough
>> um and and also her claim that you know there were kind
of a disproportionately large number of foreign registered cell
phones at the event. Um that's also true. So what does that add
up to? I don't know. But it it means that
you know the FBI has a moral and legal obligation to >> massive
celebrity on campus for the first time. Wonder why that might
be an event. H
I can't think of a reason actually. I have no idea. Why would
there be a lot of foreign registered cell phones at a university
for a huge event? Huh? I can't you know I I really can't think
of anything. I can't at all. That's crazy.
Can you guys think of anything why there would be a whole bunch
of like foreign registered phones at a Charlie Kirk event, the
first event of his new debate season?
I can't think of a single reason why that might happen. To look
in every direction and to be open-minded as you would in any
investigation, in journalism, in science, it's all the same process.
I don't know the answer, and I'm going to sift through everything
as open-mindedly as I can, as honestly as I can to get to what
the truth is. That's again, that's science. That's law enforcement.
That's journalism. For real, here's like the problem with that.
Okay, you could say that. You could say, "Well, I trust other
people to do that." >> But I think my issue with Candace
is that I can evaluate her process and how she describes her
process, and I can describe to you exactly why that's
okay. I can describe to you how she takes random claims from
people who aren't like someone who knows something, who can't
prove the claim itself, and she does irrelevant factchecking,
like, "Hey, I'm going to just make sure you're the person you
say you are." And then she goes, "Well, I verified their identity.
They are who they say they are and here's what they said. Essentially
reporting some crackhead story with no verification whatsoever.
Other than that, yes, they really are a crackhead.
Right? That's why I don't like Candace's. That's why I don't
like her process. It's all dog. And the issue Tucker's going
to run into is you don't have infinite time. So you say everybody
should be able to run stuff down, but they can't run stuff down
because they're not made of time.
Okay? They're not made of time. You don't have all the time in
the world. So ultimately,
if you know somebody has a totally flawed process, you can call
them out for that process and ask them questions about it and
say they're full of without having to go, "Oh, I have to run
down every single thing that she's ever said."
Nice job, Jay. That's another 5,000 LIVE VIEWERS. NO.
180,000 live tomorrow. No. Candace,
stop.
We'll sacrifice like half of the Gropers. You can have half of
the Groper souls. Just leave this dimension. Leave this plate
of existence, demon. >> It's justice. Damn it. >> And
I just want to make sure that is happening. And I just don't
have a ton of confidence in the FBI or the men who run it. And
I'm not saying that out of >> at all. >> That's a
scary part, too, cuz >> I'm not alleging anything. I'm
just saying I think it's really important that we have that.
>> That is what authenticity sounds like. And that's what
we're doing here. We are
>> Is that what that sounds like? Somebody's too lazy to
look into the crazy you're saying to be honest with you. Looks
like somebody looks like somebody's too busy to look into it
themselves and they go, "Well, you know, you should be allowed
to do that hypothetically without actually looking at all >> investigating,
right? Sometimes you get >> Oh, I didn't even cover. Apparently,
the US government seized a Venezuelan oil tanker today. It's
just all about oil again. >> Something wrong corrected,
but I was right about the Egyptian planes." And when you hear
Tucker Carlson say that he is confirming that that part is true,
what I take from that is very clear. He grew up with CIA agents.
Okay, this is a guy who grew up in Virginia. his father. He learns
after his father died thought he was just working with the CIA.
No, his father was on the payroll of the CIA. So Tucker's friends
are in the state. So it you should take it um as a concrete fact
that there's something up with these Egyptian planes and they
were in fact following around Charlie and they're following around
Erica as I told you. Wait, I thought the state was like not to
be trusted. And you're telling me the guy who supports you unequivocally
actually is like a spy, a total fed, like an obvious fed with
a ton of Fed friends, but he totally supports you? the crazy
truth seeker who's gonna overturn the system and and prove that
something wrong was done here. Well, that seems kind of fishy.
That seems like a little concern. Well, you know, if I was
I want you guys to know I'm not saying that she's a fed, too.
I'm not saying that she's like on a payroll.
God, I >> And that means people in the NSA, the CIA are
confirming that that is real. And yet just last week, what we
got from Blake Nef, I know he's untouchable. He's in the fam,
but I'm going to go ahead and touch that and say like this is
not okay. The vibe is not >> Nick's monologue was mostly
clowning on this tonight. Yeah, I that's cooler. But if you consider
that that's another plus like 2,000 viewers for her that every
single time Candace is criticized or proven wrong or anything
that somebody denounces her, says she's like evil. Every single
time, that's plus 1,000 to 5,000 new live viewers. She's on her
way to 200,000 live viewers. All right, we keep [__]
up. She can't be She can't be beaten. Okay, she just won. Every
single time you say she's wrong, if you prove she's wrong, that's
actually just way more viewers. Again,
not right. Is making a mockery of it. That is what we mean when
we say none of this is passing the vibe check with Turning Point
USA. There's no clear answers. There's mockery. There's laughter,
but there's no clear answers. And the mockery of the laughter
is not working. Neither are is this idea that, well, now the
the widow has spoken. We're not dealing with the widow. We want
the CEO and the chairman of Turning Point USA to answer. Okay,
you got if you can't compartmentalize, then I don't see how you're
going to be able to lead this organization in the future because
Charlie Charlie worked. We knew who Charlie was cuz he was authentic.
Okay? He didn't just go, "Well, I only make time for like big
pocket donors." Okay? He was sitting college campuses. He was
speaking to people, understanding people. He was changing his
ideas and he was changing minds. And you are not changing my
mind about the fact that something weird happened that day and
that TPUSA is acting funny. um because you you give her give
it an impassioned plea and speak about Nehemiah on Fox News.
Okay, none of it makes any sense. Anyways, Tucker then goes on
and states the obvious predicament further, which is that we
just don't have any faith in the government. Take a listen to
him discussing some of these lingering
>> Here's what I am concerned about. Two, well, a lot of
things. One, he acted alone. Tell me how that worked. I don't
you know, none of us really act alone. >> It's hard to
go anywhere by yourself, too. Exact. >> Thank you. Exactly.
Yeah. >> Except for all the times that you do. You know,
like all of those times that you do. Totally. >> Totally.
Okay. >> Oh, this was total cozer.
Um, I'm gonna totally expose Candace if they don't, but I'm going
to let them try first. I could totally expose her right now,
but I'm not going to. I'm going to let them take a shot. That
was the That was the lowest that was the weakest aura moment
from Nick in the entire generational run. That was That was weak,
man. That was embarrassing. Okay,
that that was crazy to do that. You mean you can kill this and
you're just not doing it? Why? Why can't you just do this now?
The [__] are you talking about? I'm going to wait.
I'm going to let I'm going to let TPUSA take a shot. All part
of the plan. That is queueing on cope. Storm's coming, buddy.
Storm's coming. It totally is. But it's fine. Hopefully something
happens. You're going to have to prove that to me. It's totally
possible. Anything is possible. Weird things have happened. We'll
continue to. But if you're That's not my default assumption,
and it shouldn't be yours. And their default assumption was we
acted alone. Really? Why do you think that? What about life suggests
that people typically act alone? When was the last time you acted
alone in anything? I don't go you know. Right. So a >> coach
the answer to this is anytime you drop off basically Tucker doing
the thing where he pretends he doesn't know what is again. Very
cool. Very cool >> We know that people had fornowledge
of this because they posted about it on X and said Charlie Kirk
is going to be on this date and he was. >> Is that true?
>> Yes, it's true. >> Were they just guessing? Was
it a guessing thing where every day? >> Maybe. Maybe. had
those >> I mean it's a thing where some extremist trans
people were like this better watch his back and they never do
anything and they didn't do anything this time but this time
there was an actual powerful white man who was there to take
some action okay it's like some some totally
uh who some totally what would you call it like executive dysfunctioning
trans people who are like I'm going to get them I'm going to
get them don't come here we'll get you and unfortunately for
them the very powerful strong white man who was ready to take
matters into his own hands, okay,
and do something evil. >> People been interviewed, have
they been hauled into FBI HQ and had a long conversation with
how they knew that? Like, let's get really specific. Why did
you post that? Who have you talked to? Like, if I were doing
this investigation, because I spent my whole life doing noncriminal
investigations called journalism. Like, what do we know is true?
How do we find out? Call everybody. Be open-minded. It's like
a very It's the same process. If I was doing this investigation,
they would be at the very top of the list. Tell me how this guy
who seemed normal became a radical trans furry murderer. It's
not enough to tell me, "Oh, trans. I'm not pror, by the way."
>> Um, but >> was that the guy or his boyfriend?
>> Well, exactly. Exactly. Right. Tell me how this guy
became so radicalized that he murdered a stranger. Just I'm not
saying it didn't happen. I'm saying I want an explanation for
how it happened. Why wouldn't I? >> I agree. >> Oh,
we can't talk about that cuz it'll, you know, prejudice the jury
pool. Really, you're you've told the world that you have both
a confession from him in his text to his boyfriend and the murder
weapon with his fingerprints on. I think you got a pretty solid
case. So, why is it so difficult to just explain? So, I have
said from the beginning, if you don't like what Candace Owens
is saying, why don't you call her and offer a more plausible
explanation for what happened? OH, SHE'S BAD. SHE'S BAD. OKAY,
I mean, I like her a lot. I don't think she's bad, but I love
her actually, but let's just stipulate she's bad, but why wouldn't
you do that? >> I don't agree with some of the stuff that
the rabbit hole she goes down. But I don't know. But I like the
fact that she likes to dig in the garden. You >> that's
that's the most like middle-aged womancoded response ever from
the Ovon. That's exactly how every woman who watched C. I'm sorry.
I'm going to blame women for this. I'm sorry, but that's how
they all feel. That's literally it. Listen, I don't I don't even
believe she's correct, but I love that she dugs in the garden.
She riles people up. It's pretty funny. I like it. I like to
see people a little energetic. I like to see them freaking out
a little bit. It's It's good content, as they say. It's good
content.
>> The We are in this garden. Okay. And we're not getting
out of this garden uh with the feds narrative. We're just not
getting out of the garden with trying to >> ever miss an
opportunity to blame women. Well, I I see like a female thing,
but honestly, like that's the ovon right
Guys, guys, would you say that's content? So, you know what?
It's maybe not just a woman thing. Okay. >> Emotionally
manipulate us and say it's not this feels like CO, right? It's
not like COVID 19. It's like it's like Candace 19. It's another
fake it's a fake virus. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, this is true.
This is true. Listen, I don't agree with him. I just think
Listen, if it wasn't for Nick Fuentes, I wouldn't realize that
the mythology of the Holocaust has to be deconstructed, okay,
and understood. I wouldn't understand that. And now I do understand
that. So, hey, it's like, oh, you got infected. You just can't
do it. Six feet social distancing from Candace Owens. We're going
to get every influencer on social media. Six feet social distancing.
Save lives. What are you, a grandpa killer? What? You just don't
like what? And then Tim Tim's all fired up and she's a c-word.
People are going to die if you don't get this vaccine. And I'm
like, >> dude, this is this is what uh conservative well
poisoning is in 2025.
All my all my opponents are totally provaccine. All of my opponents
are actually I am the soy or sorry, I am the gigachad vax denier.
They are the soy vaccine enjoyers. Okay, Tim Pul, that guy's
like vaccinated. What a loser. Like I feel like maybe the government's
not telling us the truth. We're right back to that. But it's
Candace 19. It's Candace 19. That's what it is. And they think
that maybe if they put the little six feet social pads in the
grocery store that the SCP will win and make us believe that
this is like common sense is the virus.
I'm the common sense virus. It's coming around. It's so evil.
Stay at home. Wear a mask. Save lives. You don't want to catch
it. You don't want to catch the common sense, you guys. You don't
want to catch it. >> Okay. Do not do not do not do not
show this to Taylor Loren. Okay, I don't think Taylor Loren could
handle this right now with all the stuff going on. Nobody show
this to Taylor Loren. It would be incredibly [__]
up. Okay, she can't handle it. >> Anyways, um I dare. >> It's
a gift right there. >> I want to catch it. You don't want
to catch the common sense, you guys. Like like common sense is
the virus. >> It's coming for you. >> I'm the common
sense virus. It's coming around. It's so evil. Stay at home,
wear a mask, save lives. You don't want to catch it. You don't
want to catch the common sense, you guys. You don't want to catch
it. Anyways, um I dare. I'm sorry. I dare. And I have been very
careful cuz I wasn't sure what direction she was going to go
if she was like I was like look she's got a whole business that
she's got to figure out. There's a lot of people in her ear.
Maybe they like did this transition too quickly and she's just
like keeping her head like no. What she's saying is Turning Point
USA is untouchable. And it's a no from me. But you know me. I'm
I'm just out here uh saying what needs to be said. We'll be right
back after brief message from our sponsors. All right you guys
Owens. You guys, Candace 19 is crazy. Okay. I'm worried. You
trust the influencers. You know, people are in the chat saying,
"We need some Candace 19 merch." Yeah. Uh, don't go Max, get
the vax. That's what That's what Mark is saying. We should We'll
get We're going to get some gear for you guys. Don't go >> bro.
What's the sponsors? Like skincare stuff was the last time. What
is it this time? American Financing.net/owens.
You guys, Candace 19 is crazy. Okay. >> Skincare stuff.
I mean, I buy skincare. Listen, do I trust this to do some murder
investigation? No. Would I want to know her skincare routine?
Possibly.
>> Sure looks like she has a great skincare routine.
Maybe the one thing I could say she verifiably looks like she
has a good opinion on. I'm worried. You trust the influencers.
You know, people are in the chat. Hey, we need some Candace 19
merch. Yeah. Uh, don't go Max, get the Vax. That's what that's
what Mark is saying. We should We'll get We're going to get some
gear for you guys. Don't go Max, get the Vax. That's that's the
vibe right now. How many influencers is it going to take to get
everyone to roll up their sleeves and not go max? That's where
we're at right now. How many people do you have to send out to
tell them? Please, please do it. Wild. Okay, I didn't get a vac.
I didn't get the COVID 19 back. I'm not getting whatever the
heck this is. Okay. Uh which is honestly on his face federal
stupidity is what it is. Now, I can also tell you that because
my mommy sleuths there they're so fast before stuff even ends.
I I get tips about things and Erica literally today sat down
with Barry Weiss. and it's it's been marketed all over. They're
going to have this big sitdown, a conversation moderated by Barry.
It's going to feature voices from across the political spectrum.
They're going to talk about grief. And I got this email after
and it's interesting. >> Oh god.
The conversation moderated by Barry Weiss.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Feature voices from across the political spectrum. Talk
about grief. And I got this email after and it's >> this
is this is Barry Weiss's big break. This will prove Barry Weiss
isn't the most boring [__] on planet Earth. Okay,
she got her big break, a town hall with Erica Kirk. What incredible
content, guys. Oh my goodness. >> Interesting. They got
actually a couple of emails. I'm gonna read this one to you because
it was a town hallish event. Here's what they said went down.
This person writes, "I just came from the CVS, by the way, whoever
wrote this email. I love you. I just love all the mommy sleeves
that are this quickly that are this quick." They wrote, "I just
came from the CVS Times Erica Kirk Town Hall." And this is what
she said about the conspiracies and Candace one. Erica said she
was pregnant when the Egyptian planes were flying and following
her. So, she wasn't on them. She said she has photo proof. I'm
sorry.
Did I ever accuse Erica of being on Egyptian planes? When I found
the Egyptian planes, I was concerned that they were following
Charlie because I thought, "Wow, has there been a foreign government
that has been tracking his events like maybe I don't know like
running through the operation early and then we broughten it
broadened it when someone clue us into the fact that actually
these planes have been following Erica." You just heard Tarson
confirm that. Um,
I thought she'd be concerned. Instead, she's she's gonna tell
us on Saturday that she wasn't on the planes. I never said you
were on the planes. Why would I think you were on the Egyptian
planes? I don't like Well, that would be I don't think that you
took off and went to Wilmington, Delaware. I know you didn't
go to Wilmington, Delaware on day assassination. I find that
answer to be lacking. Okay, that is weird to me. It's a weird
answer to me ask questions. And >> that's like strange.
Now I just have more questions. >> By the way, you can
fly when you're pregnant. Even if you were on the plate, that's
a possibility when you're pregnant. So, I don't understand that
part at all. Um, two, when Barry asked her about the conspiracies
and what she had to say to those saying them, Erica said, "Stop."
No. Three, not about Candace, but she talked about Israel and
said good things about >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. That's
why I do the Tucker for her. I didn't say you were on planes.
What do you Who said you were on planes? Are you insane? Are
you Are you totally out of your mind? Nobody said anything about
planes.
>> How TP USA is having Shabbat dinner. No, this I didn't
read that before I went live at fast. Okay.
Okay, you guys, I want you to know
>> the person thought that was very important to include
and Candace was like, "Oh, that's giving away a little bit more
about the audience than I want to." Not about Candace, but she
talked about Israel and said good things about and how TPS is
having a Shabbat dinner at Amfest.
This Sorry. Okay.
Okay. You guys, I want you to know
in addition to the fact that Charlie in the last couple of days
wanted people to know that Mikey is fantastic and super califragilistic
ispidocious and he had this whole vision and that Rob McCoy was
his favorite pastor. Um, and that you should buy Josh Hammer's
book. He also wants you to know to just be a I think but we get
it. We get it. Those are his last words. Okay. Uh, we get it.
Just
Okay. Okay.
Anyways, moving on from that. >> Just be
a And with that guys, I think that's it for the stream. Thank
you for being here. Eight and a half hours today. Let's go. W
stream. Thanks everybody for being here. Thank you for the donations.
Huge stream today. All right. Thank you guys very much. Be back
tomorrow.